okay 9:00 amm uh going to open up the
house election law uh public hearings um
representative rapor why don't you lead
today
okay okay uh going to open up the public
hearing on cacr 19 relating to
redistricting providing that an
independent Rising commission shall be
established to draw boundaries for state
and federal Offices
um representative Shu did I pronounce
your name correctly uh you are
recognized to introduce cacr
thank you Mr chair and members of
election law um for the record my name
is Diane Shu I represent the town of
Pembrook which is the entire District of
marac
12 um My Little speech here kind of
tells you that my town is lucky right
now because it's the only town that
compr prises marac 12 however I think
we're all aware that a lot of towns get
coupled with other towns through
redistricting that they have very little
in common with and one of the reasons
that I've been following this process to
try and get non-bias R districting Done
is so that we can overcome that and have
a little bit more common sense I hope in
the districts that we put forward and
that we all get elected from um that
concept is what prompted me to introduce
two previous
cacs uh cacr 9 in 2019 and 20 which
missed reaching the necessary 2third
vote to pass the house by five votes so
we came
close then I introduced a companion bill
in CA in 2021 cacr 4 which ended up just
dying in the midst of the
pandemic um I still do believe however
that a large majority of the voters
around the granite state want to see
Fair nonbiased
redistricting that doesn't favor either
party uh particularly with the large
number of Undeclared voters that we have
um so that's why I have introduced cacr
19 uh to have redistricting done by a
commission that is as unbiased as
possible rather than by sitting
legislators so I present to you cacr
19 uh I hope that we can get this done
to let the voters voices come through
let them vote on this if we can pass a
cacr that's what happens the voters get
to vote on the
question um that's about all that I have
uh if there are any questions I will try
to answer them I will tell you if there
are technical questions uh one of my
co-sponsors who's a member of your
committee helped me craft the more
technical uh setup in the bill and she
would probably be better uh able to
answer technical
questions okay are there questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you
representative Shu next up is our own
you um good
morning uh for the record my name is
Connie Lane I'm a representative of
marac 16 which is conquered ward two um
so our as you just heard from
representative Shu our existing system
of redistricting does not not result in
districts that fairly represent voters
nationally both parties have drawn lines
that favor their own party and have done
so for decades um both parties are
guilty of protecting and expanding their
power through
redistricting and our constituents know
it and they're not happy about it for
anybody who attended the redistricting
hearings that we had two years ago you
should know that I don't think anyone
spoke in favor of the maps that we ended
up with Jam manderin discourages
participation in our constitutional
democracy and makes our constituents
jaded and S and cynical because they
feel like why vote if the outcome's
already determined for these reasons we
need to change our system to make it
more transparent and less political we
may never be able to remove politics
totally from redistricting but we
certainly owe it to our constituents and
our constitutional democracy to try to
reduce its impact remember that we took
an oath to represent all of our
constituents not just those who are in
our party we owe it to all of them to do
the best job we can to be fair and how
we create districts this Constitutional
Amendment establishes an independent
redistricting commission to create new
districts every 10 years it's similar to
the bill that we heard earlier um hb4
1426 it will help us achieve a fairer
redistricting process than the one that
we have now it's designed so that the
voters draw the lines not the leaders of
our parties the purpose of the
commission is to make the registering
process more transparent because it's
done in public and impartial by
establishing standards for who can serve
on the commission and criteria that must
be followed when drawing the maps
for those of you who hesitated about the
previous redistricting bill because the
legislature did not have final authority
over the maps this is your solution it
will change the Constitution that will
allow the commission to do so it amends
it amends the
Constitution these are the critical
factors in the bill the commission is
not evenly split between Democrats and
Republicans it includes independent
members not affiliated with either party
this helps prevent deadlock the
commission has binding authority to
implement the new District Lines
independent of the legislature and
members of the commission cannot be
current elected officials so none of us
recently retired politicians or
political
appointees and they are not appointed by
officials the amendment does not choose
commission members as was done in
previous bills that have been before the
house um they are not chosen by the
leadership um they are chosen by judges
selected by the Secretary of State while
the process seems burdensome it actually
worked and Colorado which is what the
bill is based on um and it accomplishes
a selection of balanced as non-political
Commissioners as we can get that will
draw Fair Maps is it perfect no is it
better than what we have now I think so
because the selection process dilutes
the political
incentives there are about 20 states
with sometime some type of redistricting
in place and not all of them have worked
smoothly as pointed out recently by
chairman Barry when we were in the isec
session for hb1
1426 the redistricting Commission in
Michigan violates the voter's Rights Act
and has been ordered to withdraw the
districts around Detroit for those of
you familiar with redistricting terms
they cracked Detroit in other words they
sliced it up into multiple districts
rather than pack it in which is what
they had done in the past but before we
dismiss the concept of an independent
commission based on this one fuxa by the
Michigan Commissioners it was their
first time doing this remember how many
times has have our Maps been challenged
at Le my in my memory at least for three
different decades and how many times
have other States maps drawn under
something similar to what we do have
been challenged it's innumerable I
didn't try to add them all up but it's
quite a bit do not be too quick to
dismiss a commission simply because it
is not perfect our current system is
more flawed interestingly though the
Michigan commission Drew maps that made
for more competitive races across the
state and their experience this time
around will inform their work in 2031
now is the time to change our
redistricting process none of us know
what party might not be either one of
ours uh will be in power in 2030 so this
offers an alternative to both parties to
establish a neutral process that
benefits our constituents and assures us
that the other party will not be drawing
lines favoring itself um as an added
note I have two sections of the bill
that need to be amended um on page one
line 26 and and I I'll give this out to
people on on page one line 26 the last
word should be zero not one and on page
eight the last two words on line seven
through the first six words on line 10
should be deleted and replaced with
language that makes it clear that to
approve a map the commission must have
five votes which includes at least one
Democrat one Republican and one
independent thank you we
for questions all right that that
question yes representative
weing thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question good morning good
morning um you mentioned that it made
the races more competitive is that the
goal of the redistricting transparent
and more fair yes more
competitive that's how they use the term
in other words they they're no longer
strongholds for red or blue they're
evenly divided by certain criteria that
they did and that's why they ran into
trouble in just in Detroit um
so okay thank
you representative Raptor um just a
question would this make it more likely
that towns that have sufficient
population to that are entitled to their
result further
questions seeing none thank you
Hatcher pH Hatcher from
Dober I was a member of the technical
team for the mapathon citizen
redistricting project I need to start by
correcting some thisinformation from the
executive session on hb1
1426 mapathon project is not suing
anyone instead the cities of do and
Rochester after reviewing the New
Hampshire house Maps drawn by the mapon
team and the underlying supporting data
decided after public debate and votes in
their City councils to bring a case
challenging the constitutionality of the
maps approved by the legislature and
signed by the governor this case is not
about partisanship it's strictly about
the proper interpretation of a sentence
inserted into the New Hampshire
Constitution by 2006 Amendment Dober
Rochester found our Maps compelling
because they were developed with full
transparency the criteria we used was
are available on the project
website during the hb1 1426 executive
session we were also criticized for our
choice for the Congressional map but
actually if you do not like our
conclusion you really should critique
our transparent criteria and clearly
State your own criteria so the public
can evaluate them both and reach their
own
conclusions transparency really is the
key people claim that redistricting is
inherently a political process
but if transparent criteria are agreed
upon and are used to evaluate any
proposed map then redistricting for
partisan Advantage can be largely
eliminated people say that redistricting
Commissions in other states have had
disastrous effects because the
legislators have ignored and overrode
the work of the commission but in New
Hampshire redistricting input and
questions from the public are routinely
ignored is this not a disaster too
people say that redistricting must be
done by the legislature because it is
closest to the people and therefore can
be better held accountable for its
work but in fact partisan Jerry
mandering has largely eliminated any
accountability most New Hampshire
Representatives do not face any
challenge in the primary election and
only token opposition in the general
election people also talk about Judges
being emboldened to get involved in
redistricting but my reading of the
risting decisions tells me that judges
are in fact very reluctant to get
involved only do so when the
redistricting process breaks down
usually because of a lack of agreement
between the governor and the
legislature I think the judges would be
very happy if the legislature and the
governor could agree on a process that
would actually succeed more
often this is not really a partisan
issue with the Republicans in the
majority right now they are taking
criticism for their redistricting
decisions and for their anticipate
towards establishing a commission but in
2009 and 2010 the Democrats controlled
all the levers and they did not enact a
commission or any other reform they
deserve criticism for this failure in
addition survey results consistently
indicate that solid majorities of Voters
of both parties dislike partisan
gerrymandering if you doubt these
results then put your money where your
mouth is and approve crcr 19 and let's
see whether the voters really do want
reform finally I believe in 50 years
people will look back on this time in
tense part of ship combined with the
development of powerful technology to
enable extreme G gerrymandering and
wonder why did it take us so long to fix
this problem with our democracy why were
politicians so entrenched and so
reluctant to actually have to compete
for their seats thank you very much we
be taking questions sure are there
questions from the committee seeing none
Bundy
there we go good morning chairman Barry
and members of house election law my
name is Linda Bundy and I live in
antrum I support cacr 19 the
Constitutional Amendment concurrent
resolution to establish an independent
redistricting commission to draw the
boundaries for state and federal
elections our current process for
redistricting resulted in gerrymandered
maps being drawn after the 2020 census
the most notable examples are our New
Hampshire Senate maps and the maps for
executive
councel the this Constitutional
Amendment removes the drawing of the
maps from the legislator and places that
responsibility with an independent
commission members of the commission are
New Hampshire residents of two years or
more who have not held specified offices
at the federal or state level for 10 or
more
years the process requires public input
and support from Democrats Republicans
and Undeclared voters there are clear
guidelines for drawing districts cacr 19
will create a more transparent process
and eliminate undue political influence
in the creation of districts elections
will be more competitive and it will be
the voters who will determine the
outcomes rather than the politicians who
drew the maps I ask that you vote ought
to pass on CAC
r19 thank you okay will you be taking
questions Miss Bundy no no questions all
right next up is Liz tanelli from the
Hampshire
good morning thank you for this
opportunity my name is Liz tentarelli
I'm from Newbury I'm here representing
the League of Women Voters of New
Hampshire and despite some comments from
uh an earlier executive session we are a
nonpartisan
organization we support NE party and
when it comes to redistricting we know
that whichever party is in power is the
one that will benefit from drawing the
maps and we've seen that in other states
and it all depends on how strongly you
feel about that your chances in
2030 your party's chances whether or not
you want the legislature to draw the
maps or a citizen's commission I'm going
to to argue a little differently though
I recently was speaking with the leader
of common cause in
Ohio and they have made some legislative
attempts in recent years to reduce
partisan gerrymandering and they were
not successful because ultimately the
legislature uh drew the maps they wanted
now the citizens of Ohio are gathering
400,000 signatures around the state in
order to get get a constitutional
amendment on their November ballot and
they're well on their way to achieving
that they want to put the power of
drawing the maps back into the hands of
the people through an independent
commission now we of course don't allow
ballot referenda in New Hampshire and
for the most part I'm happy about that
but you the committee and the
legislature have the ability to do the
same thing here that is let's support
for fair Maps be decided by the people
via the ballot so whether you support an
independent redistricting commission
with the power to make a decision uh or
you believe that only the legislators
are capable of doing
this I don't think that's the issue
today the issue is whether you have the
courage to put that matter before the
voters in November and you can do that
r19 I will take questions if there are
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
langle good morning I have with me an
unfortunate amount of paper because my
bus is ill so I'm going to pass that
around after that way there's not
shuffling and I know representative
Barry is not the biggest fan of that
so of course so um I'm gonna take this
opportunity oh for the record my name is
Katherine LEL and I am 20 years old from
conquered New Hampshire I'm serving as
open democracy and open democracy
actions public policy fellow and I'm a
student currently at St Ansel College um
a political Hub and also one of the hubs
for talking about redistricting and
learning about it and talking about it
in a nonpartisan manner um I'm going to
take this o opportunity to Echo what
many many people behind me said about um
opportunities to represent um your
voters and your constituents as opposed
to just those members of your party um
in addition to um let's
see yes so the Brennon Center for
justice states that done right
redistricting is a chance to create maps
that in the words of John Adams are an
exact portrait a miniature of the people
as a whole so historically New Hampshire
has called like special committees and
every 10 years you'll redraw these lines
the um and it's Party leaders who have
this huge say um an independent
redistricting committee would ensure
protections from partisan J
gerrymandering efforts um encouraging
all New Hampshire voter
uh to be heard regardless of party
affiliation and I'm going to just Echo
these lovely people behind me and move
on thank you perfect will be taking
questions absolutely are there questions
no and thank you for not passing out
your written testimony during I really
actually genuinely you I've said it
before that is a huge pet peeve of mine
thank you for recognizing that of course
that goes miles for your case Believe It
or Not way more amicable uh last up is
Mara
Chapel
yes
hi I feel like longtime caller first
time no longtime listener firsttime
caller you've all gotten emails from me
over the past few years my name is Mora
andette Chappelle and um forgive me I
wrote it in the back I wasn't even
certain I was going to make it to conin
today I don't represent any anyone I
call myself the self-appointed
representative of coaz County as a whole
um so I support the bill I'm torn
between trying to be on the commission
or running for Coos 7 which was my
original intent because now I can't do
both but that's how much this matters to
me I live in Jefferson which is now part
of Co 7 The floal District that attaches
Jefferson to Berlin through a set of
woods we don't we I have to drive 35 to
40 minutes through two towns to get to
it we have zero to do with each other
um some Representatives after the maps
were drawn and I complained bragged to
me that they deliberately gered the map
so that Jefferson would be with Berlin
because they foolishly believed that the
conservative town of 1,000 and that's an
exaggeration because our tourists our
vacationers um registered there too um
that the town of 1000 would outweigh the
88,200 people in Berlin that's not going
to happen that doesn't count the
prisoners um even with the addition of
Whitefield and Twin Mountain to the map
after that um to the even with the
addition of Whitefield and Twin Mountain
to Jefferson the District of 88,200
people in Berlin still outweighed the
cumulative voot is in both of those
towns Berlin does not have woods so it
wasn't one-third of the city voting on
COA 7 it was the whole city outweighing
those three towns the redistricting
matters so much to me that I'm actively
seeking an apartment in Berlin so I can
win the two the Coos 7 seat Jefferson
and the small towns matter to me so much
that I'm willing to leave it to preserve
it also Al I support this bill because
I'm seeking representative and Senator
support to change that Senate and
executive councils be by County instead
of
apportionment right now Coos County is
essentially unrepresented in both our
towns Bridges and mountains are used on
New Hampshire promotional materials but
with the mere nine reps we have because
of our small population which I'm happy
to maintain that low number the Senators
and executive counselors are more
focused on the more populous Carol and
Grafton counties we have very little say
in the state house so almost no voice in
life okay will you be taking questions
from the committee sure are there
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you um I don't have anyone else
signed to speak anenberg can you pass
you that blue sheet and I should have uh
should have had the online submission up
so I apologize for that not on my
game
um
cacr uh okay and the blue sheet is blank
there's no one signed up uh either for
or against that didn't speak uh cacr 19
online had 241 in support and five
opposed with that I will close the
public hearing on CAC r19 and open the
public hearing on House Bill
1098 um relative to ball delivered to
care facilities I don't have a pink card
for anyone to introduce this bill do we
1098 I
can you want me to go get him um you
want ince if you could representative do
us the favor because we do have a tight
schedule today uh I will give
representative Edwards the opportunity
to speak if he comes in later so what
will happen is introduce the bill um
we'll conduct the public hearing hearing
I'll recess the public hearing so that
if he does come in afterwards we can
give him the opportunity to speak thank
you for taking the opp thank you for
introducing a house bill 1098 excellent
um for the record my name is uh Tim kale
representative Tim kale from from
Raymond and I'm here today to introduce
House Bill 1098 relative to ballots
delivered to Elder Care
Facilities um and I spoke to
representative Edwards and he saw this
as a way
to add some oversight and an ability for
people to report any IR
irregularities if in um regarding bouts
being delivered to these facilities and
uh that's all I have to say okay and I
take it you won't you won't be doing the
questions or I could I could attempt to
answer a question if someone had a
question all right do we have questions
seeing none thank you representative oh
I'm sorry I apologize representative
weary wishes to ask a
question uh thank you chair Mr chair and
um thank you for taking my question so
would there be
handled AB so deliver absentee ballots
and would there be some sort
of uh certification or affidavit
associated with the proper
identification of personnel or people in
the in the uh facility um I I don't know
the answer to that question what I do
see is that on line five persons
authorized in this section shall ensure
the process of receiving and marking so
it's this is just about I think
overseeing the
process of
okay thank you thank you yes
representative Hamlet I I will remind
the committee um the the representative
is being kind enough to introduce the
bill so let's uh let's not let's not
throw too many hard
balls okay uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
don't we do this
already uh I believe in the city of
Portsmouth we the clerk goes to the
various nursing homes maybe we're doing
it illegally um that that may be true I
I don't believe that in my town we have
someone doing this so I was kind of
intrigued by this um you know we have we
have an elder population and anything we
can do to ease the access of voting for
our elders so that they can vot I think
I see it as a good thing okay thank you
further questions from the committee
saying none thank you and thank you
representative for introducing the bill
um next up we will do uh SL Sloan
buckton I'm having trouble reading the
tried am I on yeah sorry about that
that's that's my hand writing it's Susan
buckon and I am the state long-term care
Ombudsman um thank you for allowing me
to speak this morning um I was here last
year as well on this bill and I'm here
again this year to oppose it the
long-term care on budsman is an older
older Americans act program and we
represent the rights of individuals who
live in long-term care um and the reason
that I oppose this is because it it
seems to place an unne necessary burden
on those living in long-term care and
also for the municipal voting Personnel
to process ballots for those
individuals there are several reasons
that individuals who reside in um
long-term care facilities need to be
able to request absentee ballots they
are um related to usually either their
short-term Rehabilitation and they don't
have a way to get to the polling place
or unable
or they have um ambulation or care needs
that make it difficult for them to
access their polling
place so within RSA
65717 there's
already um a process for individuals to
request an absentee ballot and to sign
the a you know if they need assistance
for someone to sign the affidavit that
they have assisted them um this language
seems a little confusing because it
seems to add an additional burden
whereby the town clerk would have to
process the absentee ballot and I would
remind you all that we have uh 78
nursing homes and 143 assisted living
facilities in New Hampshire with
approximately 14,000
residents so I you know I selected one
town to highlight which is Dover which
has eight assisted living homes homes
and three nursing homes with a total of
875 residents so I'm not sure how this
process would work for the town clerk to
have to process those absentee ballots
when we already have a system in place
for individuals to vote by absentee
ballot I'm happy to answer any
questions um yes representative
Burnham thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um are you aware
of approximately how many long-term
residents do request absentee ballots I
don't I don't I don't know that we have
any
way I will tell you that our office um
gets out and reminds facilities every
year you know we're we're kind of
gearing up now to to talk to facilities
to remind them that they may have
individuals living that in their
facility that want to vote by absentee
ballot so um I think I think it's
important that we're increasing their
access and not hindering
it further questions from the committee
representative
quae thank you Mr chairman and and thank
you for taking my question uh you
mentioned long-term care facilities and
nursing homes and and just a moment ago
you also mentioned assisted living
facilities our assisting our assisted
living facilities classified as
long-term care
facilities yes um and this Bill calls
for Elder Care Facilities um I I prefer
to call them long-term care facilities
um being in that age group myself uh I
uh yes they would fall under the
definition followup please yep follow up
uh and on the same lines uh you said
175 uh long-term care facilities would
that include assisted living facilities
in that number there are 78 nursing
homes and 143 Assisted Living I'm sorry
I misremembered and that would include
the Assisted Living okay yep thank you
very much further questions from the
committee I'll I'll have I have I'm
confused on the objection because the
law says it may so it's not
requirement those language says may
deliver not shall so isn't this just
allowing another opportunity for vote I
think it's confusing
I I'm not sure I saw that it said May
um okay well we'll have a I think
there's no other question well have
Secretary of State scaning can come
maybe he can clarify fair enough I did
see that but I I'm not sure what the the
reason would be for that okay fair
enough well I I think I know somebody
who might
okay any other questions from the
committee all right sing none thank you
and next up is Secretary of State
scanland who uh after his testimony can
question thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm David scanland
Secretary of State I'm here in support
of this bill and have worked with
representative Edwards uh on this issue
for at least a couple of terms now um
there was a bill uh that that was taken
up it was either last session or the
session before that uh apparently was
deemed to be a little too complicated uh
in dealing with this situation and so it
uh uh obviously didn't pass so this is a
a kind of a milder version of what was
presented
before when we're talking about
individuals who live in nursing homes or
Elder Care Facilities they actually have
a choice of where they want to be
registered to vote they can either
remain registered from the community
that they lived in before they went to a
nursing home or an elder care facility
or they can decide to use the location
of the facility as their domicile uh
while they're living there so they have
a
choice that has caused some confusion in
the past when the clerks have
deputized uh uh or given the authority
to untrained individuals to go and
assist residents of these
facilities uh for the opportunity to
vote by absentee ballot they might take
an absentee registration they might take
an absentee application for an absentee
ballot um and then uh in some cases they
actually have the ballots with them and
can allow assist those voters if
necessary uh in in voting the problem
has come when it is found out after the
fact that one of the residents of this
facility has voted from the community
that they lived
in uh before they came they filled in an
application forgot about it and then
somebody goes to the facility and they
assist them in voting from that location
and that has been a problem it's
unfortunate because that's an illegal
situation when that occurs it's double
voting but at the same time you know
there there are memory issues involved
and you have to feel sympathetic to that
concern what this bill does simply is
just makes a statement that if a clerk
is going to provide the service of going
to an elder care facility or a nursing
home to allow residents there to vote by
absentee that the individuals that are
going there are properly trained so
they're either the clerk or they are an
assistant Clerk or they are a clerk
proem and not somebody that's simply
deputized maybe a you know a an employee
of the facility who may take their their
charge uh uh enthusiastically and end up
getting voters to vote uh innocently who
should not be uh partaking in that so
that's all this bill does and I would be
happy to try and answer any questions
okay uh we'll start off with Vice
chairman
bone thanks Mr chairman thank you taking
the question last year I believe we had
people testifying that their parent they
found out that their parents in the
nursing home had
voted yet they don't know how because
their parents weren't able to
and but somehow or another they got the
absentee ballot sent in and whatnot by
the nursing home would this help to
prevent that from happening I I believe
it would this is designed to just just
to help eliminate that
confusion further questions
representative
we uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
secretary for taking um my question um
so in
65717 Roman numeral 2 B and C it already
addresses residents of nursing homes and
Residential Care
Facilities should those sections be
adjusted with this new proposed
RSA I don't believe so representative
because this is simply addressing who
can uh fulfill the role of uh delivering
and assisting with the absentee ballots
as opposed to the actual process itself
okay thank you further questions from
the committee seeing none thank you
secretary scanland thank you next up
will be uh representative Edwards who
shall retroactively introduce the
bill
thank you Mr chair I'm sorry I'm late
I'm in finance simultaneously I
appreciate representative kahill
introducing the bill um I I wanted to to
point out that um this is the second
term in which a bill attempting to do
something similar uh has been proposed
uh this one uh feels like it's um more
narrowly written um it was drafted by uh
key leadership in the um Secretary of
State's office so I'm really confident
that technically it's a good
bill the motivation of this is much like
um the vice chair said it came to me
about four or five years ago I had
constituents in Auburn who were
absolutely livid uh when they found that
their mother uh who was in a nursing
home uh who had severe Alzheimer's or
denture I forget the diagnosis but she
was beyond the ability to act under her
own competency and they found out that
uh she had registered and voted and
voted absentee so this got them curious
and they looked at the previous election
two years earlier when she was also a
resident in the same condition at the
same nursing home and uh they found that
she had been registered and voted under
two similar but different names so she
cast two ballots in the previous uh
election cycle so um so their requests
to me and it seemed pretty reasonable
was um you know they don't know how the
vote was cast but they know that she had
very strong political feelings and that
they were upset that maybe somebody had
caused a vote contrary to the way she
had lived her life and so this is an
attempt uh to prevent a form of of elder
abuse I think it's elder abuse to take
somebody's vote from them and cast it
without them knowing so um I hope I hope
you look favorably at this bill it
doesn't do a lot it just starts to
impose a a little bit more guidance on
how these nursing home ballots ought to
be cast I'll take questions if there are
any okay other questions from the
committee uh representative Howard thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh so what type of education is
going to be provided to these long-term
living
facilities how much has been provided in
the past or how much would be provided
in the future uh provided now to prevent
uh any uh sort of Errors uh like you've
been discussing in your testimony if Mr
scanland I I'll I'll help I don't think
Bill addresses that at all this is about
allowing the clerk the assistant Clerk
and the clerk protim to deliver absentee
ballots uh and receive them in person I
don't believe there's any training in
fact the argument can be made that
there's no training materials actually
needed because these are the clerk the
assistant Clerk and the clerk protim y
um all right further questions thank you
all right seeing none thank you
representative Edwards go back to the
beautiful people in finance I made into
Finance jokes last week so I'm I'm
trying not to spend your money today so
thank you thank you we we some of us
appreciate that see what I did there I
did it um with that uh there's no other
um people there's no other cards oh
representative PR O'Brien yes I'm sorry
last one up our own
kpo
thank you for recognizing me Mr
chairman I I just want to quickly say
that I I support this bill we had a
similar uh Bill a few years ago uh that
I
sponsored and it was a little different
this one
enables the the um ballot Clerk's
assistant clerks or clerks proem to
deliver the ballots and I think that's a
good idea and there was a question from
representative Howard about
education uh for people at the nursing
home I think this one will help a lot it
will go a lot uh in in a positive
direction because I had an experience
where I was looking for a nursing home
for my mother-in-law and spoke to a lot
of people at nursing homes and this CA
this came up they the people that are at
the nursing homes sometimes feel they
don't have enough information and
education and they would like much more
guidance than they get because they want
to do a good job and and do everything
correctly so this would help a lot uh
and it's not it's not demanding that the
clerks do it sometimes there's a
situation of the County nursing home
being very far away from the town that
the person comes from and it it can be
difficult but uh this will help a lot so
um I think that that gives them the
option and if the people want their
clerks to do this they can discuss that
with them uh at at the local level okay
questions on the
I'll try seeing none thank you now now
we're done okay um got there's uh there
was three people signed up who didn't
speak two in favor
one oh I'm sorry nope there two people
signed up that didn't speak both in
favor um and then online there was six
in support 21 opposed one neutral uh
with that I will close the public
hearing on uh opposed was
21 um with that I'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 1098 and the
9:50
okay it's 10:50 so 9:50 excuse me so
we're back going to open the public
hearing on House Bill
1200 relative to
controlled and secured storage of
printed paper
ballots um I'll recognize representative
Wei for the purpose of introduction of
the
Bill thank you Mr chair and honorable
committee members for the record my name
is Robert warry and I have the privilege
of serving in Hillsboro County's 13th
District the great town of Hudson which
is also home to the last high school in
the United States having an active dairy
farm on
campus um all
right so um the findings in this bill
speak to the high public confidence in
the Safety and Security of New Hampshire
elections because of the use of paper
ballots therefore efforts should be
maintained or effort should be made to
maintain those printed ballots in a
secure manner from their creation
through their disposal after the proper
retention period and this venerable
election law committee has also heard
about the already wellestablished
controls for counting the ballots and
most of the committee has witnessed the
diligent verification process that
moderators go through to ensure an
accurate count of ballots uh received at
the various towns and City Wards the
committee also heard in last week's
testimony on HP
1134 that an unknown quantity of over
overrun ballots are necessarily
generated by the very nature of the
printing and cutting process and an
accurate count of overrun ballots
retained at the printers is not
currently required so um various
Industries already use controls for the
secured storage of printed materials for
the Safety and Security of their product
the implementation of additional
controls uh for the storage of printed
election ballot shouldn't be an arduous
or agre just uh task and request there
um and it should uh continue to bolster
the public confidence and the Safety and
Security of New Hampshire elections just
to briefly outline the bill section one
pertains to a controlled and secured
area as report by secretary scanland
this already exists and therefore this
merely codifies current practice section
two uh pertains to authorized access it
probably does need an amendment uh
somehow um it was restricted two
employees I don't think that was the
original intent when I wrote it but uh I
I missed that in the review of that so
my bad um section three pertains to a
record of authorized access as granted
under section two section four pertains
to an inventory of all ballots and the
handling of ballots spoiled at the
printer section five pertains to
maintaining the security of the printed
ballots section six pertains to
maintaining an inventory after Printing
and distribution and section seven is
the transfer of the printed printing
records being transferred to the
Secretary of State's office as a record
for an extended period of time following
the election Section 8 creates a
requirement for a video surveillance as
a record of the maintained security for
the facility surveillance cameras are
not prohibitively expensive a single
installation of a camera is in the range
of $3,000 so if you estimate such
installations at a printer it might be a
baseline cost of
15,000 which is probably not that much
in the overall scheme of ballot printing
costs some costs would be in incurred
for ongoing maintenance but these would
be a fraction of the estimated startup
cost so as I said before I think an
amendment is of section two in
particular is necessary um but uh th
those end my introductory comments here
I'm happy to take question questions the
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative weie um next up will be
Hennessy good morning ER everyone Aaron
Hennessy deputy secretary of state um I
just want to reiterate uh secretary
scan's invitation that he gave to your
this committee last week to come and
visit our the printing process um at the
printer and um with with the
accompaniment of our office of course um
so that you can see for yourself um the
Safety and Security that our office um
takes to ensure that our ballots are
fully secure the entire time from the
purchase of the paper through to the
printing of the ballots through to the
shipping of the ballots
through to the record retention of all
election materials for uh the required
legal time period after the
election
um as secretary scanland pointed
testified to last week we take the
security very seriously um we use a
secured facility um that is um takes the
security of the materials that they have
in their possession uh very serious ly
uh we do have some concerns with some of
the language in this bill that is
written um some of it has to do with the
actual printing process um for example
when paper is printed on um the ink has
to cure on that actual paper and that
takes time sometimes depending on the
humidity or atmospheric conditions in
the room um it can be a shorter amount
of time sometimes it could take up to 24
hours so when that happens that material
is secure on the printing floor of the
facility um and I'm happy to show you
this again if um you'd like to come and
take a tour so some of the language in
here um kind of micromanages the process
our office believes that we do have a
secure process that the materials are
under um are very secure the entire time
from when we deliver the print the blank
materials to the office to when we um
ship all of the ballots out to when we
ask the printer to destroy all of the
election materials uh this bill also
calls for um I forget the language it
uses but somewhat immediate destruction
of materials that were um printed
incorrectly in the printing process the
printer needs to warm up so for each
batch that goes through there's going to
be some light Printing and our um our
office has always taken the stance that
we do not want those materials destroyed
and recycled until after after the
election um just in case someone were to
come across a batch of
shredded uh ballots um before the
election happens there might be some um
questions that come up publicly so we
would like to maintain all of that uh
those materials within the secure
printer until after the election is over
um I think that's all the comments I
have on this bill I'm happy to take
questions okay uh questions from the
committee representative wood
thank you Mr chair thank you deputy
secretary um I think you started
answering my questions there are some
things in here that you feel are
excessive uh you said micromanage but
yes micromanage thank you yeah but um I
don't want to put words in your mouth
are there pieces in here that you
wouldn't want
codified thank you for the question
um I would have to get you the exact
pieces that I wouldn't get would would
not like to see codified but anything
around the curing of the ballots and
where they can be located um anything
that would require 24-hour um person to
be watching those ballots as they cure
the additional language as to um the
shredding of the materials or um
destruction of the materials and when
that occur occurs um as I said I think
that our office does a a great job right
now ensuring the security of our ballots
um so I'm not quite sure that this
language is
necessary yep follow thank you for
answer I what about the video
surveillance what's your thoughts on
that I would have to talk to the vendor
I believe that they may already have
external video surveillance but I'm not
positive that of that we've never asked
to see it um because when none of the
materials leave the building unless they
are shipped by our employees um but as
far as putting video surveillance in a
private company um that might be an
issue for a private um employer in the
state that would be right to
knowable for questions from the
committee representative Lane um in the
kind of opposite thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question kind of
the flip side of what you would want
eliminated this is very strictly out
line so I'm thinking when in two two to
what happens in two to three years when
maybe something new to provide security
that your office wants to do would it
then be prohibited by this narrow the
more narrow language it's kind of the
flip side yeah thank you for that
question um and as a lawyer I'm sure
that you you can write that much better
than I can in Statue but there may be
some issues for that so thank you for
bringing that up I appreciate that
further questions seeing none thank you
deputy secretary um I don't believe I
have any other pink cards in my
possession unless I'm missing some
representan did I miss you hold on no
he's not on he's on another bill okay
himan we're on House Bill 1200 are you
speaking to House Bill 1200 or
1569 okay no worries um okay with that
um can I get the blue sheet please and
online of course my computer screen just
turned f
after uh we're not going to be hearing
your 15 wait are you talking are you so
you want to speak to 1200 I me I wrote
down the wrong number so my apologies
okay no no worries I'll just correct the
card that you're recogniz so you're okay
if I correct your card to 12200 you
don't want to speak to
1569 15 not yet yeah that's not coming
up until much later anyways okay you
recognized representative organ thank
you I'm representing Timothy Oregon from
straford County District 10 which is the
town of Durham um also of course famous
for being the home of the University of
New Hampshire and um so I just uh want
to very quickly say I think this bill is
unnecessary um I agree with what deputy
secretary Hennessy said that they
already have uh sufficient controls over
this process I know I mean I know it's
no fun losing an election I've actually
personally never lost an election not
yet I did have one that um ended up
winning a recount by four votes so you
do always wonder how how could that
happen and one of the ways you think is
like oh were there a bunch of like
fraudulent ballots somehow snuck into
the process um so I understand where
people are coming from but I think
there's sufficient controls and if for
some reason somebody
did what steal a bunch of ballots and
like or fraudulently print up their own
ballots or whatever um I think that
would be caught because uh we track
everybody who comes into the polling
place and then we track the number of
ballots that uh that go through the
ballot box or those are done as right
and site I'm not sure what this adds to
the process um also I also like to use
one of our favorite Expressions around
here unfunded mandate so this is an
unfunded mandate I mean it does have a
fiscal note but the fiscal note doesn't
say who's going to pay for it or how or
how much it's going to cost it's going
to be a significant amount of money and
um and also it doesn't account for uh
so-called uocava ballots which are
people who live overseas but can still
vote in federal elections I guess you
all I don't know why I'm telling you
guys this you're the subject matter
experts but doesn't account for the U
coma ballots also I see some U several
guide dogs in the humans um there is
a the polling places have uh those um
handicapped uh handicapped uh voting
stations which B basically um you um
would basically print up a ballot for a
person who's unable to read or fill out
a you know a standard ballot so it
doesn't say anything about those either
so I I just think uh I think this I
think this bill is unnecessary I think
you know we already count what goes we
already like have exact count of who
shows up at the polling place or um
request an absente ballot we account we
account for everybody who sends in an
ballot and we account for all the
ballots that go through the counting
process so I think this just creates
more suspicion and more expense and uh
so I think we should trust the Secretary
of State's office which does an
excellent job of overseeing Elections to
continue to do this so this is uh so
dist the phrase unfunded mandate I guess
I'll also go ahead and use another
favorite expression we hear at the State
House a solution in search of a problem
so I would just say it's bills uh so I
think this Bill uh should be in
expedient to legislate so thanks okay we
other questions from the committee sure
whether I can answer them or not I don't
know but yes seeing seeing none thank
you and I don't have anyone else to
speak after that um there were two
people on the blue sheet that did not
speak both signed up against online
there were 12 in support and 16 in
opposition with that I'll be closing the
public hearing for House Bill 1200 the
committee will stand in recess until
I
okay it is 10:15 I'm going to open the
public hearing on House Bill
1264 um we have quite a few number of
people signed up to speak speak on this
bill um so for the many of them are new
to the election law committee so what I
do in these situations is I always have
an order in which I go so the first
thing is I let the state reps go first
the sponsor obviously goes first then I
usually let the Secretary of State go
first or any other um person here from a
department um and then I always as I say
I make the lobbyist go last because they
get paid to be here um so the way what
I'm going to do is the state reps that
are signed up to speak and the uh
Secretary of State's office and members
of the general public uh you will go
first and you will not have a time limit
um because there are nearly 10 lobbyists
signed up to speak of this my lobbyists
are going to be limited to two minutes
each um because I imagine much of it
will be duplicative um but the people
that are not paid to be here that came
here on their own time I want to respect
you um and give you as much time as you
wish so with that um I'm going to I
believe uh representative Paige are you
going to introduce the bill all right
representative page is recognized for
the purpose of introduction of House
Bill 1260 four thank you Mr chair and
thank you members of the committee sorry
let me read the title real fast I
apologize House Bill 1264 FN relative to
the definition of accessible voting
systems I apologize represent thank you
thanks thank you uh Mr chair and thanks
members of the committee um I guess in
an
unusual move for a political person I
will try to be
brief so I will keep it as this is a
pretty simple bill um in essence it
requires that uh well let me back up
under the current situation with voting
in our state um people who have visual
impairments or print disabilities uh
have the use of assistive technology
which is really a lowcost low Tech uh
device it's basically a tablet that's
got headphones connected to a printer
and you may have seen these in the
polling places um but you would only see
them in state and federal elections you
would not generally see them but for two
towns in Municipal elections so so when
I told reps this um this sort of a heads
scratch uh why is it that we don't have
them for Municipal elections um and for
those of you who did the uh there's a
future in sight uh Randy Pierce is here
who did a a lunch for the Reps in the
cafeteria he had a a machine that
demonstrates this and other folks will
talk about that but basically what this
bill attempts to resolve is that issue
where people who are visually impaired
or have print disabilities do not have
use of this lowcost low tech technology
for Municipal elections and I know
everyone on this committee and everyone
in this body uh takes quite seriously
the secrecy of the ballot uh that is
fundamental to our right and we don't
need to go in and on about that so what
this bill does is it resolves that and
it requires that those devices be
available uh for municiple
elections and I think that aligns us
with our constitutional obligation under
state constitution and aligns us um also
puts us in line with federal disability
law the
Ada um requires this and Conquer for
example is under a consent decree or a
settlement agreement with the Department
of Justice because they were under the
threat of a lawsuit because they weren't
providing this they do now exiter
voluntarily does it but to my knowledge
those are the only two that provide
these devices who can people will talk
more about what that looks like what
those devices are about uh behind me
but so so not only do we protect the
secrecy and privacy and Independence of
someone being able to cast their
ballot by using the machines in
Municipal elections we would be avoiding
some unfortunate situation for a
municipality who's going to be sued
under the Ada and ultimately be required
to have to use these machines in any
event these are lowcost machines you
know anywhere from 1700 to 2500 I've
seen I'll let others testify to that um
then they're programmed um they are
provided right now by the Secretary of
State's office for state and federal
elections but again um they're not in
the Municipal elections so this bill
would would Rectify that
um I I I think that's that's in essence
what this would do I I I it's pretty
simple but it's pretty important I think
we could all agree
that the current situation in a
municipal election where someone has to
tell someone who they're voting for and
rely on that person to fill the right
oval or whatever it is even if it's your
best friend or or you're the clerk
there's something wrong about that and
this bill would solve that problem so
I'm happy to take questions there's a
line of folks that are far more informed
than I am on this but yeah other
questions from the committee
representative Howard thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
uh under the way that this uh
legislation is written it states that
every city and every town which has
adopted an official ballot system as
provided in RSA 6692 or RSA
66913 uh does that mean that in towns
that have not adopted uh an accessible
uh ballot system uh that they wouldn't
be subject to this
legislation well my understanding is
that every town and municipality would
be subject to it in terms of the um
alignment with the statutory framework
to ensure that um you know I I think
that that's the intent um the Secretary
of I did have a brief conversation with
Secretary of State's office about um
some statutory alignment which seems to
be to to make sure that this would also
be applicable for uh uh School U
elections and things like that so that
seemed like a minor and I I'm not
speaking for him and I I think deput
Secretary of State Hennessy is going to
testify but something that can be
cleaned up with an amendment um all this
bill does is just take what we're doing
at the state and federal level with the
machines at the secretary States has now
and and requires municipalities to do
the same okay thank you further
questions from the
committee seeing none n I'm sorry
representative qu I missed you thank you
Mr chairman and and thank you
representative uh um first of all I
absolutely agree on the importance of
the secret ballot it's one of our
fundamental requirements no question
about that but I have kind of a detailed
question on page two line
10 talks about uh accessible voting
system that enables all individuals with
disabilities to vote without the Need
For
assistance uh how do we ensure that
there people with varying levels of
disability of course and they all
deserve cons the ability to do that
but depositing you know conveying the
ballot to the The Ballot Box or the vote
accounting machine is part of voting and
so would this prohibit some someone from
assisting a voter who Maybe Can't convey
that ballot on their own to The Ballot
Box would it help would it prohibit
someone from you know an official from
conveying the ballot for them thank you
sure I mean I'm I mean I'm not sure that
we could game out every scenario but I
appreciate the question first of all
thank you and
um you know I think um the intent at
least with respect to this law this bill
would simp simply be within the context
of using the assisted technology machine
to ensure that there's privacy in terms
of conveyance of the ballot to the
machine is that like you know I'm
walking to the machine with it um well I
I would presume that under the Ada some
if that would be a reasonable
accommodation to to help someone that
would probably be permitted um I I can
tell you that uh you know I use the
machine in the most recent
primary and it it's terrific it just it
is the ballot it prints it out and I you
know put it into the ballot machine just
like uh as I've been behind the without
assistance so um one one thing I do want
to make mention of real quick is and
this is unrelated so I is that the new
new uh New Hampshire Municipal
associations are open to they're they're
this is a bipartisan Bill uh right and
and it's also got the support of the
municipal Association among many others
um and they're open to um footing some
of the bill in terms of the programming
costs on this which you which because it
goes to the the vendor and they make
sure it's you know in line with what you
wanted on your ballot
so representative
Lane uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking the question
um why does from your understanding why
does the Secretary of State not provide
them for Municipal
elections and I may have a follow
up yeah I I will ask the same question
of the Secretary of State
yeah so I certainly they can speak for
that I can say that I've had meetings
with the Secretary of State as as the
interest groups that are involved in
this have as well and so I'll just speak
from my perspective about their
perspective and that I think is there
seems to be some um hesitation with
respect to uh Manpower if you will uh
being able to turn around some of the
machines between um like the primary in
January and a municipal election March
do they have the staff to reprogram wipe
the machines clean from the last
election reprogram and then send them
out I I think the good news on that is a
we have the machines um the number of uh
towns that would have a pro you know be
jamming up that kind of pack schedule
would be limited because they basically
be S SP2 towns right from let's say we
have the January primary then my exitor
is sb2 we have a March ballot um so
that's a limited un so I'd like to think
that somewhere in sort of our New
Hampshire efficiency
model we could figure out a way to to do
that to to be able to Not Duplicate
machine
purchasing I haven't quite figured that
out but the wisdom of the committee
might
yeah representative
Brennan she does
not thank you thank you for taking my
question are you aware of vendors who
may be able to do the reprogramming of
these devices um to kind of take that
off of the Secretary of State's plate
and allow municipalities to contract
with vendors who might be able to you
know take this on in that short
turnaround time frame that's a really
good question and my understanding is
that yes there are vendors that do this
for I think for a living if you will
that's their function among many other
things but yeah I think that there's a a
well-oiled machine that knows how to
program these things and I think that's
if I all states I think but for us in
Hawaii provide this technology in
Municipal elections so there's a
Marketplace and a vendor that that can
do this stuff and they do it and they
currently do it for us I think it's my
understanding further questions from the
committee representative wey thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question my wife taught
for many years at Perkin School for the
Blind down and water and so uh this is
near and dear to my heart I'm I'm just
um I'm I'm concerned that uh you
mentioned that it's more targeted toward
the visually impaired and I'm I'm
concerned that it enables all in in page
two line 10 enables all individuals with
disabilities I'm wondering if that's too
broad a scope um and and if it might you
know o open up municipal alties to
additional lawsuits because we haven't
provided for every
disability so that's a good question and
we have a graduate of the Perkin School
of the blind who's a constituent of mine
who's the driver behind this bill jeene
Shiner called me up and said we got to
do this and I said okay Jean just listen
to Jean uh but to your question um you
know I think that and I'm going to let
the disability rights Community speak to
this because I am by no means an expert
in this I don't think that by expanding
this to and it's not necessarily just uh
they know the universe of folks that
would be able to use this this
particular technology not just my
limited knowledge of telling you I think
the the reduction of a lawsuit is
happens by by by doing this not an
increase in terms of um probability of
that
yeah representative Brennan thank you um
do you know if clerks or election
officials have some kind of test that a
voter with a disability would need to um
fill out or complete in order to use
these devices or are they available to
any voter that requests access to the
one for all um devices yeah I'll try to
answer that the best I can and that is
they are available to any voter as my
understand that would request them yeah
and in fact as I mentioned I used it in
March my clerk took me over to the spot
and did it so further questions seeing
none thank you representative Paige
thank you Mr chairman uh next up
representative
Lynn uh thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Bob Lynn I'm a
representative from uh Windam Rockingham
District 17 and I appear um in support
of uh this bill um I don't really have a
lot to add to what representative Paige
said the only point that I I think I
would make and which I think is really
important is and I and I'm sure the
Secretary of State um will expand upon
this but it's my understanding that um
in the main uh the the machines that are
that would needed for this are already
in existence and the only question is
should those machines be able to be used
for local elections in addition to State
elections and um as as was pointed out
um voting is pretty pretty darn
important and it seems to me that it's
uh that um the you know the balance
there tips in favor of yes they should
be available for for local elections so
that that's really uh the Su substance
of my testimony I'm happy to answer any
questions if uh people have it represent
Brown thank you and thank you for taking
my question um it's I'm glad to see you
co-sponsoring this bill representative
Lynn thank you for that I'm wondering if
it is your testimony that every eligible
voter deserves the opportunity to cast
their ballot and have that ballot
counted every every eligible voter who
meets the requirements of the law yes I
do I do agree with that see what you did
there representative Howard thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh so under the you might not
necessarily know but under the fiscal
note for this bill it labels everything
as a local expenditure uh because of
your testimony do you believe that this
needs to be something covered by the
Secretary of
State well I guess I'd want to you know
I'd want to hear what the secretary of
state has to say about this I mean I if
it's if the machines are available and
it's not
you know a huge deal so to speak to have
the to have them simply kind of
reprogram for local elections I would uh
you know may maybe that is something
that the that the state should pick up
or maybe that's something that you know
um the mun the municipal Association
would have something to say about about
how that Arrangement should be should be
worked out okay thank
you okay um further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
represent thank you next up will be
Hennessy good morning Aaron Hennessy
deputy secretary of
state sorry uh I just want to let you
know our office does support the use of
these devices in local elections um
there's some semantics that I just want
to walk you through um so I personally
had several meetings um with the sponsor
of this bill starting in the fall to try
and work out how this bill could work
for um for local elections and with the
assistance of our office so I just want
to give you a little background on what
the current um equipment that we use as
as a state for accessible
voting uh we have a programmed tablet
and it's it's like a a flat tablet
that we um clean like the hard drive um
after every election and then when we
receive the programmed ballot for each
of the polling locations currently
there's 208 um we physically um program
that each individual tablet for that
polling location's ballot um and test
the programming of the ballot in our
office um then we package that tablet up
um and we send it to each of the local
election officials um they are required
to um test that at their before
implementing that into their local into
their state voting um at their polling
locations as well um the what goes along
with the tablet is a tent a privacy tent
you may have seen this at your local
polling locations it's a large white
tent um in within the tent is a docking
station for the tent tablet that
connects the tablet to a printer and
other accessible voting equipment
including a
keyboard um and in discussions with the
sponsor of this bill we think that is um
we would be very happy to share this
equipment which is already maintained by
the local election officials the city
city or town clerk keeps the tent they
keep the T they keep the docking station
they keep the printer um unless we
upgrade the equipment um they maintain
that at their in um secured securely
storage in their um local offices um
what it comes down to for our office is
the logistics of getting the tablets
back and wiping them clean I'm not just
wiping them down just wiping the hard
times CLE so that we can make sure
there's no viruses or anything that were
entered into at the polling location
somehow um and that the um the next
election can be programmed for that um
there does take some time for our office
to get them back and to do that and time
is money sometimes so if we were to
share our devices with local election
officials this is something I think we
can do but it just takes it takes
Manpower and it takes um time to do this
which we don't currently have um as you
know our office doesn't just do
elections we have a dedicated it team
that is to our entire um office not just
our elections division um so they have
other duties as well
um what the if we were to share our
tablets we would need additional tablets
um because of the timing and turnover of
the tablets um and sometimes after a
state election a local um somewhat the
locals don't always return the tablets
to us timely with their return of votes
um so we would need additional tablets
in the case of that event um what the
the additional time that the
municipality would need is that they
would need time to then go to a vendor
um most likely the vendor we use since
they're using our equipment to program
their local ballot so this is something
that we wouldn't do because they are
each local programs their own ballot
they don't have to um use our printer
they don't have to use um the setup of
the ballot that we do at State um
elections so this is something that is
done locally and they they still follow
the law but they can do it however they
wish to so there's a lot of time and
testing involved and um security of the
tablet involved and I think that's what
the um the fiscal note reflects is that
there's there's going to be some
Manpower from our office and new
equipment from our office that needs to
be purchased um there is one thing that
I want to point out in the bill on page
two there's some um as a representative
paid page alluded to there's some
statutory construction issues with the
bill um
uh bottom of page one actually it starts
and it changes amends RSA
66925 to read and it in it crosses out
the word town and puts in local and adds
cities into there um this shouldn't be
done in the statute it should be done in
each individual statute um it would
cause some um election law issues that
we see Pop Up in other areas so anytime
you want to address a a local election
or a city election it should be done in
those statutes there's also a concern
that um some City Charters would have to
be amended to reflect this um and that
would have to be on a charter by Charter
basis so you can't just put into law if
the charter is already in place and says
something differently um and not a
lawyer again but my understanding is
this this paragraph needs to be updated
to include each individual paragraph
that would refer to a local or a city
election I'm happy to take questions
representative bone thank you Mr
chairman and thank you SEC deputy
secretary taking a question um yeah I've
been involved with a lot of local
elections and I know the town is
responsible
for um programming the machines and
whatnot that's not an issue but I see an
issue here do you see that this could be
a 28a issue if the towns have to buy the
tablets
if 28a where they would the it's a
mandate that they the legislature would
force them to spend money yes um I'm not
a lawyer so I would re I would leave
that up to the lawyers in the
room thank you further questions
representative Brennan thank you um just
for
clarification is the Secretary of
State's office taking a position on this
bill and if there were a vendor able to
coordinate the cleaning of these
devices um with
municipalities would the Secretary of
State's office
support um enabling municipalities to
engage with that vendor to take it off
your plate thank you for the question um
I think I our office would support the
bill if it has the corrections that I
recommended um ISS uh corrected in there
um the um outside vendor this is the
first I've heard of that come up it
didn't come up in any of the
conversations I had with the bill about
an outside vendor taking over the
process would I consider a security
process so I'd have to have discussions
with my it team but my initial reaction
would be no we do not want an outside
vendor um taking over a security
election security thing but I would need
to know more about the process followup
please yep it's fine
um I thought I heard you say in your
testimony earlier that you currently
contract with a vendor to do the wiping
of these programming the I'm sorry the
programming yes um so perhaps maybe I'm
Mis
um
misinterpreting um or you know
attributing programming and uh wiping
these clean would a
vendor um perhaps the same vendor that
you use be available to municipalities
to do the programming um for these local
ballots that um are within the purview
of the municipality is that something
you would support um engaging the
municipality with that vendor yes our
office is happy to um adjust our
contracts if needed I believe they
currently do say that um it the contract
that we have with the current vendor
which is democracy live would um is
accessible to cities and towns to use as
well okay is that was that your question
thank
you representative Lane uh thank you Mr
chair um I think someone has already
asked the question of you that I had
promised to ask but I will ask another
one um do you will this apply only tob2
towns or would it
be that's my question one that's my
first
question thank you for the question so
again the way the language is written
it's kind of unclear now because it just
it puts language into a section of law
that it's not the appropriate section it
needs to be put into any other sections
but I believe it would it would apply to
um school districts Village districts
cities so any local municipal election
but and I believe that's the intent of
of the sponsor but I'm not positive on
that yep
follow um do you have do you have a
sense of how many that how many towns
or I and for the for the cities I guess
how many polling places that would
be uh sorry um 308 is what I said but I
don't know like locally it again we
don't run local elections so I don't
know how many they use locally I'm
assuming it's the same
um sorry and I believe I missp spoke
before I think it's 308 not 208 so
I thank you um um oh
gosh how many do you own now how many of
these tablets does the Secretary State
own
out I'm taking a guess but when I SP in
the fall when I spoke to Our IT
department on this it was there we had a
buffer over the so if we need 308 I
believe we have 320 but I'm not positive
on that exact number right
now representative Brennan thank you um
isn't it true
that towns that have adopted official
ballot um operate their Municipal
elections using that official ballot for
the election of candidates and Zoning
amendments and therefore would apply to
Beyond sv2 towns but town meeting towns
that have adopted That official ballot
process which I believe and perhaps the
new New Hampshire Municipal Association
can answer this um all town meeting
towns have adopted That official ballot
for the election of their candidates and
Zoning amendments and any other thing
ballot I need a clarification on that
I'm sure the municipal Association can
answer that but I believe this bill does
elections further questions on the
committee seeing none thank you deputy
secretary um we're going to take a brief
pause and recess on this bill to we're
behind we're going to come right back um
but we're going to allow for the
introduction of 1310 so the sponsor can
go about their the rest of their
business um and then we're going to come
right back to it so we're just going to
we're going to recess uh 1264 going to
open the public he on House Bill 1310
relative to meetings of the supervisor
of the checklist going to allow for the
introduction of the bill once the bill
is introduced we going to immediately
recess the bill and we're going to go
1264 representative Lan you're
recognized um thank you Mr chairman I
greatly appreciate this um my name is is
representative Erica Leon I represent
the town of dairy and if this bill looks
familiar to you it is uh very similar to
the bill as amended that came out of the
committee last year but was tabled on
the floor I know that you've heard
another bill about increasing the
frequency of cleaning the voter cleaning
the checklist from 10 years to four
years this bill was actually introduced
as a way to have ongoing the the
underlying bill um of maintaining the
checklist on an ongoing basis by
checking it with death records with
motor vehicle records and with property
transactions in the town was a way that
was intended to allow for greater
ongoing checklist Management in the town
of Derry we've had um almost 2,000
voters who had left town removed from
the from the voter roles after the
10-year voter Purge and by doing this
we've been able to keep a more
consistent more tight number of Voters
on the polls um as you're aware the
number of um voting stations and many
other things are based upon the number
of registered voters in the town so this
has a great impact on day-to-day
election processes unfortunately not
every supervisor of the checklist has
actually meant to deal with the uh deal
with the information that has come the
largest one is that um the law now
provides that the national change of
address registry um provides information
annually through a check done by the
Secretary of State to the towns because
there are towns and cities that are not
meeting in order to handle the data
their voter roles are unnecessarily
inflated um this bill simply would
require them to meet um at least every
90 days for the purpose of periodic
checklist maintenance so you know that's
that's not overly frequent that's four
times a year that could be handled in
their other business if they choose to
do that at another supervisor session
which they have done in Dairy
unfortunately because some supervisors
have met and only done the statutorily
required minimum this law is
unfortunately necessary um I I believe
that by doing this and making sure that
the supervisors are actually processing
those data that are available to them we
won't need to have such a burdensome
process every 10 years or every four
years if the other bill in front of you
this year were to pass um so with that
I'm happy to take any questions that you
have other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative Leon we going to go
recess thank you the public public
hearing on House Bill 1310 and reopen
the public hearing on House Bill 1264
relative to the definition of accessible
voting machines next up to speak is Jean
exitor
good
morning um my name is Jean Shiner and
I'm an resident of exer and I am a
graduate of Perkins as somebody
mentioned um I am totally blind and
voting independently with a secret
ballot has been been a passion of mine
for several decades I am a member of the
Coalition of blind and visual visually
impaired voters and we are a Statewide
group of consumers and agency
Representatives working on voting access
for the past eight years we have worked
with the Secretary of State's office to
have state and federal elections with
accessible ballots and in 2018 I was
able to to fill out my ballot with the
one for all device place it in the Box
along with everyone else it was a
feeling of great
accomplishment along with having state
and federal elections accessible
regarding voting the Coalition also
wanted towns and cities to have the same
right presently exiter and conquered are
the only
two municipalities with accessible
ballot
and it happened um in conquer a
gentleman filed a complaint with the
Department of Justice and he won his
case and then conqur has to have
accessible ballots for their um
Municipal meetings and um in exitor many
of us with vision loss worked hard with
exitor to get the ballot
accessible and I'm going to talk about
my experience with voting and exiter
last year was our first time voting with
an accessible ballot and I want to say
this is where it gets personal for me
before then I would bring my town clerk
into the ballot with me and she would
read the long three ballots I'd say the
town ballots are the most complicated
and lengthy ballots of any of them
especially compared to this last one we
went through when we just voted for one
person
um I went in last year it was a very
snowy day went into my booth put on my
headset used my arrow keys selected my
candidates voted on the article warrants
and then took my ballots three of them
and put them in the box and it was just
a very empowering experience for me I
was so glad that I could vote that
way and I want to say I want everyone
with a disability to experience that we
all have the right constitutionally to
vote with a SE ballot and we don't have
it yet and I don't think we should be
waiting for another session to have this
happen I want to ask you to consider
passing this bill this
year we have this right for state and
federal
elections and we need to have the
same ability to vote with this
for Town and City elections so I thank
you for listening to me today and thank
you okay will you be taking questions
from the
committee yes all right are there
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
exitor
welcome to election
law thank you very much my name is Dana
Trahan this is my guide tikva under the
table checking things out before she
decides to lay
down um
I too am a resident of exiter and a part
of the Coalition of blind vision
impaired voters um I was cited until I
lost my site back in 2010 in 2010 I lost
my sight to the extent that I'm vision
impaired or legally blind um and so I
was able to vote independently and
confidentially On My Own by going into
the voting booth and and marking my
ballot until 2010 when things changed
and um I'm imagining that you all here
would would have a hard time with that
too you know having it be that you can
no longer just exercise your right right
to vote and be confidential and uh
independent about it so um I was happy
at the time when there was some
accessible system in place I remember
there was something with a telephone
keypad that we could make selections
with and it faxed somewhere um but
especially pleased when the one forall
came into place for the federal and
state elections um to be able to go in
and vote on my own again
um by either you know using the keyboard
and the arrow keys like Gina described
or by using the tablet as representative
page has described um either way and
it's the system is called the one for
all and I love to say that it's one
system for all to use um the Secretary
of State's office worked very nicely
with us when we had different um
concerns about um the audio quality or
you know the fact that originally it
wasn't a pre-printed ballot it was a
matter of our votes printed on a plain
piece of paper so we had to put them on
the side of the the counting machine so
it was a little different that way but
the fact now that it's a pre-printed
ballot and we can vote as all others do
um I know someone was concerned about
the walking the ballot from the the
booth to the machine and it's easy
enough to even keep that private I know
Jean for instance will ask our town
clerk for a manila envelope to put her
Ballot or ballots into and she can carry
them privately and insert them to the
machine as everyone else does
um I too you know I I never really
realized the importance of being able to
vote independently and privately because
I just did it you know just like I I
didn't really understand the the
importance of public transportation
because I just always got in my car and
went where I wanted to go when I wanted
to go so having the change in my ability
um has really brought it to my attention
um being a part of the Coalition it's
wonderful to help try to spread the word
about it um I'd love to challenge you
all here to to use the one forall system
the next time it's time to uh vote an
election so you can see for yourselves
what it's like um don't know that I have
much more to add I'm happy to take any
questions okay are there questions from
the
committee see none thank you so much
thank you okay um we are now into
lobbyist
land all right here we go so we're on
the two-minute clock here
um let's start off with with Ryan
Living
okay welcome to election law yes thank
you uh again for the record my my name
is Ryan dony I am an advocacy
coordinator with Granite State
Independent Living GSI is a Statewide
nonprofit
organization that Advocates and provides
services for seniors and people with
disabilities who want to remain
independent in their homes and
communities and I'm speaking to you
today in support of HB 12
64 uh and i' just like to take a moment
to talk about myself and my own
experiences uh as you can see I'm a man
who lives with a physical
disability and there's a lot of stuff
that I need help with in my day-to-day
life but I also value my
Independence and
anytime that something can be adapted or
modified so that I can do it
myself rather than having to rely on
anybody else I I love that you know I
love the feeling of of being able to to
do things on my own including
voting
and
uh I do vote and I've used the
accessible voting system before and it
is fantastic it works well and I'm very
grateful to have that available for
federal and state elections and I'd like
to see that available for local
elections as well it's it's my right and
I think that anything that makes voting
in all
elections accessible for for all people
is is a win for the state and a win for
everybody so with that I I hope that you
folks will seriously consider this bill
and and vote in support of it happy to
take any questions that that you might
have are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you um late submission here Shannon
McLoud is a member of H I believe you're
the w three moderator right
knowledge hello thank you so much for
allowing me to speak um this is actually
my first time testifying before the
house very exciting um my name is
Shannon McLoud I am the W 3 moderator in
Manchester I've been serving in that
role for two terms um and I am here to
speak in favor of this bill uh we have a
few different residents in ward 3 who um
routinely use our accessible voting
booth and um this past municipal
election one of those voters came and
was very very frustrated that she um was
not able to use the accessible voting
machine uh to cast her ballot um she
needed assistance um which meant that
her ballot was not secret which she was
very frustrated by um expressed that
frustration to our poll workers which we
completely understood she did come back
for our presidential election and was
excited to be able to use the accessible
voting machine um something that's
interesting about Manchester they
actually do set up the booths even
though they're not able to be used the
booths are there and they look exactly
the same as they do for the um for the
state elections people just use them as
a private booth rather than having to
use the machine um so I don't imagine
that it would be a huge lift
particularly not for our local election
officials to be able to use it um but it
would certainly help our voters so happy
to answer any questions uh questions
from the committee um I actually have
one have you have you spoke with the
city clerk at all about this um I
haven't actually okay I might reach out
to him so just want just curious if you
already talked to him all right thank
you um next up we're going back into
Rosenberg good morning I'm also bringing
um I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the policy
director at the disability rights Center
this is my colleague James zigra who is
a senior staff attorney at our office
who knows all things election law and
I'm bringing him up in case you all have
any technical questions for him um
disability rights Center is a state's
protection and advocacy system for
people with disabilities and we strongly
support this bill um as you've heard
being able to cast one's vote privately
is a fundamental right it is something
that is just of Supreme importance to
all of us and um in all elections
Manchester had an election this past
November where we elected a I I live in
Manchester our mayor and that was a
contentious election and people with
disabilities if they wanted to vote
would have to share who they were going
to be voting for in that election and
that's just wrong so um we think it's
really important to do this and it can
be done and you've heard that we already
own these machines as a state um we you
will also hear from the municipal
Association that they are you know that
that the folks that they represent the
municipalities are happy to take on the
responsibility to pay for the cost of
programming cleaning transporting these
machines um if needed um they will they
will do it they're already responsible
for running their local elections and
they want people to vote too so I hope
that you all do if we need an amendment
to add some statutory references that
seems very easily done we'd be happy to
work with the secretary of state I'm
sure that all the folks behind us would
be happy to do that so um if you've got
questions I'm happy to answer them but
I'm really hoping that you will support
this bill questions from the
thanks next up is Randy pierce with
site
table all right thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today so I
am randy Pierce I am the president and
CEO of future in sight many of you
probably know it as the New Hampshire
Association for the blind we serve the
entire state but we also serve me I am
totally blind myself as I have been for
a little over 20 years now so the the
reason I'm here is to highlight three
points first gratitude I love the
progress our state has made because when
I first went blind I like Dana had to
transfer from voting on my own
independently and in privacy to stepping
into a booth and I'm 6'4 with a nice
tall guide dog to match up with a person
to record it a person to witness it and
we are tighter than on the elevator on
the way up here when we do that and once
that even happened without the person
making judgmental comments as they
recorded my vote right that's not what
we want for our citizens that's not what
we deserve that's why we have this
system and we've made a long stride
towards there but the fact that it is
only encompassing part of our elections
is something that many legislators I've
spoken with didn't realize previously
and now that we do I want to applaud you
for taking steps towards the solution
because we serve there are 28,000
constituents in New Hampshire who are
sight impaired profound sight loss to
the point that this system can benefit
them and that's not even counting the
rest of the print disability abilities
out there and of those folks that means
every one of your communities has many
people I was born grew up I was born in
ASA grew up in cber 27 people that we
know about in Nash in coldbrook New
Hampshire over a thousand in nashwa
right that could qualify for these why
aren't they using the system because
consistency is what they need when they
go in one time and they're allowed to
vote accessibly they go in another time
they're not they're intimidated to use
it the best form of advocacy any of us
can do in my opinion is to be competent
and to be confident but when you get
undermined every step of the way that's
a challenge I feel like I strive towards
that every day and I still struggle when
I have to go into my municipal election
and can't vote with the right means so
for all the other 28,000 and for me I
strongly urge you to consider all of the
ramifications that come if we don't meet
our federal requirement to provide
voting in an accessible fashion I'd
welcome any questions questions from the
committee representative we uh thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Pierce for
taking my question just I I wanted to
get a clarification on one of the
numbers you mentioned you said 28,000
not including and what was the phrase
that you print disabled so there are
people who might have an a disability
which is not site related but inhibits
their ability to read the ballot whether
it's dyslexia whether it's many forms of
those right that would exponentially
increase it thank you you're welcome
representative PR O'Brien thank you uh
thank you Mr Pierce uh I really
appreciate you being here today I just
want to ask one clarification you
mentioned that you you only had one time
that you went into the voting booth
where you felt like the person assisting
you was not making judgments about how
you voted is this correct that is
exactly what I said and understand
either the person who is recording it or
the person who was there to witness them
recording it what a terrible situation
and we've had a lot of contentious
elections through the years and when
you're involved and first off as a
public figure for all the work I have to
do I don't want my vote being shared I
don't deserve my vote being shared but
that's exactly
right Paul uh further questions I I do
have one along the line where do you
vote so I just moved two years ago to
take this job and I now vote in
Canterbury New Hampshire Sam is great
there but he has no access to get us
accessible equipment okay where was your
this is I mean we're off track n this
was in N I was born in Nash spent the
bulk of my life there hopefully there's
more life ahead mind you but yeah okay
I'm sorry it's just those things like
that are obviously very concerning to us
so probably uh I filed the complaints
not only with the clerk but also with
Secretary of State's office when it
happened okay perfect thank you all
right um anyone else wish to uh any
other questions I should say seeing none
thank you um next up is
Bryan fery
man almost um well thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee uh my name
is Brendan flarey I'm here today on
behalf of secure democracy USA um you
should have or I handed a letter into
our representative Grill um yet looks
like it was passed around so really uh
to save everybody's time I'll sum it up
into about a sentence uh secure
democracy USA uh supports House Bill
1264 uh because it addresses concerns
around ada8 compliance and as we heard
from so many today uh it extends a
private independent and dignified vote
uh to our voters here in New Hampshire
we're happy to work with the committee
um in addressing any issues with the
bill and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you questions from the committee
seeing none thank you great thank
angle hello
again um once again I have an
unfortunate amount of paper so I'm going
to do the same thing and pass around
afterwards after this whole thing has
closed um
so I for the record my name is Katherine
LEL I vote in conquered and I I am open
democracy actions public policy fellow
um once similar to uh Brendan Verity
from secure democracy I'm going to sum
it up in about a sentence or two um open
democracy and open democracy action uh
support this bill um because it supports
ADA compliance it allows all voices to
be heard and it
supports um the pur pursuance of
democracy and Civic engagement for all
people I really can't say much more
other than listen to the voices that are
being spoken out for once today um these
are very strong voices and I myself
cannot speak on this as I am was born
sighted and I still have my site so
please listen to these voices it's so so
important thank you okay questions from
the committee seeing none thank you um
uh so everybody knows we are into the
time slot for uh House Bill 1384 but the
sponsors are all members of the
committee so we're gonna we don't need
to open and recess that um next up is
Germaine good morning chairman members
of the committee my name is Mackenzie St
Germaine with the New Hampshire campaign
for voting rights which is a project of
America boats New Hampshire um we are
here today in strong support of this
bill um and you've heard firsthand the
reasons today why these accessible
machines are important I hope through
discussions and work on this bill and
Logistics everyone can keep in mind and
remember that we all agree on the
importance of every voter being able to
cast their ballot independently and
privately whether they're voting for
president State Rep school board or
anything else um also I know there's
been conversations around the machines
that we have versus new machines um I
think there are benefits and we would
support if at all possible using these
same devices for the federal state and
local elections um not only for the
voter experience and having folks go in
and being consistent and knowing exactly
how to vote how the devices work and
what to expect but also for training
training for election officials um one
of the things we hear a lot on Election
Day or in the fall up on Election Day
was issues around the accessible voting
devices
because they are you know an extra step
of training that folks need the
moderators and election officials need
to learn about um I know that our
election officials take it very
seriously but there can be mistakes in
setting them up or knowing how they work
having consistent equipment each
election can help ensure that we can
train people up really well and that
equipment is set up whether it be local
state elections again ensuring that
folks are able to cast their ballot
privately and independently um and if we
were to get new equipment in the future
again it being consistent using the
state equipment and being able to have
um groups that train like future and
sight being able to train voters getting
everyone up to speed on how the
Equipment Works how they need to use it
um and confident in doing that to remove
some of those barriers so thank you all
and Happy to answer questions questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
thank you next up uh Mr Grace from the
New Hampshire Municipal
[Music]
Association
thank you Mr chair n Grace for the
municipal Association we are committed
to uh solving this issue this session um
obviously as you've heard today this is
a liability issue for municipalities
conquered nextra have already experience
that and it's clearly a fairness issue
for disabled voters so um to answer some
of the committee's questions um it does
appear that an amendment is needed I'm
more than happy to work with uh the
sponsor and stakeholders to ensure that
we can uh get something that
works um I believe that we can uh
perhaps modify the definition of
accessible voting system
slightly um to clarify what that means
and then shorten up this paragraph two
on page two so that we can resolve the
issue with uh enables all individuals
with disabilities to vote just to make
it clear that we're talking about a
system similar to the one forall system
um obviously our interest here is the
same as other stakeholders in making
sure that um we we can clarify uh how
this process works and make it as
seamless as possible and as similar as
possible to what happens in state and
federal elections as well as address
those security concerns because we want
to make sure that everyone's vote um is
counted um the other thing I want to
mention is uh that I did learn in a
meeting with the Secretary of State's
office that we are expecting at some
point information from the federal
government um answering a question about
whether those uh devices used for state
and federal elections can be used for
local
elections obviously I anticipate the
answer to that will be yes I assume that
means we'll have to purchase some more
devices at the state level to make sure
we have enough in circulation that we
can service local elections in addition
to uh the state elections when we have a
time crunch um I don't know how many
devices that would be off the top of my
head but I'm sure someone can do the
math on that
um and just to clarify uh with the
committee I do anticipate and I do not
see any issue with municipalities paying
for the programming costs of those
devices we will obviously need to have
the secretary or some vendor selected by
the secretary set some timelines to make
sure we can get them the content of the
warrant to uh whoever is programming
that in a correct in enough time that
can happen as well as ensure that those
devices get back in a timely fashion um
but I think this is doable um and I'm
happy to answer any questions the
committee may have questions from the
committee representative Mo thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question I have a
question on elections in non sb2
towns uh Town Town elections uh Town
meetings school board meetings which are
done differently in different towns um
so and also even deliber deliberative
sessions so how you think we need do in
those those areas so what I would
anticipate is this would apply to any
use of the official ballot that's
defined under 403 and
4014 um so there a couple options
obviously at very traditional town
meeting everyone shows up at the meeting
and you vote there's no ballot um
there's a modified version of that where
you can vote for officers you vote for
select board Etc I anticipate it would
be used for that election of officers um
and then you have
a kind of the step above that is the SP2
town where you vote for all of the
warrant articles as well as the election
of officers it would be used for that as
well I believe the intent is to use it
on the school side as well as well as in
cities so I think the amendment needs
will clarify that to make sure it
captures exactly what what's meant here
because that's what we saw in conquered
as well as exiter obviously conquer a
city exitor as a town so um they have
different experiences but it's the same
concern that was brought forward follow
up follow up followup at Del liberative
session there are some cases where there
needs to be a secret ballot do you think
this needs to be done at that also so
there's also an unofficial balloting
portion of town meeting I don't I don't
know that it
would be part of that um we'd have to
look at that process and just clarify it
to make sure we can use it as much as
we're allowed
to further questions from the committee
representative Brennan thank you um so
just to make sure I'm understanding your
testimony
accurately um municipalities that you
represent uh that are nhma members are
fine with footing the bill
for one forall system or similar to be
used in municipalities to ensure that
um
all residents all eligible voters within
that municipality are capable
of casting their ballot in the secret
secure way that is promised to
everyone
I think that the law requires us to do
so thank
you further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you uh last
Hampshire hi good morning my name is
Henry clemento from the ACLU of New
Hampshire um I'm not going to Guild the
Lily I'm just going to say that the ACLU
of New Hampshire supports like I think
most if not all of this committee and
most of not all this house does uh the
ability of everyone to vote um with
dignity and Independence and so we
support this Bill thank you will you be
taking questions sure questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you uh I don't have any other pink cards
in my possession is there anyone else
who wishes to speak to House Bill
1264 seeing none um I have the blue
sheet blue sheet has one 2 three four
five six seven 8 nine eight uh people
signed up in support who did not speak
online there were 324 in support three
opposed and one neutral with that I will
be closing the public hearing on House
Bill 1264 I appreciate the Public's
interest in this bill um one actually I
should say one thing we are going to do
about this uh stakeholders of this bill
please reach out to representative Wei
um he is going to coordinate the
necessary amendments so Secretary of
States interested Advocates um I'm going
to give that to representative wey since
he has a um uh let say close CL interest
in this subject um and that way we can
get a nice clean Amendment and we have
it all going through him instead of
trying to bombard me with him um because
it'll get lost and he will do a much
better job um with that we're going to
close out House Bill 1264 FN we're going
to go back uh into house bill uh 310
relative to meetings of Supervisors of
the checklist I'm going to try to get my
pink cards back in order here now we
have 131 right here
um uh
[Music]
so only have one pink card I think uh
Kathy Anderson Kathy Anderson are you
still
here Kathy Anderson you are recognized
thank you for your patience I'm sorry
we're a little behind try to get caught
up it's okay I'm Kathy Anderson I live
in Hancock New Hampshire I'm here to
oppose this bill I am the supervisor of
the checklist in Hancock Hancock you may
well know is a town under 2000 on the
western edge of Hillsboro County we have
about 1,400 voters on our checklist the
three supervisors are volunteer labor we
spend a lot of time at this volunteer
labor we get no reimbursement we don't
get cups of coffee at elections we just
work um I think we probably meet this
bill but I don't really want to have to
be counting days to add one more job to
my responsibilities we strongly believe
in voting we want to support voters we
want to get them on the checklist in a
reasonably fast rate and um more
meetings would not help that there's a
lot of work to the checklist I presume
you all are aware of that that we have
to not just register a vote but enter
them and do the filing and it just
continues on we do a lot of
work thank you would you will you be
taking questions from the committee sure
are there questions from the
committee okay that's easy thank you so
much thank you um is there anyone else
who wishes to speak to houseb 1310 I
don't see any pink CS in my possession
seeing none um we had one person signed
up on the blue sheet they were in
opposition online there was three in
support 33 opposed and one neutral with
that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 310 so look at
that we're moving again um and I'm going
to now open the public hearing on House
Bill 1384 relative to non-compliance by
a town or uh Ward moderator and clerk uh
I believe representative we are you
introducing this Bill yes sir okay I
don't see no you're good representative
where to go introduce um we do have one
weie all right thank you Mr chair and
honorable committee members for the
record my name is Robert wary and I have
the privilege of serving in Hillsboro
County's 13th District District the
great town of
Hudson um I said uh the following in
last week's public hearing on House Bill
1381 relative to the training on
Election procedures and bears repeating
the great state of New Hampshire has
many wonderful clerks and moderators and
many other election officials who
diligently performed their job and
handled their responsibilities with
great professionalism and integrity
these individuals are in the majority
and they are not the problem I would ask
to last week's comments that the
performance of election duties is
relatively complex at least as indicated
by the thickness of our RSA books and
the election law procedures manual and
not only is it complex procedurally it's
complex because of the variableness of
resources required ac across the
different types of Elections except for
maybe dixville Knox I guess um and given
the variableness of the number of voters
between the various local elections
primary elections um midterm elections
general elections the required resources
vary greatly another another factor that
must be considered is the fact that
elections are only performed
sporadically elections can never be a
routine operation because they are never
routinely performed so given the
intrinsic complexity of Elections
performing elections must be recognized
as a challenging series of tasks which
must be carefully
performed and also this was brought up
by one of the moderators testifying last
week that that this RSA is limited to
moderators and clerks it is only limited
in that way because of the original
language of that of RSA
65977 that is limited to moderators and
clerks and perhaps additional an
additional RSA is needed um that would
put the same requirements for other
election officials that already exists
for moderators and and clerks but that
is perhaps an LSR for next
year so what is the problem that this
bill is trying to address there is a
small there is a concern that some small
minority again I would emphasize small
minority of election officials are not
diligent in following the procedures and
that this lack of diligence is due to
non-compliance with procedures and a neg
a level of negligence that results in
significant errors the the original
language only addressed int intentional
neglect now we heard in a testimony a
few weeks ago on House Bill
1364 that the Judiciary Committee uses a
four-fold framework for assessing
culpability namely purposefully
knowingly recklessly and
carelessly so intentionality or
purposefully is likely difficult to
prove unless there's a forensic audit or
an investigation by the Attorney
General's
office so the language in this RSA has
been modified to address a relative
inability to address intentionality
directly lack of training which already
exists addresses the knowingly aspect
the additional language seeks to address
the culpability aspects of recklessly
and carelessly and finally some
additional language reaffirms that this
RSA should only come into play when
there is a significant
deficiency so uh with that I am happy to
take any questions and answer if I can
questions from the
committee representative Lane um thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative um you your last
statement was if I heard it correctly
was this was aimed for
significant misb significant
non-compliance because I don't reading
it quickly I don't see where that stands
out so um so in lines 19 and line
22 there's already language existing in
the current RSA for significant
deficiency and deficiencies and then
significant deficiency and then on page
two of the amendment um oh I'm sorry
wait a second hang
on
um oh a preponderance of ADV oh uh line
21 significant deficiency is also added
she'll document the reported facts and
circumstances of the significant
deficiency so that's where that's is
that what you were asking about yes um
okay follow up are you clarifying about
the amendment yes I think you Miss B you
don't have an amendment correct you're
just talking about the B sorry
that's changes to the RSA I'm sorry it's
already been a long day so it's it's
totally to totally yeah it was a little
bit confusing I knew I I knew what you
meant I believed in thank
you sorry all right further questions
from the
committee representative
Hammer hi thanks for taking my question
where has this happened
to what town city do you have any
idea well we have we have heard
testimony about um our um Hudson
neighbor Windham and and uh We've also
heard about the senate race for District
24 I believe it is um and so I think
those
are uh I think some of the inducements
behind this because as as everyone
probably recalls but um there were over
130 issues found in the first and then
in the subsequent two-year thing which
was observed by um
a member of the Secretary of State's
office um there was still an additional
30 some errors or issues that were uh
noted and and the testimony uh that we
heard a few weeks ago with regard to The
District 24 Senator race had um an a
large number of issues as well um if you
want I'm happy to provide that
additional detail
to you um
offline further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um next
Hennessy thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Aaron Hennessy
deputy secretary of state
and we have a some concerns over the
language of the bill that changes the
language
from neglect to non-compliance what that
would mean is that anyone who
unintentionally makes a mathematical
error is a
non-compliance and um who um may have
been able to correct that in the past
would now be in violation under these
sections um our fear is that um you will
see in your um cities and towns that you
will be unable to um have people sign up
to run for these election official
positions um because no one would want
to be um caught in
non-compliance um who may never have
done something intentionally um in
neglect of but may very extremely
unintentionally done something in
non-compliance of and that's our um
concerns with this legislation I'm happy
to take
questions okay with that thank
Al you got it thank you how do you I
think we all need lessons in printing
myself
included
thank
you thank you for having me uh my name
is Al brandano I'm from Kensington New
Hampshire and I'm voting i' I'd ask for
you to vote in favor of uh HB
1384 I think one of the most important
things we've heard in this committee
time and time again uh is uh secretary
scandin every time he attends here he
tells you that the most important goal
for him is voter confidence over and
over and and over
again um so this is really important
because I believe this is where the
rubber meets the road for hearing from
the people themselves rather than
somebody with an orange badge this is
really important I want to take a little
bit of the history um there have been
three formal complaints in Windam that
have not been answered by the Attorney
General yet that's over a 2-year period
what does that do for voter
confidence uh there were over 200
complaints combined in those three
formal to the attorney general no
response Senate District 24 had over 147
violations and they weren't violations
of uh not um simple violations these we
were these were significant so sign
significant in fact that the ballot law
commission uh voted 5 to1 to move this
to the Attorney General yet a year later
no formal
response so what does the average
citizen and voter believe does does Mr
scanland um goals ring true apparently
not um one of the most important parts
in uh the Senate District 24 was when
chairman um the chairman of the ballot
law commission asked Lugar jula's
attorney do you believe these violations
affected the outcome of the election
attorney McDonald with these many
violations how can you prove it did not
and this is the problem we have clerks
and moderators article two uh part two
article 32 of the New Hampshire
Constitution makes them the people who
sort and count votes they are the
responsible party laws that are against
discipline if we can't hold somebody
accountable we have no discipline we
have no we have no voting we don't have
anything to believe in if we can't hold
people accountable and I and I strongly
um oppose the fact that people will not
show up and and and participate in the
voting process if you look in most towns
they don't ask people to show up they
don't ask people to come and hand count
most small towns or most towns have
their own group of people that they
continue to go to it's not open to us
and many people would be would love to
participate if we just were
asked and why not hold these people
accountable that's why I'm asking if you
really believe in voter confidence and
you believe in this give something back
to the people and I'll take any
questions any questions represent Brena
thank you um you specifically cited
Windham and the issues there and if if I
understand the sit situation
correctly um the issues came
from elected
officials that the voters selected and
would it not be um possible for the
voters to hold those election officials
accountable at The Ballot Box by
choosing another person to run the
elections uh great question
representative and you always do um it's
really sad that we don't have a press
anymore people don't know about this
this is the problem we're having there's
no more local press people are not
informed and if they're not informed and
know is it not the responsibility of the
candidate for elected office to spread
their message to encourage voters to
turn out to vote for them as opposed to
someone who may
have um caused difficulty in previous
elections I'm not sure I understand the
question because what I'm trying to say
here is that these issues have gone if
the Attorney General is not responding
where else does the voter turn to it's
up to the attorney general to see or how
they're going to react we're saying
after 3 years and two years we have
nothing nothing from the attorney
general nothing from the Secretary of
State the people don't know where to
turn and that's not a good place to be
for voter
confidence thank
Burnham um thank you for taking my
question thank
you do you believe this bill would um
hold the Secretary of State's office and
the Attorney General uh more accountable
to further investigate and and try to um
fix the wrongs within that local area I
think I I'm hopeful what it will do and
this is why I was really this was a
positive this bill is a real positive
because one it shines light as as
representative Brennan was talking about
earlier about Shining Light on something
making it a so people can view what's
really happening or understand but
second of all right now there is no
there's no pressure on anybody to do
anything right to hold anybody
accountable there is none if you look at
the Attorney General how many cases have
they
prosecuted
zero questions representative Bon thank
you is it possible that the attorney
general and the Secretary of State's
office have not found legitimate
evidence to support prosecution of um
crime crimes associated with your claims
that's a great question it hasn't been
adjudicated we're all waiting to hear
and there you know Justice delayed is
not Justice served this is the problem
with voter confidence it's it's like a
soap bubble you know once it breaks it's
you can't bring it back trust is
everything and I think this bill will
help build trust between the local the
voter themselves and and you know the
from no sorry further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
Mr brandano um is there anyone else
signed up to speak I don't believe so um
with that repr wenberg can you grab that
blue sheet uh we'll close the public
um and then we will open up
15 well let me read the accounts first I
apologize z uh zero on there that's fine
um and
then one again
1384 uh online was 13 and
support 14 opposed and there was two
people signed up who didn't speak uh
that were both opposed and with that
I'll close the public hearing house B
1384 and we're actually starting to get
back on time uh house and open up the
public hearing house B 1523 revising the
moderator worksheet for counting votes
in the election um I do have few cards
about this yeah
um I'm here we'll get you afterwards you
can introduce it representative B and
then we can roll
on all right so we're opening the public
hearing of house bill for 1523 revising
the monitor worksheet for counting votes
and elections representative Burnham is
recognized for the purpose of introduc
introducing the
Bill thank you Mr chairman and thank you
fellow committee members
um for those of you who are involved in
your local elections uh you may be
familiar with the moderator's checklist
or not if you're a moderator which I
just learned that um representative
Hamet is that um it is after a long day
and evening it's an arduous process for
the moderator with all the forms they
need to complete and uh this past
primary I sat down with my moderator
just to watch um how he addressed the
this uh worksheet to the moderator's
worksheet um this this came up because
as we were looking at the worksheets in
the past it was very difficult for the
moderators
to come up with a balanced number so
this here is just an inventory so let me
just back up a little bit here um it's
it's so this is completed at the end of
the election night and it's typically
called the election night moderators
worksheet but then there's different
names so I think it's been adjusted a
few times um and uh after even speaking
with uh deputy secretary of state
Hennessee uh when this was being drafted
I had learned uh that there are
additional means of um ballots that are
included but are grouped together so
this kind of gives an overview of the
individual
ballot um groups and that's what we're
really trying to do is account for the
um every ballot and within the group
that they're in um so hopefully uh the
ballot inventory and Reconciliation will
meet the standards for many voter
Integrity groups as well as assist our
moderators with a more concise tally at
the end of the election night and then
after just listening to the bill earlier
um that just might be another one that
we can group so we can have
accountability for the Ada um printout
ballots um so that that might be needed
as well I do have um an amendment that I
passed out along with a sample of the
worksheet I'm kind of one of those if
I'm going to complain about something I
also want to have Solutions so you have
a somewhat um revised worksheet and um
there is an amendment I wasn't able to
get it because um I know how quickly you
want to get through um the bills so it
is waiting um and there might be an
additional amendment to that so that's
why I didn't rush for it after uh
speaking a little bit more in detail
there so the current um worksheet can be
be found in our manual if you you
probably all don't have one because it's
really heavy but I brought mine today I
lugged it here it's it's uh got the
exercise for that one that was great so
you can see um if you had that you can
kind of compare to where it is currently
and where we kind of want to move
forward
um we have heard already the need for
better accountability of our ballots and
that also includes absentee ballots this
process will not ask for any additional
work from the clerk or the moderator
because this process is already being
done by adding a few additional area
areas of tallies the new proposed
worksheet will provide the information
needed to keep track of all the ballots
and provide better accountability of the
ballots one of the things I did note
watching our moderator is sometimes he
had to back in the numbers to kind of
make it work well that's not really the
the way we should be doing it so we want
to have better accountability for the um
inventory of all ballots on the ballots
uh inventory section one the number of
test ballots are now included in the
beginning so in previous they were never
included uh typically the clerk will
receive 100 ballots for them to test um
and so we just thought it's a ballot
even though it's a test ballot they
should be included
um it also uh it separates um that
section also separates the number of
photo copied versus absentee ballots
vers instead of having them grouped
together um the absentee ballots that
are used as official election day
ballots so this is not your absentee
ballots but say they run out and they
they need the ballot so they can
actually grab an absentee ballot and use
that as the official day
ballot um so part two provides its own
section actually let me just back up one
more thing on section one so after
plugging in some numbers and making sure
everything was working out I realized
that in section one E and F are
redundant and so I'm going to recommend
an amendment to remove them um that will
bring us the correct calculation uh for
that section part two provides its own
section for DRS and T ballots inventory
and of course this portion will be
required for the clerk to provide the
moderator with some of the figures but
the clerk will already have them so um
that's easily accessible section three
is formerly B on the current one that
has not changed section four formally C
uh it just has a few edits changing ACU
vote to election machine device because
we will no longer have the ACU vote so
that kind of up dates that section five
is formally D which is the hand count
ballots cast that has not changed and so
part two has an edit from election night
reconciliation form which is another
form that the moderator has to complete
to just reconciliation form because
that's what's listed on the header of
the form so we're just trying to keep
some consistency and clean things up uh
the tally category just adds the
absentee ballot section two and then the
rest Remains the Same
so the updated formula for this
worksheet and the reason why it went to
numbers versus letters is just because
the way that OS set it up so I had to
make it consistent with the bill and so
therefore that's why it's changed to the
numbers it's just the technicality thing
there I guess uh Total 1 I plus total 2
H would then equal total to J and you if
you follow along on there um you can uh
see what how that would total up and it
continues that it equals total three
total four and total section five which
then equals your counts of votes in the
contest and hopefully it all balances
out that's the goal um so this is I do
have that amendment I do want to remove
the other sections so um and I think I
clarified anything there so I'm open to
any questions
Hamlet and thank you representative
burnam um so yeah there are things that
I like about this bill uh I have one I
have a few questions about one question
is in it's on page two down near the
bottom under Section Roman numeral 4
c number
five way down at the bottom hand count
of ballots cast required I'm not sure
what you're referring to because if
you're referring to in the moderators
worksheet that we use now in part
two uh in under votes and contests no no
I'm reading the wrong thing
sorry in part C voter participation
tallied it no sorry it's a different one
um okay in part D you may oh there this
this form is so complicated it is part D
it says you may hand count the total
number of ballots cast do I think that's
not for hand count towns that's
for you know any towns including voting
machine towns it says you may hand count
the total number of ballots
cast but in your
Bill you're saying hand count of ballots
cast is required did you mean
to um yeah see there's another yeah
because that is um option for this and I
think that's what I clarified also for
um machine count cities and towns only
um that I added to that section um
and um
yeah so the required should probably be
removed I'm not sure why that is there
okay because that is that is the um that
is the option but just for the city and
town section because in portion in
section four you have your towns only
that do hand count and then on the right
of that is machine count City towns only
so my understanding is that section five
is if they
um hand count the total number of
ballots cast that you may hand count um
so should they need to that would that's
where it would go okay because there's
additional so some ballots uh are kicked
out of the machine you need to kick you
or they're right in and you have to
count those so that's where that would
go okay um I have a follow-up question
yes as long as everybody's good yep yeah
all right so this is you probably have
um you want you want the test ballots to
be counted and
in Port Portsmouth we've got five Wards
and the city
clerk test you know tests the machines
with the test ballots ahead of time so
we never we we the people out in the in
the wards
working uh don't ever see the test
ballots so that's me just adding one
extra step complicating things that we
don't we we don't even know how many
test ballots there were I guess the city
clerk would have to tell us that right
and I believe the city clerk is
available that day
correct not in all Wards well she floats
around to the different
Wards yeah so why I guess my question is
why do you want the test ballots
included why is that important in the
reconciliation so great question it's
it's an inventory it's a ballot that's
there so we want to make sure that we're
counting all
ballots that's
all
sure the committee oh there you go
representative Brennan thank you um I
seem to recall having a bill perhaps
last week where the Secretary of State
um or deputy secretary of state I can't
remember which one went
through the entire inventory
process um
that they do to make sure that ballots
are tracked
responsibly um and accounted for
appropriately and I'm wondering
if what this bill is trying to do
conflicts with the inventory protocols
that the Secretary of State office
currently maintains sure great question
um so it's just a process of chain of
custody so the
clerk or clerks I don't know how many
are available their office counts all
the ballots when they receive them so
they're all accounted they're sorted and
they're put back in the boxes prior um
before the
elections this is just kind of taking
that information and and putting it all
there so we're tracking the actual
inventory of the ballot in the process
night
please is there currently a problem that
actually needs to be resolved that this
bill is trying to correct
or um is
this oh I'll I'll just leave it at that
is there a problem that this bill is
trying to
correct
um I don't see I I don't know of um
specific ones but it is just a tracking
of ballots and and um from some of the
issues that we've seen uh in other towns
there are some that are un
unaccounted so it would just be
providing
[Music]
um uh secured um
ballots and inventory making sure that
they're all accounted from the beginning
until the end of the
we just
clarify um so the moderator's checklist
on page 423 of our election procedures
manual um there's a sample work sheet
there and then that corresponds
to uh RSA 6 5973 which is the general
content of return and that lists out
which votes or which ballots are to be
counted and stuff so a lot of this
um bill is trying to harmonize and align
the RSA with the actual election
law manual worksheet is that correct yes
that is
correct thank you as representative
HR you describe what
a um test ballot
is so there are extra ballots that are
given um along with the um ballots for
election day specifically to test the
machines prior to the
election and they're accounted for and
then they're put back into the
box
followup yep represent Hammer thank you
um so they're put back into what
boooks um that I'm not sure that's uh
it's uh I'm I'm I'm I it may be the
folder they came in I think I'm not sure
which process the test ballots come back
in or how they arrived maybe somebody
else might know but
um
sorry
um trying to phrase this as a question
so I I have seen um the Hudson moderator
uh take the test ballots run them
through the machine according to the
protocol and then package them up in
their own separate box appropriately
labeled in that way would that sound uh
similar to what goes on in your town yes
I just wasn't sure if it in a box or in
an envelope so I do know they go back
into some type of
raer have you consulted with moderators
and are they comfortable with the
revisions to this yes well I've
consulted with mine because I see how
distru he is every time and um I I would
like to hear from others as well um I
just know that this has been an ongoing
issue with um you know when you're if
you're going to have inventory you want
the numbers to balance out at the end
and it has not been happening for the
most part and sometimes it's just off by
a little bit and sometimes it's off by a
lot um I I when we were drafting this
and constituents that I was working with
they they had copies of the checklist
from their towns and cities and they
were some of them were off by a lot and
so how does that happen it should be a
simple process and I'm trying to provide
that in this work this new revised
worksheet because um sometimes as we've
heard today ballots are added they just
because we the towns and cities receive
them there's other methods of them being
added in that day um and so we just want
accountability for those as
well we're going to do last question
here so representative where so we heard
dep deputy secretary Hennessy talk about
how how challenging sometimes getting
the accurate count is and the concerns
about labeling that as
non-compliance um would you think that
this moderator's worksheet that is now
aligned with the RSA would in fact
reduce the possibility or the
probability of calculation errors
because there's a fuller accountability
and Reconciliation of the ballots being
provided to the town or city
Ward is definitely the goal and I'm sure
with just a couple more um edits and the
amendment will'll be I think we'll be
really in good shape for for the next
run with these um worksheets that is the
goal thank you okay thank you
representative vernham uh only under one
card is uh for deputy secretary of state
Aaron Hennessy um represent you grab
me
Erin Hennessy deputy secretary of state
um I just want to start out with I
applaud anyone who wants to talk about
reconciliations as an accountant um my
fear is that the way this is currently
drafted um it it increases the
complication of the process and we will
get more errors um versus um our goal in
our office is to simplify the process to
make sure its accuracy and transparency
is correct um there's several instances
that were not brought up I'm not going
to discuss every anything that the
committee has already spoken about but
um we like to see and I know that um
especially when the committee takes a
look at 664 we just want to see um
consistent language throughout a um
throughout the process so changing um
official ballot to election day Ballot
or in here it's also referred to General
ballot um which has a diff very specific
and different meanings um we want to
make sure that the language is
consistent throughout um out the
election chapter so that when a um
moderator is actually reconciling they
know exactly what they're supposed to be
putting in here so there's a lot of
consens
inconsistencies as it's written
currently um one weird thing is that it
takes out the moderator's signature for
some reason on the moderator's uh
worksheet instead of um and ads the
clerk has to sign it and one supervisor
of the checklist has to sign it so just
things in here we when we make changes
broadly like this to try and help
improve the process I I like to look at
every single word um and I know it's
difficult because the way um
it was drafted it's a replace all and so
it's very difficult to see what has
changed in in the language um but I'm um
I'm happy to work with the
representative to Fig see if there's a
um more simplified version that would
get to the end that she's looking at um
also I just want to point out um having
just sat through the last bill um we do
not separate out
um ballots that have been have gone
through an excess ible voting machine
those are official ballots that are fed
into the printer and the voters um votes
are marked on there for the sole purpose
of making that um vote of that um
individual voter um private so we would
not ever want to put those aside or mark
them any differently um just to maintain
their secret ballot I'm happy to take
questions from the committee
representative
Brennan you have concerns about your
current inventory process for tracking
ballots um that this bill would
resolve thank you for the question no I
Nowa
Lane um to get back to representative
Hamlet's question where in cities the
clerk will test the machines and then
they go to the Awards so there's no test
ballots by those
moderators is is am I miss so but this
seems to require test
ballots and and there aren't
any thank thank you for the question the
test ballots are separate and
um in cities the city clerks do a lot of
the work and it's a little different
than the town process but in general the
test ballots which are 50 of them um
which you can use 35 of the test ballots
that we've sent and 15 absente D ballots
if you wish to substitute out those to
test in a different way but those are
put back in the envelope they came in
and they're put in the side pocket of
the device um so that when the um
moderator opens up the ward or or
polling place they can um see evidence
that the long tape's in there from the
test process that it was actually tested
before they put the device
into use for the day um also when the
AG's Department comes to look they can
see that the device was properly tested
and the information is there available
to
them follow so how did say in conquered
you know there's what I don't know 10 12
Wars um how do you do that in the
different polling places I mean is there
a stack do they test a stack for each
Ward thank you for the question yes each
individual device is tested with their
specific Wards ballots and they're
supposed to test them with 50 ballots
going four different directions so 200
total
votes
yeah questions from the committee seeing
none thank you secretary Hennessy I
don't have any other pink cards in my
possession on this bill there was no one
signed up uh on the blue sheet and
online there were 14 in support and
three opposed the committee will be
recessed into till 1: p.m. for the
introduction of House Bill 1557 enjoy
your
lunch
okay 1:00 and we're back going to reopen
the public hearing for the house
election law committee
going to open up the public hearing for
House Bill 1557 FN requiring the
secretary of state to enter into a
membership agreement with the electronic
registration information center
representative Angela Brennan is
recognized for the purpose of
introduction of the Bill thank you
chairman Barry and members of house
election law for the record my name is
Angela Brennan I represent Bo and
Hopkinton in marac District 9 today I'm
here to introduce House Bill 1557 which
requires the secret Secretary of State
to enroll New Hampshire in the
electronic registration information
center also known as Eric by joining 25
other States including every New England
State as an Eric member New Hampshire
will show we are serious about our
shared goals of improving election
Integrity increasing the accuracy of
voter roles building confidence in our
election process and providing much
needed assistance to our local election
officials here in house election law we
often hear testimony from people about
these matters and several bills this
year have claimed to be solutions for
improving election integrity and
increasing the accuracy of voter roles
here's some good news we can accomplish
these shared goals by passing this bill
to join the only proven reliable
sophisticated election support system
that utilizes numerous secure data
sources to identify voters
moving both within our state and to
other Eric member states allowing for
election officials to clean our
checklist after every
election and quickly identify any
possible instances of suspected voter
fraud to be brought to law enforcement
authorities for prompt thorough
investigation Eric is the only secure
nonpartisan nonprofit long-established
costeffective program governed and
funded by member states to ensure any
instance of voter fraud is caught
quickly by identifying voters who have
moved in or out of state or passed away
we can be confident our voter checklists
are
clean this bill if passed requires a
secretary to enter into a membership
agreement effective no later than
January 31
2025 which gives plenty of time to
review membership requirements um and
begin that process which is an easy one
um the bill says that funding shall be
provided by any federal funds for the
purposes of election related expenses
including help America vote act dollars
which we know that we have plenty of um
Eric requires a one-time membership fee
of
$25,000 um and then there are annual
dues that are related to the um voter
population of each state
because New Hampshire is on the lower
end of the spectrum um the beginning
amount is about
$377,000 and that is an annual fee
certainly we can afford that to make
sure that our elections are secure and
accurate and funded by federal
dollars um I have provided you a letter
that has been sent by secretaries of
state and top election officials from
across the country who are members of
Eric and they have found that this is um
the most
important organization
nonprofit um that has kept their voter
roles
accurate um they are eager for New
Hampshire to join Eric because the more
states that are involved the more
effective Eric can be for all member
states I've also provided information
about the technology and security used
this is a very secure system it has been
around for over 10 years there has not
been one instance of um data breach in
that
time there are states who have left Eric
that is
true but some of those are actually
looking to return to Eric because they
found that in their desire to create a
system similar to Eric that operates
Within their own State they are have
failed to do so they cannot match the
security and accuracy provided by the
Eric data
collection um there are states that are
looking to get back into Eric which
means they have to pay the membership
fee again so they have realized their
mistake and they want back in we also
know that there are several states that
we anticipate will be joining Eric this
year creating again a more effective
system completely governed and funded by
those
States um we
have heard some hesitation about linking
the Department of Motor Vehicle records
and the Secretary of State and voter
records um I have to admit I
find that a bit
frustrating that um there may be some
who don't want communication between our
our different Departments of the state
it's just as frustrating to me as when a
a town board and a school board fail to
communicate you're all serving the same
people uh increased communication serves
the people better so uh I completely do
not believe that argument that the DMV
and the voter files or Secretary of
State's office should not
communicate I I will add that this is
and emphasize that this is a
bipartisan um system it is um supported
by a variety of States 25 including the
state of Georgia um Secretary of State
Brad raffensberger says maintaining
accurate voter roles protects the
Integrity of our elections systems like
Eric are an important tool for election
administrators and help prevent people
from being registered in and trying to
vote in multiple States states that
prioritize best practices and actual
election Integrity over politics are
going to stay in Eric and have clearer
and more accurate voter roles than those
leave we all know that election
integrity and voter confidence is a high
priority for this committee for many
members who have come and spoken to our
committee before and for the Secretary
of State as well um and it is supported
joining Eric would be supported by the
committee on voter confidence because
increasing the accuracy of our voter
roles or voter checklist was a high
priority finding out of that committee
on voter
confidence um some people may be
concerned about security as I mentioned
Eric has never been victim of um
hacking and that's important because
states that are trying to create their
own system can't match the security of
ER
um Eric distributes to each member an
application that applies a cryptographic
one-way hash to sensitive data elements
before the jurisdiction submits the data
to Eric this Eric hashing application
uses a module provided by IBM in
conjunction with sensing which
implements a very complicated one-way
key you cannot a no one can access this
data except for the designated member of
the designated member state of
Eric the hashing application converts
these data into what appears to be a
string of random characters making the
data significantly more difficult for a
potential hacker to
utilize we take our elections here
seriously the security of our elections
is Paramount Eric increases is that
security of our
elections any state that is serious
about efficient safe accurate secure
elections is a member state of Eric it's
time for us to join our neighbors all of
our neighboring states that are members
of Eric and States across the country
that are members of Erica it's time to
join them and say to our constituents
that we Val value our elections now I
have heard that there has been
some hesitation or concern about one
component of Eric that requires Outreach
to likely eligible but unregistered
voters this is a membership requirement
yes but the state gets to determine how
to do that voter Outreach and it simply
tells the likely eligible voter how to
register to vote when we have our new
election information portal it may be
simply providing a
website we share a goal of increasing
our voter participation we should always
strive to reach that 100% voter
participation could you
imagine this voter
Outreach does not force anyone to
register it does not Target anyone
suspected of being a member of any
particular party it simply says hey you
moved you may not be registered yet but
registering is quick and easy just visit
your town clerk's office and bring these
uh papers with you and you can sign up
or here's our new election information
portal website and you can sign up begin
that registration process online quick
and easy the membership requirement in
Eric for this voter Outreach is once
every two
years this is not a heavy burden is is
not a heavy lift for the Secretary of
State's office to do this
Outreach now there are many states who
have found that um doing the Outreach to
likely eligible voters is better when
it's done more frequently because you
can make sure that your voter checklist
is most accurate there are some states
that will do it every 60 days there's
nothing in the membership agreement that
would dictate to the Secretary of State
when or how to conduct this Outreach
years I anticipate that you may have
some questions and instead of rambling
on I want to thank you for your
attention and if you do have questions
you then
we
up thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question representative
Brennan um just a quick question um on
this
um
so I I want to bring two things in the
bill together and try and understand
them better so lines 8 and and 15 and 16
talk about duplicate voter information
and cases of duplicated voter voting
record suspected of illegal
voting um so that's the first part um
there's also the fiscal note at the end
um that talks about a Max of
174,000 plus and there are three three
pluses here plus the undetermined fiscal
impact of data security staffing needs
and compliance Plus plus the uncertain
financial implications of Staffing and
mailing Clause plus additional General
funds due to potential
expenses so I've heard repeatedly
usually in my left ear that our
elections are safe and secure and that
this bill this bill seems to focus on
duplicate voting and I'm just wondering
if
174,000 and plus these undefined
undetermined expenses really account for
the number of d duplicate of voting
records that we're going that we really
need to address I mean how many are
there are there are there that many that
it warrant um that potential
expenditure thank you for the question
um Eric does track duplicative voter
registration it also tracks cross state
movers instate updates um duplicative
and deceased voters um to make sure that
our voter roles are most accurate I know
that that is a priority for you and this
committee and I think that the expense
that the state would need to make um to
invest in membership of
this um organization or this
program far
cost so um if we look at the uh Eric
bylaws from February 23 on page 19 it
states there's a mandatory requirement
to keep Eric membership and I'll I'll
read quote when the member receives Eric
data regarding eligible or possible
eligible citizens who are not registered
to vote the memb shall at a minimum
initiate contact with each and every
eligible or possibly eligible Citizen
and inform them how to register to vote
this um this seems like a potential cost
um uh each member shall have until
October 1st or 15 days before the close
of registration whichever is earlier of
the next federal general election year
to initiate contact with at least 95% of
the eligible or potentially eligible
citizens on whom data was provided and
address validation was performed now
just doing some very rough rough math
bear with me I'm an engineer I love
numbers so but we have 1,400,000 people
there were about 800,000 in the 2020
presidential election that's probably
the max um we won't get more than that
on our local or even the midterms if you
subtract students um from the educ
Department of Education 2024 doe numbers
that's about you know another 200,000
gone um and then just taking as a
ballpark figure another 100,000 you're
still left with almost 300,000 people
whom you would have to initiate contact
with that seems like a big mailing
expense um so I I'm I have some concerns
about these undetermined costs and the
mandates that are in the Eric bylaws
that would require you to initiate
contract this number of people it seems
um really quite uh imposing in terms of
putting the Secretary of State's office
as to having to do all this
work was that a question yes it was I
mean what you how would you answer that
thank you for the question um the
wonderful thing about the Eric bylaws is
they are created by the member states
themselves and if we were to enroll in
Eric our secretary of state or his
design would have a role in determining
future bylaws and could potentially make
those adjustments um along with the
other member states it's also important
to know that Eric does not dictate how
to go about uh conducting that voter
Outreach in fact one of the
um one of the pieces of data that can be
collected is email addresses and so
perhaps if the Secretary of State wanted
to reduce costs they might do some of
the Outreach via email additionally
there's no uh requirement that the
mailer must be 10 pages long at a size
greater than uh typical sheet of paper
in fact it could be a simple postcard it
could be at the side of our pink cards
um the information is simply how to
register to vote and we don't need a lot
of information or paper space um to
provide that to likely eligible but
unregistered voters who we should all
want to register to vote and participate
in our elections because we take our
you
um which is a question Republicans so
clerk um thank you for taking my
question um regarding the uh fellow
member states um have they reported any
issues with implementation or management
of the Eric system and if so how have
they addressed those issues there have
not been issues any issues that do come
up are you know again this is completely
governed and run by the member states
themselves so problem solving is done
within the states and with their fellow
member states um it's also important to
know we are not doing any of
this we are not involved in any checking
of data to keep our voter list most
accurate we are not involved in any
Outreach to likely eligible but
unregistered voters this is something we
should be doing if we care about our
elections if we care about election
integrity and voter participation we
Eric PR
Brien thank you Mr chairman where is Ed
Eric headquartered right now Eric is
made up of member states and so each
state is part of Eric they have an
office in Washington DC they do not give
out the address of that because they
want to maintain security um but Eric is
member states it is not some Shadow
organization it is literally the member
states that govern that create the rules
that fund the program um and make sure
that um you're getting the information
that you need
followup representative Lane wants to
yield for a followup because you were up
next representative Lane okay so yes
you're good to
go it's been a little while since I paid
Eric but uh some states have joined and
then left and do you know anything about
that if you don't then maybe some
speakers after you would know something
about that thank you thank you for the
question and I'm sure some other
speakers do know um I do have a list of
member states and it is true that there
have been states that have left the
number of member states was higher than
it is right now um we know that we are
living in very divisive times where the
prevalence of disinformation has
influenced people um to
make one might characterize them as poor
decisions in fact states that have left
Eric that have sought to create their
own system to maintain their voter
checklist the most accurate way possible
and the most secure way possible
have not been able to do that and they
are looking to rejoin Eric um because
they they miss the value and benefits of
being a member state of Eric um I'm
happy to provide you with a list of
states that currently um our member
states in fact I'll read them right off
to you Alaska Arizona Colorado
Connecticut Delaware Georgia Illinois
Connecticut I'm sorry Kentucky Maine
Massachusetts Maryland Michigan
Minnesota Nevada New Jersey New Mexico
Oregon Pennsylvania Rhode Island South
Carolina Utah Vermont Washington
Wisconsin and the District of Colombia
you'll notice that all New England
states except for New Hampshire are
members of Eric and you know also that
we experience a lot of people coming and
going in New Hampshire there's a lot of
moving between the New England states a
lot of people that come and go between
New Hampshire and Massachusetts if we
ever wanted to catch voting in both
States New Hampshire and Massachusetts
Eric is the way to catch those voters
you know we've heard
um wild conspiracy theories about buses
of Voters coming up from Massachusetts
to vote in New Hampshire elections never
proven but the only the way you could is
through Eric it would be able to tell
you if a voter had voted in both
Massachusetts and New Hampshire so if
that is something that worries you I
hope that you would support uh joining
Eric representative Lane oh I'm sorry I
thought you had your hand up I apologize
uh representative uh
bay sir chairman thank you for taking my
question this question is of interest to
me as an
immigrant uh does Eric allow for a
possibility of uh registering uh new
immigrants in theory as soon as they
come out of their um oath taking to be
uh new citizens where you can present
them with with an online device such an
iPad or or or a PC so that they can
register to vote just when they became
citizens of the United States thank you
for the question um Eric does not
control voter registration at all it
does not um
provide voter
registration um information the state
would be able to provide new immigrants
or new Americans with the information
needed to get them registered to vote
but that would not be within the purview
you I believe representative barham's up
next alternate so you guys know thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question how can we be certain that uh
unfair election Advantage isn't provided
to companies who have pre-existing data
sharing
agreements I'm not sure I quite
understand your question there you know
there's a lot uh it speaks about sharing
data so how do we not know that they
have pre-existing data sharing
agreements with other um
companies well well again Eric is made
up of States not companies there is not
you know some Shadow company taking your
data and um manipulating it in any way
and so you know I think that's the best
way I can answer your question um there
may be others who can provide it but
I've also provided you with a
documentation about the security
protocols um that Eric takes seriously
um and have been approved by um and
evaluated by additional um
Security
Services uh cyber security firms um to
ensure that that Eric has strong data
security practices and there have been
no critical findings of the way that
they manage data which is again managed
completely by the states okay thank
you
rafter thanks for taking my question um
could this reduce staff time or expenses
that we currently incur to maintain
checklists and update them absolutely
this would absolutely help our local
election officials with the maintenance
of the checklist and could certainly
have an impact on um costs that
municipalities face in their voter
checklist maintenance um it's also
important to notice that that states
that are in Eric that have um same day
registration like we have here have seen
a decrease in the lines on Election Day
for registering to vote because of the
voter Outreach that is done um to make
sure that likely eligible voters know
how easy it is to register in advance of
an election um that they don't need to
register on the same day they can
advance other questions from the
you believe in Manchester W 10 we had a
voter vote and then this voter went on
to neighboring town of gtown and voted
with Eric would this might have been
stopped would he been stopped from
voting again
instate Eric does track instate movers
and after every election would be able
to provide the data necessary and flag
this particular transaction to make sure
that that person was prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law as
investigated um thoroughly by the
office um further questions from the
committee uh representative
qua M thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question how many states have left Eric
and have any of those States actually
returned thank you you know off the top
of my head I don't know the exact number
of seates that have left but I know that
currently there are 25 member states
with more expected to join this year who
have not yet been members of Eric um and
there are some who have left and are
attempting to return back to
yous from the
committee okay uh I have mine and you
already probably know what it's going to
be um so the state constitution see if I
can bring it up here I was flipping
through stuff about Eric while I was
talking to you um the state constitution
has in it a right to privacy so the it's
mment 2B so right after 2A which is one
of my faves uh but 2B is also one of my
favorites passed I think we passed this
in 2018 right so it's not exactly not
exactly one of those old ones uh an
individuals right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent so if we enter
into
Eric some third party is looking at our
data via the DMV right that's how it
works the DMV data is shared the DMV
data is private the voter list is
actually not private the voter list is
actually public um but how is the
sharing of this information even if it's
secure even it's with a third party
that's blind how is that not a violation
of the New Hampshire Constitution's
inherent right to privacy which
specifically mentions private
information the information is not
private in fact the information that is
evaluated through this data sharing is
already with the government name address
driver's license number these are all
part of governmental records and so I
reject the premise that it is violation
of the Constitution um we are talking
about
uh specific information that the
you questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um next
up is Aubrey Friedman may I just add
quickly Mr chairman that the voters are
on the side of Eric there was a a study
done a survey done by St A's just this
past November where uh it was found that
75% of new New Hampshire voters support
New Hampshire joining Eric and I think
we should listen to our voters because
they know best thank you I hear you I am
familiar with that survey I would uh
welcome anyone to look at the wording of
that survey because I took
it um oh actually late entry here I
apologize we're going to hold on you
because we have the Secretary of State's
card just made it to my desk and I like
to usually like to bring him in right
after the induction of the bill so you
will be up next I apologize but I just
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Secretary of State David
scanland uh and I want to give you my
thoughts on this bill uh first of
all the people I've spoken to around the
country and secretaries of state's
offices have said that this program
works well for them I've never heard of
anybody speak poorly of it however uh
recently
the program was more politicized made
more politicized than it was when nine
Republican states decided uh to leave
the
program and I was not a part of those
discussions so I don't know the specific
reasons that they used but I know that
one of them was a
frustration of uh the rules that are
used by uh by Eric and the inability to
change those to make them more
compatible with what those States wanted
to do and I'll get into uh some examples
of that in a
second
um New
Hampshire uh the Secretary of State's
office within the next couple of months
is about ready
to uh uh roll out the next generation of
our Statewide voter registration
database a brand new system and as part
of that we are incorporating the
national change of address
information which is some of the stuff
that Eric does uh it will be easier to
share the death data that we collect uh
through our division of Vital Records uh
into that
system and uh and I believe that it is
going to make it a lot easier for our
supervisors of the checklist to maintain
that database uh at at the local level
uh in addition to that this committee
has heard a couple of bills that deal
with uh more frequent intervals in terms
of a verification of the checklist
formally called purging but that would
be a more frequent review of inactive
voters on that list to help keep those
uh lists
clean so with that understanding also
I'd like to say that I've been uh
involved in this election process since
uh 2002 that's the same year that the
help America vote Act passed Congress
Congress and it was the first time that
New Hampshire was required to create and
maintain a Statewide centralized voter
database and I can tell you the
discussion at the time was that we are
going to have all of this personal and
private voter information in one place
and how important it is to keep that
information private and confidential and
the commitment at the time and I was a
part of that was
we're going to honor that uh you know
that uh thing for the New Hampshire
voters that we're not going to Simply
give away all of this data that we now
level
so what Eric
requires is a regular data dump of the
information that we have not only in the
elections database but also in the motor
vehicles database and that dump includes
private personal confidential
information in the past when we have uh
in the past when we did a a an
interstate match uh we sent data to a
central system and our data was matched
up against the data from other states it
was not kept uh it was simply a match
and we received uh a lot of matches back
of what appeared to be duplicate voters
I think the number was close to a
100,000 uh but it was very basic
information New Hampshire was one of the
few states that went through the
exercise of going through all of that
information uh eliminating names
whenever we added middle names initials
looked at birth dates stuff that was in
our system and we narrowed it down to
about
250 suspicious uh voters and out of that
there were a handful was probably around
10 uh where there were uh convictions
based on prosecutions for inappropriate
voting double voting uh that was found
as a result of that check a really small
number when you boil it right down but
this is what the the the agreement says
uh for members of uh of Eric this is
what they have to agree
to now within 60 days of the
certification date and at least every 60
days thereafter the member shall
transmit the following data to Eric all
inactive and active voter files
excluding those records that are
confidential or predicted from
Disclosure by law including those fields
identified in exhibit B and exhibit B is
a list of uh the data that's requested
names addresses phone numbers birth
dates things like that
uh and all licensing or identification
records from Motor Vehicles departments
including those fields unrelated to
voter eligibility such as Fields related
to an individual's driving
record including those fields identified
as exhibit the MV motor vehicle
data Motor Registration data and motor
vehicle data shall be collectively
referred to as member data under no
circumstances shall the member transmit
an individual's record where the record
contains documentation or other
information indicating that the
individual is a non-citizen of the
United
States so that's number one it's it is a
complete dump of personal and private
information to a third-party entity um
that is not the state of New
Hampshire now the next part that I have
an issue
with oh let me just refer you to the
bill while we're on that topic real
quick
on lines uh starting on line 11 through
13 a sentence says that the Secretary of
State shall ensure that any information
or data shared between agencies is
protected by security processes and
protocols and that any information or
data that is of confidential nature
remains
confidential that's fine with me in
terms of the Statewide voter
registration database that's my
responsibility I own that and if that
system is hacked into or breached
somehow that's on me but I have no
authority over motor vehicle records uh
housed by the divisional Motor
Vehicles or any any other agency that
might end up providing information under
this
statute and I have no authority over
what Eric would do uh with the data once
they have it I can't guarantee even
though they have they might have a good
track record I cannot guarantee uh that
that information is not going to be
hacked or breached or or uh so I think
that's an inappropriate Clause to have
in this uh piece of
legislation
then this goes on to say that the
Secretary of State shall consistent with
membership requirements
receive uh Eric reports for the purposes
of improving the accuracy of voter
registration data for which data
provides evidence of eligible or
potentially eligible citizens who are
not registered to vote and initiate
contact of each eligible or potentially
eligible Citizen and supply information
on how to register to
vote that is the next issue that I have
with this piece of
legislation is that there should not be
a third party dictating to New Hampshire
how we are going to reach out and and
encourage voters to register to vote
that should be a decision that is made
by the legislature and the citizens of
the State of New Hampshire and we should
not put ourselves in a position where we
a third party dictating how we are going
to conduct that part of our election
process so uh with that Mr chairman uh
I'd be happy to answer any questions I
just one uh there were there were nine
states that left the Eric program uh I
have not heard that any of them are
considering coming back although uh that
may
be enough um questions from the
committee uh representative prudo
O'Brien thank you thank you Mr chairman
uh Mr secretary do you know why they
left the can you just sum that up again
for us thank you I can tell you what I
heard again I was not a part of those uh
conversations um uh one was the fact
that there are Provisions in the Eric
program like the one that I just
mentioned about having to reach out to
voters as a requirement of belonging to
the program and uh concerns were
expressed over for that and uh there was
no desire to remove those concerns on
the part of Eric um I understand that
there were some issues with individuals
that were participating uh on the board
of directors uh but uh yeah that's all I
regard I have a followup along that same
line um so I have to go last but is it
concerning to you or your office that
over a third of the members have left
this program in the last
year I think it's an interesting fact
although I I'm not looking at this
program from that perspective uh I I I
think that if there was a program out
there that we where New Hampshire could
match its data up with the data from
other states uh and not have that data
kept anywhere other than just providing
that information I think that would make
sense and I would certainly be happy to
do it with our neighbors in New
England uh representative
Lane thank you Secretary of State um I
think I heard you say that Eric tells
you how the agreement tells you how to
reach out and and I I guess I heard from
the other speaker that that was not the
case that it was up to you on how you
wanted to do it and I thought in in a s
in your own time frame but maybe I
misunderstood could you clarify that
please
sure so this is uh I'm reading right
from the membership
agreement when a when the member
receives Eric data regarding eligible or
possibly eligible citizens who are not
registered to vote the member shall at a
minimum initiate contact with each and
every eligible or Poss ly eligible
Citizen and inform them how to register
to vote each member shall have until
October 1st or 15 days before the close
of registration whichever is earlier of
the next federal general election year
to initiate the contact with at least
90%
95% of the eligible or potentially
eligible citizens on whom data was
provided and address validation was
performed formed as described
above and then it it continues on in a
fairly lengthy uh paragraph from there
but to me that's a requirement that uh
the state has to reach out to uh
identified eligible or potentially
eligible uh
made questions from the
wey so I understand that um as Eric
generates this data that
um that actually Eric also has an a data
sharing agreement with the center for
election Innovation and research CER
C and that that data set that data
sharing agreement would theoretically
allow them
[Music]
to provide New Hampshire voter
information to Seer from
Eric um there's
no Clarity or prohibitions in the bylaws
at least as I've read the Eric bylaws
from February 23 about that and
um there's also been some discussion
about
some states uh
using
uh the c or C are using the information
in some states to bolster registration
on one side in particular I won't say
which side um but do you have any
concerns I if if this data
sharing uh would occur with seir would
you have any concerns about how that
might affect um registration and and
voting in New
Hampshire well first I'm not aware of a
sharing agreement um that's that's news
to me and and I'm not saying it's not
the case it could very well be but that
just gets back to my initial comments
about being serious uh with strong
conviction that New Hampshire data the
the information on New Hampshire voters
should remain private and confidential
just as we agreed to when we first
created the database system
um those states that Acquire data um you
know I would believe or certainly want
to believe that that they would use that
data uh in the best interests of the
voters in their state and uh that's how
Bay Secretary of State's office engage
in any type of uh proactive Outreach to
voters if the question is do we send
mailings out to individuals uh the
answer is uh we don't uh but we do have
very active programs through social
media and conventional media to reaching
out to let voters know about dates that
are coming up uh in order to register to
vote uh we initiated a really neat
program this year where uh we have
reached out to uh new American citizens
those who have been recently
naturalized uh we have a brochure for
them uh that information comes in
multiple languages uh we have a video uh
that was produced with members of those
minority communities uh and the
Secretary of State's office encouraging
people to vote that's up on our website
uh and so we are actively reaching out
to potentially new voters
um we just did the great fourth grade
sticker contest and I know it's going to
be a few years before they can show up
at the clerk's office but it gets them
thinking about when I get old enough
when I'm old enough I want to register
to vote so you know we we do have
programs in place where we are
encouraging that uh opportunity may I
follow
up
um should Eric be part of New
Hampshire's
future
um would those
um programs that you've mentioned you've
been doing would would that not be
responsive to the requirements of Eric
do you feel that there are things
specifically that you're not doing that
needs to be done on account of Eric and
again this is a legislative policy
decision but what what Eric is calling
for which we do not do is identify
individuals who appear to meet the
qualifications to be a voter but have
not yet
registered and and it would require my
office to make a contact with those
voters just letting them know that they
it representative prudo M Brien thank
you thank you Mr chairman uh that makes
me think of a few things what you just
said so would data from the Department
of Motor Vehicles be shared and would
that I'm trying to remember what I used
when I when I uh register to to when I
got my license would that include Social
Security information my birth
certificate passport information is that
something that they would be gathering
and then if I felt strongly about not
voting for example maybe I had a
religious um obstacle to that would that
still be shared with them would that
would that DMV information still be
shared with this outof state
organization so I'm I'm really glad you
asked that
question first I did not take a close
look at what DMV information uh is being
requested although it sounds like it's
pretty comprehensive but New Hampshire
is also unique in that we are one of
just a handful of states that is exempt
from the national voter registration Act
of 199
3 and at that time there was for those
states that fell into that act uh there
became a direct tie between elections
and Motor Vehicles so that anybody going
to get a driver's license could also uh
register to vote and because of that
most States 40 plus states in the
country have their elections offices and
their elections information
already uh matched up and and and
coinciding with their motor vehicle
data that has not happened in New
Hampshire because we have not had to do
it there is a provision in Hava that
allows and
requires uh the elections data be
matched up against the motor vehicle
data so that we can identify same names
same birth dates but maybe uh uh
different addresses so that we can clean
up the records and keep those clean but
we do not have any access beyond that to
motor vehicle records we do not keep
motor vehicle records and motor vehicles
does not keep any elections records so
for New Hampshire to participate in Eric
there would also have to be an agreement
with uh the division of motor
vehicles uh we would have to work out
our
um uh electronic systems to combine that
data before it could be sent to Eric and
I don't think that that's a big deal
based on conversations I've had with the
commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology but uh it is a
big deal in the sense that that the data
that we have on citizens of New
Hampshire are two distinctly separate
silos and uh that would have to be
worked
out
lane thank you Secretary State
um I I got a little confused about the
information that we would be sharing
with Eric and I think you said there was
confidential information that would be
shared and what is that confidential
information that's not already
public well number one it would be birth
date
information
um
so it would be all name fields all
address Fields driver's license or state
ID number last four digits of social
security number date of birth activity
dates current record status phone number
uh email address or other electronic
contact method uh there is a provision
that says if that information is
collected by the member State and we do
not collect phone numbers or email add
addresses for the purpose of entering it
database further questions from the
weary for pursuing that earlier Venture
where you
uh look through all those names and
sorted out who were the duplicates and
who were the problematics the 10
problematic folks um there was a Yale
study back in about 2021 that that
estimated that Eric had a 4% false
positive rate and so I'm
curious
um how how would the Secretary of
State's office handle you know false
positives and you know where someone is
basically claiming to be or or Eric
would identify those persons as that
person as a duplicative voter but but in
fact there was a reasonable explanation
and that's how how would your office
handled
that well it would it would require uh a
very thorough review and when we went
through the exercise the last time it is
mind-boggling to know how many people
have the same name and the same birth
date uh in this country it is
remarkable and so um
you have to continue to look at ways to
narrow uh the field by just adding more
information that is available from
whatever sources you could find and when
we reached a certain point uh we had to
hand
over uh the potential matches to the
Attorney General's office who have a
much
broader uh array of sources of
information uh because of their law
enforcement ability they have databases
that uh Secretary of State's office
simply does not have access to and then
uh if they they end up being convinced
that you know they have found uh matches
for duplicate voting then then they do
an investigation and so I mean it is a
very thorough uh wellth thought out
process a 4% false positive uh wouldn't
concern me at
all
Rapter Mr chair um Mr secretary um going
back to the requirement to reach out to
potential voters which you identified as
a burden if you don't follow that
requirement to the letter would you get
kicked out of Eric or is there some
other penalty or
sanction first of all don't get me wrong
I didn't say that was a burden what what
I was objecting to was a a
third-party uh instructing New Hampshire
that they had to do it if the
legislature said this is what you're
going to do uh we would make it happen
um uh get getting back to uh Eric there
are Provisions in here of what happens
if you don't follow through with uh the
information and I'll admit I didn't read
those as closely as I read the parts
that I just conveyed to you to you
hearing he we're going
to I know I'm I'm asking the committee
to to get to the end of this um but I'm
not going I understand the importance of
this so I'm not going to cut off
questions but let's uh let's be direct
representative
Bay do you have an estimate of how many
eligible but unregistered voters there
are in New
Hampshire no I don't uh but I can tell
you that among all the states New
Hampshire has a very very very high
participation rate of uh citizens that
participate to vote here and so it it
the number of Voters that we have in
that category I would guess is much
smaller than it would be in some of the
other
states other questions to so you know
the number you're looking for is called
the VAP ler age participation and the
Secretary of State's office produces a
report about it every two years it's
available directly on their website I'll
do the plug for you um with that I don't
see any other questions Mr secretary
thank you um I am going to recess this
hearing for the purpose of introduction
of House Bill 1569 the sponsor is here
so we're going to do what we did earlier
we're going to allow the sponsor to
introduce and then we're going to recess
and go right back to the next this
bill I have a question um unlike the
other sponsor I think there will be a
lot of
questions um so are we going to do those
go through those you're totally allowed
to ask your questions I just I try to
when the sponsors are here I try to
okay allow them the okay opportunity to
do it on time um so representative Lynn
uh you're recognized for the purpose of
we've recessed uh
15 57 we are coming right back to it um
and we are now opening up the public
hearing on
1569 relative to eliminating voner
identification
exceptions thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Bob Lynn I'm a
representative from wendam rocking
District 17 and um in the in the
interest I know you're pressed for time
in the interest of sort of brevity first
I I'm happy to answer questions if
people have it but what I would say just
for your information is this is the very
same bill I mean literally word forword
that was introduced last year uh it was
if I recall correctly tabled the purpose
of it is to eliminate the affidavit
ballot procedure and basically say if
you want to vote you provide the
documentation you can do that you can
register to vote on the day of the
election but you provide the
documentation if you don't provide the
documentation you don't vote period end
that's that's the sort of testimony that
I love okay uh with that we'll take
questions from the committee on 1569
from the sponsor and he is he is correct
it is identical to the bill that was
tabled in what I refer to as table thaon
um uh from last year so representative
Brennan I believe you want to speak or
no oh representative
weary Aon thank you for taking my
question I believe that there was a a
study that uh representative pruss did I
I believe for with regard
to folks who had submitted affidavits
but had not provided enough
information and in in follow-ups the
percentage of people who actually ended
up
completing their affidavits was
surprisingly low like less than
10% um is
that what this bill is trying to get at
is is you know removing these sort of
excuses for not completing the you know
affidavits of Eligibility to vote well
you know I mean I suppose that is one of
the one of the benefits maybe I you know
I I
to be very honest with you until you
just uh notified me of that study I I
was not aware of of that study um but I
guess what I would say is it you know
one of the things that I remember when
the when the affidavit ballot bill was
um was uh was going through the process
was well there was a there was a
question about well would this be
unconstitutional because it'll be you're
not counting arguably are not counting
all the votes on the night of the of the
uh election although as I think I said
at the time with regard to that it's
hard it's hard to understand how it
could be unconstitutional when recounts
are allowed so you you allow recounts so
um but but anyway it does it it
does it eliminates that issue in other
words to the extent that there's some
claim some suggestion that you're not g
to have all the everybody's vote who
everybody who voted is not going to get
counted that day this eliminates that
because you you either provide the
documentation or you don't vote um and
the the other thing is candidly I just
have it seems to me that it is not a
good
system that allows
someone where where you're supposed to
have all this do you know all the stuff
the documentation in the four areas that
you are able to say in effect well I
don't have that but I swear that uh that
it's all true and we just sort of you
know have to accept that um so this is
that from the committee representative
Lane um representative Lyn uh
as you have a whole section about
citizenship and having to prove
citizenship in the bill um are you aware
that there are federal cases where they
have said that basically you cannot do
that that you have to when there's a
federal election you have to accept yes
or no um are you a citizen yes or no and
I guess I would follow up if you wanted
to have a conversation about those cases
yeah you know my understanding I think
the case that you're referring I can't
remember the name but I know it was
written by Justice Scalia I think that
it that
applied under you know that it applied
under the statutes that are not that New
Hampshire is not covered by I think
that's that's correct um and the the
other part of that is I mean it's it's
this is sort of Orphan Overlook but as I
recall that decision I think that the
the court left it open that there is
that the the the form that is used in
the states that are covered by the the
national
legislation um there is a way that those
states can challenge having to use the
form they just basically that decision
was kind of a procedural decision you
procedure
also are you aware of how expensive and
how few people really have that
documentation
available well no I guess I'm no I'm not
I'm not aware of that I think that I I I
think that um most people do have their
birth certificates or can relatively
easily get them and you know that what
it what this sort of really brings home
to me is that I I think that voting is a
sacred right I completely agree to that
but it's but it's also an important
right and it's not so I don't think it's
unreasonable to say to somebody you know
if you want to vote you shouldn't if I
want to vote in 10 minutes I shouldn't
have started thinking about it 10
minutes ago I should have started
thinking about it you know uh a while
ago so that I could make sure I I can do
what I need to do to be able to vote I
reasonable further questions from the
Hammer um I have a situation here and
I'll end it with a question what about
the family who has lived in Manchester's
W 10 and always voted every election
well their family home had a fire
recently just before the January 23rd
presidential primary the home was
declared a total loss I'll repeat a
total loss the family escaped with only
the clothes on their backs this family
was able to rent an apartment in
Manchester's W 12 this family went to
vote at their new polling location and
tried to register without any IDs
because we have voter identification
affidavit in place currently this family
was able to register in W 12 and vote if
you take these voter identification
exceptions away wouldn't that be yet
another Devastation to this family who
has already suffered a total loss of
their family home well I first of all I
think you posit a really really you know
unusual situation but I suppose if if
the if the people were really you know
if that terrible situation happened and
the person was and the person the people
were really interested in voting for
example I would think that one of the
things they might have been able to do
is have family members or neighbors who
didn't live with them be able to come in
and say and and say look this is what
happened this the the house just burned
down yesterday I've known these people
for 40 years of course they're citizens
of the United States I know that um and
I would think that a reasonable election
official would accept that under those
circumstances
yes that's
fine so that's an
exception right well no no no the rules
it says in there or or any natural a or
any other reasonable documentation which
indicates the applicant as a citizen of
the United States um so if you know if
you're if if documentation is too narrow
maybe it should say evidence or any
other reasonable evidence uh sure that
if that you know that might be an
appropriate change to make but I think
you know I think that the example I gave
would be a reasonable in those
circumstances now it might not be in
other circumstances but if something
happened you know on the ver on the you
know Eve of the election sure I think
that would make
sense questions from the
committee seeing none oh I'm sorry I
apologize representative Bron I didn't
see your hand thank you it's good to see
you again representative Lynn um earlier
day on a different bill you testified
that you support um every eligible voter
being able to cast their ballot and have
their ballot counted are you concerned
at all that if this legislation is
enacted that every eligible voter would
not be able to cast their ballot and
have that vote counted no I'm not
because as I said be as I said before it
it seems to me that it is not in in any
way
unreasonable to say that if you want to
vote you have to act responsibly you
can't just decide you know you can't
it's it's it's it's not like you know at
five minutes to 12 I decide what let's
see what do I want for lunch today am I
going to have tuna Fisher turkey
sandwich or whatever you you it's it's
reasonable to say you have to think if
you want to vote you have to think about
that at least some reasonable period of
time in advance followup please yep
follow
are you aware that many voters make
their decision about how they're going
to cast their ballot as they're walking
into the polling location and would it
not be um in the same vein as
prohibiting those folks you know you're
the line of your argument is that people
should be thinking far in advance and
many people don't and they make that
decision the day of the moment of as
they're walking into the polling
location and as they close the curtain
behind them in the polling booth think
that you're confusing two things the
question of I'm going to vote is a
different question than who I'm going to
vote for I I have frankly been in that
situation very many times of well you
know closing the closing the curtain
particularly for positions further down
the down the ballot absolutely that's a
different question than am I going to
vote I you know I I I know and I think
you know most reasonable people know
fairly significantly in advance whether
they're going to vote or not that's a
different question I think thank you
followup please uh this will be the last
one but yes thank you are you aware of
any numbers from perhaps the Attorney
General's office that have uh that would
indicate that we have an issue with
affidavits being filed for voting
purposes that have led to prosecution
for voter fraud um which seems to be the
basis of this is that we're trying to
eliminate voter fraud and we want to
provide as much information as possible
when registering to vote are you aware
of what the numbers are from the
Attorney General's office regarding the
amount of prosecutions for voter fraud
as a result of using an affidavit to
vote well I guess I'd have two responses
first uh the the the information that
was brought out by by your colleague
sitting next to you about the number of
affidavits that are the the information
is not provided after words um that see
it seem would seem to me that uh you
know that would raise my suspicion about
why wasn't it provided uh suggesting
that maybe they didn't it didn't exist
um so that that's that's the first part
the second part part that is is I think
is critically important there's no
question that voter fraud is very hard
to prove so you know um is the uh I I
don't have the statistics from the
Attorney General's office I suspect it's
pretty low it's I I mean I've heard
about you know a few times every every
election cycle you hear of a few cases
like that sure does that is does that
mean that that's all the fraud there is
no as as as pointed out by the other you
know the other why didn't these people
return their affidavits I mean one the
or documentation That was supposed to be
provided it seems to me that as I said
voter voter fraud I think is very
difficult to prove and so I think the
answer is we really don't know the
extent of voter
fraud right further questions from the
committee representative
Burnham Mr chairman thank you for taking
my
question I recently went with my
18-year-old daughter to get a second set
of
earrings and knowing what I know about
what's acceptable to uh register to vote
in our state I was a bit taken back that
she required her ID to show her age and
where she lived unfortunately she wasn't
aware and uh therefore she wouldn't be
able to get her ears
pierced I say this
because if you are if one is required to
have some type of identification to get
their ears pierced wouldn't one think
that they would need that identification
to be able to go and vote no I I mean
exactly it just seems to me it's
you know it's hard to imagine that
somebody doesn't understand that this is
voting is a is a serious matter and that
you you know you're not going to just be
able to I would think that most people
would understand I'm not going to just
be able to walk in and you know uh and
and just and just vote without having to
provide any any any uh documentation or
evidence of who I am and and that I meet
the
requirements from the committee
see
none this is I I already said the last
one was the last one so this is actually
the last one I would hope the ranking
member will back me up on that after
this
one thank
you um New Hampshire is in a a critical
time period where we are experiencing a
housing crisis like never before um if
someone is without a home
homeless um transient
do they forfeit their right to vote
because they don't have a permanent
address no I don't think they do I think
they have I think that they there are
ways that they uh that they can you know
that they can confirm that they have a
domicile um in wherever wherever that
may be um and and you know and I think
we've I think we've heard at least I've
heard examples of like you know police
officers or Social Service workers or
whatever sort of being able to verify
yes you know this person actually does
live at this at you know in this
encampment or whatever so I think it can
it can be done again does it require
somebody to think a little bit about it
yeah it does but I think it can be done
is voting a right or a
privilege there's no question it's a
right okay thank you um with that thank
you representative Lenn we appreciate it
um going to let you go about your day uh
we're going to recess the hearing on
1569 and reopen the hearing
on 15 1557 requiring Secretary of State
to ur a membership agreement with the
electronic registration information
center going to recognize um uh Aubrey
freem Freedman we're going to come back
to you I I told you we would come back I
long uh Mr chairman committee members uh
Aubrey readman I live in Bridgewater
private citizen I speak in opposition to
this bill um first of all the main
purpose stated to eliminate duplicate
you know possible uh duplicate voting is
is a good uh that's a commendable goal
um however trying to register every
single voter who's eligible that to
me uh seems like an impossible and that
seems the more bigger part of this bill
trying to register everybody and at
significant cost I mean personally when
there's an election you see signs out
you know there's an election coming you
it's in the news and there's ads and you
can't miss the signs so for a person to
not know that an election is coming if
they're interested to vote they will
contact their town clerk ask somebody
how do you vote so this kind of Outreach
effort to get everybody registered seems
honestly silly to me and more important
so let's say you achieve the goal of
registering every eligible voter how are
you going to get them to turn out on
voting day because registering is one
thing but you you actually want people
to vote well I've seen our uh in our
towns we we get the checklist
periodically for Schoolboard elections
and you'll see like 12 13 14 names on a
page and especially in the March
elections you'll see like one name shows
up the next page nobody showed up so if
people want to uh so this whole effort
to register everybody to me seems a
waste of time if they want to they'll
find out and more important if they want
to vote they'll vote so what are you
going to do if you did get everybody to
register are you also going to start
calling everybody uh the day or day
before the election to turn out and vote
it would be impossible so I think that's
one of the problems with this joining
the Eric is total registration of
everybody uh I also see in my mind the
biggest problem with voting problems is
the mail in ballots that's the real
issue harvesting and you know there's a
lot of problems potential problems with
that so and this joining the Eric has
nothing to do with that and I actually
think it will make it worse because Eric
wants AVR automatic voter registration
you know from the DMV I came from
California and that's how they do it
there once you've registered you got
your license or your car they mail out
the ballots and uh there's really you
you kind of lose control that's the
bigger problem and um so and and they
also opt out too if it was opt in it
wouldn't be so bad but it's always opt
out so that's the problem and this
joining Eric isn't going to solve that
problem at all uh what else here uh well
the cost has been mentioned and I I
think it's I think it was at high of
174,000 I think they're going to need
more staff than just one person to try
to contact 95% of every eligible voter
so I think the costs are a little bit
low and it did say uncertain cost too so
that's a problem um also
um the Eric reports I've looked at the
website and it has all their their stats
and shows for the different states uh
possible uh duplications but those are
possible duplications I'm curious how
many actual convictions did it actually
did the reports really turn into and has
been mentioned there's very few people
who really vote in two different
different places I mean it just I mean
your one vote the chance of getting
caught um is so silly I don't think it
but as I say the mailin ballots there is
kind of some value in trying to play
around with that you know the harvesting
and everything and lastly just the data
sharing what could possibly go wrong
with data sharing so that in itself
would be enough to uh I think it's not a
good idea and that's why I oppose the
bill will you be taking questions yes
please uh representative bone recognize
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question you mentioned rights
um just like any other right isn't it up
to the citizen to exercise that right
right or or choose not to a lot of
people are just not interested in leave
them alone they it's there I just cannot
see that it's that hard to registered
and if you move to a new uh area you're
if you're interested if you're not
interested interested you won't bother
with it thank you further
questions I'll I'll follow up with
representative BM are you aware of any
other rights that are automatically
granted by going to the DMV such as do
we give people a gun exercise are second
amendment
rights okay no all right thank you um
Perry
Strafford I speak in
support uh since last doing Eric
research in
2020 the number of potential voters Eric
has identified as increased among 31
States from 34 million to 6 60 million
and has provided
39.3 million voter record updates to
name only two G categories of
reports this and much more information
state election officials would otherwise
be required to collect from various
state and government agencies at its own
expense suggesting there are cost
savings to be had to offset the cost of
membership in
Eric those fees 2020 were $25,000 as a
one-time fee $220,000 per year
membership and an estimated $50,000 in
yearly administrative costs costs that
appear very reasonable giving uh given
the ongoing
benefits I do not have an updated fee
schedule some unlikely members of Eric
include Alaska Arizona Georgia Kentucky
South Carolina Utah and Wisconsin with
an additional 18 states utilizing the
research of this public charity
nonprofit its three-page PDF sets out
the prolific security systems used to
protect the Integrity of voter
information and of its own work
product our Secretary of State's office
was once a member of the now defunct
Kansas cross check program despite
public concerns from voter protection
Advocates that its system was highly
suspect and inferior to Eric it can be
fairly stated the office of the
Secretary of State relatively recently
therefore supported the concept of
outside assistance in maintaining
accurate voter roles obviously you've
you've heard the secretary
testify
quoting Eric's executive director quote
utilizing these four data sources Eric
provides its members with reports that
identify inaccurate or out-of-date voter
registration records deceased voters
individuals who appear to be eligible to
vote but who are not yet registered and
possible cases of illegal
voting I suggest utilization of this
product is a win for voters and the
state
and I provide a link um for full details
uh at eric.org
so I urge pases thank you be taking
questions from the committee I will are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you Mr Perry uh next
up is Al
brandano he's still here I saw him here
earlier but I think he's depart I think
he has left um all right uh next up then
is Linda
Bundy
good afternoon chairman Barry and
members of house election law I'm Linda
Bundy and I live in antrum I support HB
1557 requiring the secretary of state to
enter into a membership agreement with
the electronic registration
information
center quoting Eric's executive director
Eric is a nonprofit membership
organization created by state election
officials to help improve the accuracy
of Stater State voter roles and register
more eligible Americans to vote 25
states in the district of Colombia are
members of Eric New Hampshire is the
only New England state that is not a
member a state's voter registration
roles are the foundation of free fair
and valid elections accurate roles build
confidence in election
results Eric uses a robust and safe data
sharing program that employs
state-of-the-art matching technology by
comparing a member's voter records to
other members voters records DMV records
and federal deceased data and National
change of address data Eric identifies
differences that indicate a member's
voter record may be out ofd or
inaccurate Eric generates four types of
reports from the data comparisons
members are required to request at least
one report once per year additionally
Eric provides an eligible but
unregistered report that identifies
individuals who may be eligible to vote
but are not registered at least once
every two years years members send voter
registration information to individuals
identified in this report Eric never
connects to any State's voter
registration system membership in Eric
is a secure logical way to improve and
modernize the maintenance of our
election checklists I ask that you vote
ought to pass on HB
1557 thank you no question no questions
see I like a good no questions um next
up the and only Lucas Myers good to see
you
brother good to see you as well Mr
chairman uh Lucas Meyer uh from
Manchester New Hampshire uh here to
testify and support of this bill uh I
feel like there's a bit of whiplash
coming before this committee today where
I've heard some testimony that
apparently uh allegations of voter fraud
are no longer a problem in the state
despite many years and many many bills
and many court cases some of them
costing the state over $3 million to
litigate um and an attempt to find and
strengthen our elections when in reality
those efforts only disenfranchised
eligible voters in the state so one
would
assume a program like Eric a bipartisan
proven
program would not be something that this
committee could come together on I am
excited this year that there is some
bipartisan uh representation on this
bill but it is my understanding that the
shared values of this committee include
supporting our local election officials
by having more accurate clean voter
lists a shared value that came forward
during the committee on voter confidence
put together by the Secretary of State
as a recommendation for this committee
to take seriously this session uh to
catch possible cases of voter fraud I
grew up in the state hearing about buses
coming in from Massachusetts carrying
voters in let's find out that's all
we're asking Massachusetts is a member
of Eric after the election we could have
a report not months later weeks later to
hand to our attorney general to say hey
let's go investigate these the these
possible cases Georgia just announced
today that they have uh the Secretary of
State Republican Brad raffensberger
because of their membership and Eric
identified 17 possible cases of voter
fraud across the state which they handed
down to the Attorney General's office
for them or the State's Attorneys to go
out and investigate we talk about voter
confidence we talk about ending this
distraction of a conversation about
voter fraud in the state we have an
opportunity we talk about folks who vote
for the first time perhaps with an outof
state license that makes some people
uncomfortable I can understand that on a
human level did you know that using data
from 2016 from an nhpr report that over
75% of out ofate IDs that were used in
New Hampshire in 2016 came from states
that are also members of Eric
Ergo after the election people are
saying hey what are all these out of
state licenses we could as a state
within 75% identify oo Mike O'Brien
voted in two in New Hampshire and Maine
and Massachusetts we' be able to know
that how many Mike O'Brien are there in
New hampsh I know there's I know there
at least one but we know a lot so I say
this because and I and I understand this
is New Hampshire
we like to think we are perhaps unique
in our desire to protect data and
information of our citizens I think we
are all adults to assume that the 25
other states in the that are part of
Eric also want to protect their voters
information as well and if that question
lingers for you as a Committee Member
you do not have to wander in absentia
you can call your colleagues in Vermont
in Maine in Massachusetts in Rhode
Island we we can get answers to these
questions what we cannot do outside of
Eric is get the benefits that this
unique proven secure program
delivers so I really hope and despite
and the last thing I'll say here is on
why states have
left we've been tiptoeing around it it's
because certain Republican states think
George Soros pays for this
program it is lunacy it is not rooted in
reality it gives credence to big lie
conspiracy theories that this committee
is working to push back against and I
know that that is a bipartisan agreement
that that is not how we run elections in
the
state so this is an opportunity not only
for New Hampshire the first in the
nation state which we pounded our chess
about how we do democracy best in the
country and that's why we should have
the first in the
nation let's match that by showing the
country that we will not cave to these
conspiracy theories and instead take a
really strong step and shift the
dialogue towards no this once sleepy
program that started in 2012 is in fact
what it is which is an opportunity to
help our local election officials catch
cases of voter fraud and heaven forbid
enfranchise eligible but unregistered
voters which as a downside to this bill
is pretty antithetical to what it means
to be a grand estator in my opinion but
I'll leave that to to you all
individually and I'll stop there will
you be taking questions I'd love
to are there
questions um representative weary yes
thank you Mr Meyer um so what are the
origins of
of Eric how did it come about how was it
started and what was what were the
funding that contributed to its Origins
the Pew charitable trust was the
original entity that I believe seed
funded the project um but since then um
has grown out to be just administered by
the member states but 20 12 recognizing
that states needed a tool to combat
these lies of voter fraud and to also
identify a problem that our local
election officials were having of just
like cluttered up voter roles so that's
that's the Nexus of
it followup if no one else wants to go
sure who was one of the main
contributors to the Pew charitable
trust have their 990 in front of me
would you would it surprise you if was
George
Soros
no on that bombshell um any other
questions um and and I I think we should
we will take these accusations against
Mr O'Brien very seriously you know I
mean can I respond I mean yeah sure go
for it I mean is is the supposition then
that it is is that your supposition
representative that it is paid for that
is a it is a
liberal think tank that is trying to
skew our elections CU I think the the
evidence is pretty clear against that
and I think perpetuating those types of
conspiracy theories which is what it is
is
dangerous I I think we'll end that there
I think you can imagine the members a
stance on that given the pointed
question so um any other questions from
the
committee nope seeing none thank you
it's always good to see
you um next up is Mara Chappelle I got
name better and
better
so two for two Mora and nette Chappelle
um Jefferson New Hampshire I wasn't
again not prepared to speak but based on
something he said I wanted to clarify um
the buses from Massachusetts and I hate
and those are the people that are on my
side they always say that and I'm like
sh don't say that because it's not true
we all know it's not true but what
happens is coaz County again where where
I am we are routinely all of our
elections are routinely one two three
votes
because was that small so one two three
people hugely matters the rest of the
state saw it this in 2022 how many ties
were there I think there was a record
number of um recounts because that's how
close so one two three votes matters so
it's not the it's not the buses coming
in and AFF in the state it's the
short-term rental owners who vote using
their their their vacation house address
they vote absentee from Massachusetts
and Connecticut and wherever else it's
the out of state Rel cuz I'm from
Massachusetts and my my family goes I
don't vote because it doesn't matter in
Massachusetts it would be very easy for
me to go yeah they live with me right
small town though I would get busted
when we all see each other um I have
painstakingly every election for the
last few years I get every voter
checklist every mock voter checklist of
coaz County and go through them and
cross check them against all the
short-term rentals and cross check them
against anything that I can and
Jefferson has routinely 10 to 15 Twin
Mountain has almost 30 Randolph has
almost 30 right there that's three reps
that's three reps that get
affected and as you've seen in your own
house
elections one two three hugely matters
how many things have been decided by our
thing so it's not the buses from
Massachusetts it's still the little guys
and also um actually the the real point
I meant to make I don't mean to ramble
I'm sorry I'm new at this um it's not
whether or not they voted in
Massachusetts and up here that's what
people get fixated on they'll vote here
instead of Massachusetts which is still
against the law but gets brushed aside
stop they think with the what he was
saying is to just only if they voted in
both places they're voting up here
instead of their home state and it just
doesn't happen to be by bus so will you
be taking questions if anyone has them
does anybody have any questions seeing
none thank you so much all right we are
now in lobbyist land yep I think yes um
so I'm going to put on the two- minute
the two-minute shot clock um first up
you good to see you as well it's been in
a
minute afternoon afternoon chairman
Barry members of the committee uh Matt
musian a voter in Claremont I am the
advocacy and engagement director with
603 forward and today I'm here to
testify in support of House Bill
1557 um Eric is the only secure
bipartisan tool to improve the accuracy
of our voter roles uh support
hardworking election officials and
strengthen election integrity and build
our voter confidence in the final report
of the Secretary of State's special
committee on voter confidence uh the
committee made a recommendation quote to
have updated checklist verification and
provide a uniform and secure checklist
updating system Statewide that accounts
for movein move outs and deaths New
Hampshire should have cons New Hampshire
should consider methods to determine if
New Hampshire citizens have voted in
other states end quote Eric would
clearly accomplish this shared goal that
the committee identified in their
nonpartisan report as you've also heard
a recent poll conducted by the St anel
College Survey Center revealed that 75%
of granted State voters think that New
Hampshire should join Eric and as you've
also heard Eric has support from
election officials across the political
Spectrum from Georgia to Rhode Island
who have uh relied on Eric uh to keep
their voter roles accurate and up to
date every state in New England is a
member of Eric and it's beyond time for
us to join this nonpartisan system and
often the conversation in New Hampshire
around voting rights uh gets mired down
in a debate over voter fraud or
perceived relaxed nature of our
elections in New Hampshire this means
that it's often younger folks or more
transient voters who face the most
threats to their constitutional right to
vote because of conspiracy theories and
conspiracy theory driven bills that make
it harder and uh more costly to vote 603
forward supports Eric because we believe
that by providing the data needed to
root out actual cases of voter fraud we
would be able to focus on the continued
Improvement of our voter confidence and
put to bed these convers ations our
focus should be on making elections more
secure and efficient for folks to
participate and having upto-date
accurate voter registration list is key
to maintaining our secure elections so
we ask you you please vote a to pass on
House Bill
1557 are there questions will you be
taking questions certainly are there
questions from the committee um I have
one because I I I kind of warned against
referencing this say a poll earlier but
uh apparently we're not going to pay
attention to that so you say it's 75% %
of I have two questions here so youly
75% of grand estaters believe we should
roll in Eric do you genuinely believe
that 75% of grand estaters know what
Eric
is it's a good question I think that 75%
of granders can probably identify with
the concept of Eric and maintaining our
accurate voter roles in identifying
these issues fair and my followup is s
uh UNH released there a survey today
which by the way everybody should go
check it out um it talks about the
support or opposing New Hampshire law
requiring the first and Nation primary
so 66% of graters support the first and
Nation Primary Law are you to have me
believe that more people in New
Hampshire support joining Eric than
support our first in the nation primary
that's the number say yep so if anybody
wants I'd recommend go reading that poll
Germain
good afternoon I promise I will not be
citing any sort of polls in this
testimony uh my name is McKenzie C
Germain uh I'm with the New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights and America
votes New Hampshire um we support this
bill hp1 1557 and New Hampshire joining
Eric I've spent much time in front of
this committee or listening to testimony
and this committee spent a lot of time
uh listening to the testimony that was
brought to the 2022 committee on voter
confidence one very common thread
amongst all of those things was a lot of
talk about cleaning checklists keeping
our checklist up to date in state making
sure that if folks move have moved out
of a place no longer are eligible to
vote that we are keeping our checklist
clean clearly that should be a priority
and I know is a priority of this
committee um but there are often things
that are brought up ideas that are
brought up that are actually harmful
because they are removing voters who
should not be removed from the list and
making it more difficult for them to
cast their ballots this is a system that
we know that is trusted um that actually
works to address those concerns and it
is the only system out there that does
this between states um so we support
this bill and hope that you all uh will
come around supporting it as well right
will you be taking questions sure other
questions from the committee
representative
wey at a recent uh Senate hearing for
the uh interval for voter checklist
verification they said that um only
5% were
removed um who didn't then rreg or who
who then did re-register so it was 95%
effective 5% were false positives or
something like that where they had to um
those particular voters had to
reregister again so I I'm your statement
was about you know that that a lot of
people are being harmed by this I'm I'm
you think 5% is is really that harmful
register thank you for the question I
think our current system you know is the
10 years I know there's a lot of
proposals to make that shorter intervals
I think in the current system it is you
know we wait a really long time and then
remove a lot of people who haven't voted
recently um there are ideas I know
coming forward in terms of doing that
way more fre frequently in terms of two
years four years five years um or you
know kind of individuals looking through
the lists and claiming people have moved
I think a that we can all agree on
obviously that improves how we're
cleaning our checklists um extra
technology like the online voter portal
which we're hoping um will be up and
running in the coming years systems like
Eric those types of things Al together
um can lead to cleaner lists without
additional harm but I think our current
system you know is is not removing a
number of people unnecessarily but it is
also 10 years and I know there's a lot
of support in trying to increase the
cleanliness of lists beyond what we
currently
do further questions from the committee
I think you believe it or not you
actually asked the question I would ask
which is how do you oppose the Clint the
and I guess I'll ask it again if you
just answered that's fine but I'll ask
more direct how do you guys ju suppose
your position of opposing more frequent
voter rle purges I don't really like
that term but cleaning um based on
inactivity with this which it's stated
purpose is to remove voters like how do
you guys I guess I'm trying to figure
out how do you guys get to one but not
the other so thank you for that um I
think there's a difference between
removing people just because of
inactivity so they would have missed a
presidential election versus removing
folks because we have evidence that they
have moved to another state they have
moved to another town and using that
kind of they are no longer eligible to
vote there versus inactivity and that's
the kind of difference very good answer
thank you thank you I was curious I was
I was genuinely curious how how we got
Lane under um the system of
Eric uh will we avoid the situation of
people who've been
purged showing up thinking they're
registered and now we no longer if the
pre the next bill passes we no longer
will have affidavits and they will not
be able to perhaps register to vote I
will say that I am not in terms of in
the weeds exactly how that process works
an expert um I would hope that it would
be you know the people who are moving or
people who have gotten the know the
choice to send the 30-day letters to
folks when they are removed from the
list town by Town more frequently so
they can see oh nope I actually there
was a mistake fill out that send it back
and remove the number of people who are
coming to the polls unknowing you know
not knowing that they weren't
unregistered but I think it's probably a
process of Eric question
specifically question from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you um next
up is uh Nancy and I can't read the last
name of my
apologies withraw my those are my
favorites okay um next up are the last
up to speak if there's no one else
signed up I don't believe um is Brandon
FL flery Flaherty excuse
me
um and then we're on to the next one the
last one the best one who knows all
right well I don't want to keep you from
that next bill so um a lot of theu that
uh other folks have said I'm going to
say so for the record my name is Brendan
flare I'm here today on behalf of secure
democracy USA uh thank you for hearing
Our Testimony um two things Eric uh will
help us keep uh the voter list clean and
up to date um we've discussed those
issues already a lot here um and uh Eric
is the only proven system for efficient
and secure transfer of uh sensitive
voter
information um Eric member states are
requ required to meet the same stringent
standards for cyber security and uh
without joining Eric uh state would need
to pursue um its own contracts for
information this is in some of the
letter uh that I had shared around with
the committee um pursue its own
contracts for uh information sharing
with other states um which is costly and
challenging so that's all I have thank
you and thank you for taking my question
could you speak and I don't know if you
have the expertise to speak to this some
of the concerns around confidentiality
and the sharing of that information um
could you speak to that because I think
it is somewhat troubling sure uh I don't
have the expertise to speak to that in
detail um but happy to follow up with
so questions seeing none thank you okay
uh we we made it through that one uh it
was 1557 I have no one else signed up to
speak or no other pink cards in my
possession no one else wish to speak uh
got to do some quick math here excuse me
four eight okay uh there were eight
people signed up to
speak um who didn't six were in support
two were in
opposition um
online we had
1977 been sitting here for a
minut that's the wrong Bel online I'm
going to have to read in a second cuz
the states in it just 363 in support 11
perfect um 363 in support and 11 in
opposition with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 1577
and reopen the house the public hearing
on House Bill 1569 relative to
eliminating voter identification
exemptions the bill has been introduced
this is the last public hearing of the
day uh so next up to speak is
Nasi chairman Barry good to see you back
on with as a
chair um and the rest of the committee
also um resident of
Rollinsford um and it's on the main
state many times I get a complete
Rollinsford but it's right there and
registered
Undeclared um and also I'm one of the
supervisors of the checklist for
Rollinsford and uh with the legal wom
voters and so very happy to be with them
and this um bill has uh one sponsor Bob
Lind that I realized he had to leave so
um now I look at this is be sensible and
a lot of
listening sensible to listen to voters
sensible to believe our our governor
cunu actually that has said that um
Integrity for the voting in our
elections is good minimal meaning
minimal uh amount of
Fraud and um also sensible to support
constituents all voters all eligible
voters and the voting rules using the
affidavits
work they work they
do and um on election day to register to
work uh to uh to vote it's very popular
to uh to register on Election Day and uh
you know besides save a
trip it's uh you know just think of uh
the town hall such as Rollinsford with
limited
hours they really do it's like closed
Wednesdays uh Mondays except this week
um opened us 8 to one and um and then I
think uh on Tuesday Thursday 1 to six so
um you know trying to juggle this time
and then get there um you know it's it
can be
difficult and but the rules are followed
using affidavits they are and we really
take pride in following the rules from
secretary scanland uh
department and Trisha that heads New
Hampshire votes the election net we
follow that really uh we take pride in
following that and so uh I'll say what
is sensible is to kill this bill any
questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you thank
you it's good to see you again thank you
um next up is Nancy uh
trying my name is Nancy marashio I live
in New London and I'm representing the
League of Women Voters in fact I am
reading the testimony of our president
Liz tentarelli who could not be here and
we'll pass out copies
afterwards afterwards because I'm a
teacher and I know you'd read if I pass
them out
now the mission of the League of Women
Voters is empowering voters we try to
explain in the simplest way while still
being accurate how to to register and
how to obtain a ballot removing the
affidavit option for people who do not
have all the documentation asked for
means our instructions now will have to
be get every single document you can
find before you go to register and even
then they might not be enough voting in
New Hampshire is for very organized
only the proof of domicile section of
this bill s sounds very like sb3 from
2017 which league and others challenged
in court ultimately we won we pointed
out there some Oddities including this
from today's Bill an applicant whose
domicile is at an abode of another and
whose name is not listed on the document
offered as proof of domicile May provide
a written statement from a person who is
listed as owner property manager or
tenant on the document that the
applicant resides at that address signed
by that person under penalty of voting
fraud if false information is provided
in other words the potential voter
cannot sign an affidavit that he is
temporarily living with a friend or
relative but the owner or tenant of the
property can sign an affidavit to that
effect and be believed but not the
prospective voter himself how in the
world does that say to new voters
welcome to the representative democracy
world it is documentary proof of
citizenship that disturbs me most
today's bill says that election
officials shall accept from the
applicant any one of the following as
proof of citizenship the applicant's
birth certificate passport
naturalization papers if the applicant
is a naturalized citizen or any other
reasonable
documentation which indicates the
applicant is a United States citizen
currently one can list one's place of
birth and sign the affidavit that it is
accurate and if one was born in the US
all is good but without the affidavit
option if a person does not have a
passport and let's be real many people
can't afford to travel internet
nationally and never get a passport how
does a married woman for example prove
citizenship her birth certificate likely
has a different last name does she have
to present that with her marriage
license to prove she's one and the
same and when is that birth certificate
and marriage license after all these
years when she's moving to a retirement
home in a new state just for the record
a driver's license does not prove
citizenship other potential voters could
also be affected people who became
naturalized citizens as Miners did so
under their families ages they may not
have those papers young firsttime
registrants may like my grandson several
years ago text their moms from the polls
and ask do I have a birth certificate
well of course they do but they don't
carry it around and Mom and the
certificate may be many miles away the
fact is that most people now register on
the day of election at the polling place
if they arrive without paper proof of
each of the four
qualifications ID age citizenship and
where they live they will been be denied
the right to register if this bill
passes voter registration should not be
a gauntlet this bill is still hunting
for a problem to solve an article in the
New Hampshire business Business review
from last November listed the 15 cases
of fraudulent voting prosecuted in New
Hampshire from 2016 to
2021 I used to be able to find the list
of those cases on the Secretary of
States or attorney general's website but
can't seem to find it anymore for most
of those cases the person who voted more
than once in the same election very
likely was able to present the documents
discussed in today's Bill those cases
involve people with two abodes in
different places of course that's wrong
being rich enough to have two places to
live doesn't give you double the vote
power but the point is the people were
caught and punished those Bad actors
should not be allowed to influence the
good people in our legislature to make
voting registration a Herculean task for
the young the disadvantaged whose
documents may be unavailable and others
in transitional stages of Life
affidavits are legally binding documents
and have worked for New Hampshire
registrant for years I urge you to
oppose HB
1569 as a bill in search of a problem a
bill that would inadvertently
disenfranchise eligible potential New
Hampshire
voters
you be taking questions sure are there
questions from the committee
representative
wey if I heard you correctly you
mentioned that some of the citizenship
document is something having to prove
that is something that you would object
to so in the previous Bill we heard
testimony about uh Eric and and one of
the data items that they require is a
proof of citizenship and then uh
explanation of what type of
documentation was provided for that
citizenship in the pendex spe of the
bylaws would you be opposed to Eric then
if if it's requiring you know that sort
of proof of citiz I'm sorry I'm going to
do something I've never done I'm going
to rule the question out of order it's
not it's not gerain to the bill um
excellent so don't don't hate me forever
but we got to we I'm not opening up
Pandora's Box on this further questions
from the
Lane fine um are are you aware that it
can take up to six months and cost over
$500 to get copies of your
nationalization papers yes thank
you questions from the committee seeing
none um thank you if I can add just one
personal comment I was a newbury's town
moderator for 25 years and the biggest
issue people had was
citizenship
documentation fair enough okay uh next
Hancock hello again I'm Kathy Anderson
I'm live in Hancock um I'm
speaking as supervisor of checklist for
Hancock to speak about how important it
is to have these affidavits people come
in and many times more people come to
register to vote at the election than do
in advance of an election and they come
in and they don't a small minority do
not have all the paperwork and they just
don't have it I can think of
individuals um who just don't come in
with it with one item and having the
affidavits makes it work makes people
believe in voting makes people feel um a
better part of the country and I
strongly encourage you to continue
having the affidavits and not support
this B this issue thank you taking
question questions sure are there
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you um next up Bruce
Barracks close close ah all right what
is it I guess we'll find out in a second
no I I may not tell you I'm not sure no
it's uh Bruce Burke and I am from the
town of Pittsfield um I just thought I'd
share a couple figures with you uh in uh
terms of perhaps the U Inception of this
bill so you heard earlier in the 2020
election
790,000 New Hampshire voters voted I'm
going to call it 800,000 for ease let's
imagine for a moment that there were
8,000 affidavits signed on the day of
the election that is
1% of the voters in fact it was shared
this morning that there were
1,400 affid Davids
Statewide that comes out to less than
99.83% of our votes are
untainted now let's assume for a moment
or let me ask you for a moment do you
think all 1,400 affidavits were
fraudulent how about half of them being
99.9% of the vote being uh
non-controversial
so let's pick another figure 1,400
affidavits maybe 10% of them were
fraudulent now where are we I can't I
don't go past tens of a percent but
we're somewhere in hundreds of% of
potential fraudulent votes my point is I
think you can hear that perhaps this
bill right is
unnecessary right it is we hear this
phrase all the time a a problem right in
search of a bill I'd be happy to take
your questions I will not do the
hundreds of a percent of perhaps
fraudulent votes fair enough are there
questions from the committee um I have
one since I like numbers you like
numbers are you aware that the House
Majority was decided by less than 100
am the the Assumption then is that the
14 you know just to work off of your
assumptions and your hypotheticals for a
moment sure if there are four 1,400
Statewide affidavits and there's some
small percentage that are
doing is it likely that someone would
distribute them across the state evenly
or would they focus them on particular
Target districts if they wanted to
commit fraud sure who knows I mean I I I
understand your question I just I'm just
going to reiterate that 1,400 affidavits
in a voting population of
790,000 people is not a significant
number and that's assuming for a moment
that they're all fraudulent that that's
all the point I'm trying to make in
terms of this bill well received are
there any other questions from the
committee oops none seeing none thank
you so much uh next up we're going to
have the best handwriting of the day
award uh opilia
Bernett um if people should could just
come and look at this card it is amazing
they should all be written like
it thank you chairman for that
comment good afternoon chairman and
members of the committee my name is
ofilia Bernett and I am the Democracy
organizer with open democracy and I also
advocate for formerly and currently
incarcerated individuals I'm here today
to testify on HB
1569 and urge you to oppose this bill HB
1569 is a bill that removes the ability
for those registering to vote to sign a
sworn affidavit if they don't have
physical proof of identity age
citizenship or domicile right now law is
voters are for proof of domicile age
identity and citizenship when
registering to vote if they are not able
to provide these documents or lack their
of they are able to sign an affidavit
then they can register and cast their
ballot if this bill passes impacted most
by this bill are those who may not have
all their documents required to register
and who are more likely to move and
therefore register to vote more
frequently like someone who has been
previously incarcerated this bill
mandating voters to have documents to
prove dsah identity and age will
disproportionately impact formly
incarcerated individuals this
requirement poses a significant barrier
to voting for those vulnerable
population many of whom face challenges
in obtaining these documents due to
their past convictions such a bill
undermines the principles of a fair and
inclusive Democratic process by further
disenfranchising those who are already
marginalized
it is crucial to consider the impact on
all members of society including those
who have served their time and are
seeking to actively participate in Civic
engagement formally incarcerated
individuals face several challenges in
obtaining these documents required for
voting including lack of identification
many individuals leaving incarceration
may not have a valid form of
identification such as a driver's
license or state ID which is often
required to register to vote obtaining
documents like birth certificates social
security cards or proof of residency can
be challenging for those limited for
those with limited resources or support
networks many firmly incarcerated
individuals may lack awareness of the
specific documentation requirements for
voter registration leading to confusion
and potential dis
disenfranchisement addressing these
challenges is crucial to ensuring that
not only just formally incarcerated
individuals but also young voters and
people experiencing housing insecurity
have equal access to their fundamental
right to vote and participate in the
Democratic process a poll done by new by
UNH in 2022 showed that 92% of New
Hampshire voters had had confidence in
the 2022 elections Governor sununu
himself says our system works and has
integrity and Secretary of the State Dan
ganin has said there's no evidence that
I I've seen of any organized widespread
voter fraud taking place in New
Hampshire with that being said I ask you
chairman and members of the committee to
oppose this bill that will disrupt the
election process and let's continue to
allow Grand estaters to have faith in
the system thank you you taking
questions from the committee yes I are
there questions from the committee
representative
wey
um what is what is the so under RSA
6545 um there's a disqualification for
felony so a person sentenced for a
felony shall forfeit his rights for
voting stuff so if
[Music]
you're is there a mechanism that you're
propos I'm trying to understand who
you're advocating for in terms of are
you talking about people who are
currently disqualified by their felony
convictions are you talking about
someone else I I just want to understand
that better I I believe if someone has
paid their time and has proven
themselves to be responsible citizens
then I I think there ought to be a
process to allow them to vote but um I
do um I I just want to understand your
thoughts on the matter please absolutely
and thank you for the question um so
what I'm saying is that you if you are a
felon you are able to vote you do have
the right to vote but I'm saying being
able to come up with these documents is
really hard if you first come home from
prison or even if it's been a couple
months to access some of these documents
are really hard because you know you um
you no longer live at the apartment or
place that you were living at before or
you've had to move because you've been
incarcerated so you're not there at the
place that you were last living at
before considering that you've been
locked up for a couple years so getting
some of these documents might might be
hard to obtain to be able to register
the vote all right thank you for the
answer you're
welcome so the member knows in New
Hampshire um misdemeanor is up to a year
so that's not a felony and then you can
be held on preventative detention um and
felons get the right to vote after they
have been released um their rights are
restored so I hope that answers the
question so my my answer help the
witness out I would assume she would be
advocating for um in this particular
case those held under a year under mror
charge those held under preventive
detentions who have not yet lost their
right to
vote thank you I'm here I'm here for
everybody
um further questions from the committee
all right hearing none thank you and
last up is Henry kimowitz with my
ACLU thank you yeah my name is Henry
Clement toich I'm a senior staff
attorney at the ACLU of New Hampshire uh
asking the committee to oppose HB
1569 there's a couple things that it
does uh there's been some discussion of
how uh this bill removes all the
affidavits used in the registration
process which would impact you know
hundreds if not thousands of people in a
cycle um who don't have proof of
citizenship like a passport or a birth
certificate um I wanted to address a
question that you had asked
representative Lane about uh court cases
striking down documentary proof of
citizenship uh representative Lynn is
right that most of the cases that
address that um come under the nvra but
one doesn't and that's F versus swab
from the 10th circuit from 2020 which
actually uh and the citation is 957 F3
1105 and that struck down a documentary
proof of citizenship requirement under
the 14th Amendment so so that would be
applicable here putting aside the um
irony of allowing people to challenge
voters with an affidavit but not to
register to vote with an affidavit one I
think underappreciated part of this bill
is the um reinvigoration I'll say of
voter
challenges so under this
bill uh if a person challenges an
individual's right to vote and the
moderator deems that challenge well
grounded on a sort of preponderance of
the evidence standard the person can't
vote and so that's basically what that
means is that one person a lay person
who doesn't have any training in finding
this who isn't a judge um is basically
has the right to take your right to vote
away from you um and if done wrongly
that's an obvious constitutional
violation and though there will be
mistakes made in that process because
there are a number of missing important
procedural protection s there's no um
rights for Witnesses rights to introduce
evidence on your behalf there's no uh
judicial right of review there's no
right to an attorney there's no um
procedural rules there's no right to
appeal um the standard of review is
preponderance of the evidence which is
one of the lowest standards of review
that we have and so there's just this
tremendous risk that a person can come
in submit a written affidavit saying I
know Henry he's not a citizen the
moderator you know I'm not prepared for
this cuz I don't know what's going to
happen I didn't bring my passport
because I didn't know I was going to be
challenged the moderator agrees with the
other person now I can't vote and
there's nothing I can do about even
though in fact I am a CIT citizen so um
I think that's a a really good reason to
vote against this bill I think it's
going to create a lot of liability for
people um in addition to the to what
others have said about the affidavit so
um I'm happy to answer any questions if
there are
any
Bron for taking my question um thank you
for bringing up the voter challenge
section of this bill as I read it it
says that no challenge may be asserted
except in the form of a signed
affidavit but what this bill and and
please correct me if your understanding
is different from mine I am understand
this bill to be looking to eliminate
affidavits at the polling location for
voters but if someone present at the
polling location wishes to challenge a
voter the only way they can do so is by
signing an affidavit does that does that
interpretation of this bill make sense
with your
interpretation I I think it's the right
interpretation of the bill I'm not sure
it makes sense from a policy perspective
um I mean it basically what it's saying
is we trust people who are challenging
voters more than we trust voters I think
thank
Lane and thank you for giving me an
answer about the other question
um I'm kind of harping on the citizens
ship piece so um I I is it true that if
you lie and say you are a citizen and if
it's found out you can never be a
citizen are that you can never be a
citizen right so in other words if you
lie about
that in your background check they'll
find that out because you'll be on the
voter
roles and they will use that to deny you
citizenship so I I don't I don't know
the answer to that because I don't do a
lot of okay uh naturalization work but
what I can tell you is if you lie on the
form and say that you're a citizen and
you're not and you're discovered and
prosecuted and convicted number one
you're convicted of a felony for
wrongful voting but number two you're
going to lose your right to vote in New
Hampshire forever under the New
Hampshire Constitution so even if you
then later could naturalize which you're
probably right you can't you still would
not be able to vote in New
Hampshire and you could go to prison for
years sorry it's not pointing my way
I thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
my question um do you know if it's
typical that voters who use an affidavit
will have proof of some of these
categories but may file an affidavit for
citizenship for example so the answer to
that I do know the answer to that is yes
so in in um
2020 November 3rd 2020 we got right to
know data from the Secretary of State
explaining how many people Ed the
um affidavits to prove either Identity
or citizenship and um it was in the 600s
used the qualified voter affidavit to
prove identity in the 800s used it to
prove citizenship and 14 people used it
to prove identity and citizenship so
that means is that everybody but 14
people were able to prove one of the
least thank you thank you I now call
one
there we go good afternoon uh members of
the committee um again my name is
Mackenzie St Germain with the New
Hampshire campaign for voting rights and
America votes I think my pink card was
lost along the way so I apologize if
there are two floating around up there
um the New Hampshire campaign for voting
rights opposes this legislation um I
wanted to emphasize that this could
absolutely affect any person and cost
them their right to vote uh we know you
know there's some groups that may be
more Ed and there's people who
anticipate having all of their documents
and then on the day of they don't um and
for that reason any person could be
affected by this bill and absolutely
lose their right to cast a vote in an
election um I do have a testimony here
from Andrew Harmon who's a voter in New
Hampton that I will hand out afterwards
um he was unable to be here today but he
is a legally blind voter um during the
pandemic he moved from Keen to help his
family in New Hampton um that was was
his new domicile and he wanted to vote
there in the town election I believe in
2021 um at that time he had a
non-driver's ID but it did not have his
new address on it it had his Keen
address on it he didn't know that he
needed to bring any documents to vote
that date other than his ID he brought
his ID they asked for CIT proof of
citizenship and domicile obiously he did
did not have those with him he didn't
have a document with his new address on
it but he was able to sign an affidavit
and cast his vote that same day under
this bill he would not be able to cast
that vote and he would have been turned
away uh I also spoke to another voter
recently named Michelle McCord of
holderness um she could not be here
today but allowed me to share her story
um she had moved into a new apartment
with her partner just a few weeks before
election day again she hadn't signed a
lease she was just moving in um with him
she had an ID but it had her old address
on it she didn't want to vote at her old
address she did not feel like that was
her home anymore and that was not right
to do she wanted to vote at her new home
um she didn't have a document with her
address on it again she was able to sign
an affidavit and vote that way but in
both of these cases we would have folks
who under this law would be turned away
and I think we could probably spend all
day here thinking of different options
different ways that could happen um I'm
someone who normally walks to the polls
or I um drive with my fiance if I show
up at the polling place and um my name
is no longer on the list it was removed
somehow as we know some names are
wrongfully removed it does happen we
have same day registration as a fallback
but in that scenario up until this year
when I renewed my license it did not
have my current address on it without my
car registration I would not have
something with my address I do not carry
around my birth certificate or passport
I don't know any folks who do um but
there are a lot of cases where these
documents someone has them they might
not have them because of an emergency
but we know that they can sign an
affidavit that is a legally binding
document and folks take those very
seriously and it allows all voters all
eligible voters to be able to vote and
cast their ballot um when they get to
the polls under our current system and
we need to maintain that system we know
that it works and we'll cite one poll uh
today's UNH poll showed that 94% of
folks uh who are pulled said they were
confident that the results in the
primary were accurately counted that is
a really high percentage of voter
confidence and we should do everything
to maintain that not to make it more
difficult to vote in the state so I am
happy to answer questions
any
questions good thank you thank
blob thank you
my apologies for sending the card up
late I didn't realize I didn't send it
up before and knowing that there would
be a number of U
speakers um speaking technically on this
bill my Approach is the philosophical I
hope you'll bear with me for less than
two
around I speak in
opposition this bill repeals Decades of
progress towards rectifying 234 years of
denying certain classes of Americans of
voice in our experiment in
self-governance from the beginning there
were restrictions on who could vote and
the value of the vote for example Jerry
mandering has existed early on in that
regard I often think about the Flight of
the
Kittyhawk and how it only took five
minutes for some bright individual to
act on the idea of installing a machine
gun on it to gain serious advantage over
others since the beginning it has been
students of good government in and out
of government who have delivered
expanded rights and
opportunities artificial intelligence
has already been used to recreate music
from deceased persons to give adult
voice to toddlers to Mock and has been
deployed in the grite state to suppress
the vote it will be used by independent
political organizations competing for
the most effective AI ads for their
candidates it will be used to subvert
democracy it will be used indefinitely
for all
purposes another serious issue is
us we are using the tools of democracy
to subvert
democracy to start we must unite in this
body to maintain confidence in our
elections we must continue to expand
access to The Ballot Box to make it
convenient to vote to hold voting in
high esteem against those who would take
it from us this bill represents a taking
a taking of had fought voting rights
already
acquired in a world of rising autocracy
we must rise United in support of
expanded
rights I urge itl
thank
you thank you uh Matt mushan 603 forward
um much of what I had prepared today has
been said so I'll keep keep it brief um
I'm here to testify an opposition of
House Bill
1569 um as it's been stated it's really
just a bill in search of a problem we
have seen numerous studies reports and
investigations that have all confirmed
that New Hampshire elections are safe
and secure and that our existing
affidavit system works 603 forward
opposes this legislation because it will
disproportionately negatively impact the
right to vote for young
voters as well as I'm trying to
summarize here as well as new Americans
people experiencing housing insecurity
and the
elderly um if we wanted to uh if we
wanted to prioritize making our
elections more secure there are other
options like House Bill 1557 thank you
very
much thank you any
questions good thank you very
Spencer
hi uh thank you very much um Mr chairman
and the committee for taking my
testimony today it's actually a bit in
two parts um I am with the Kent Street
Coalition we're an all volunteer
Grassroots organiza advocacy
organization and we strongly oppose this
bill and urge itl so I want to go on the
record with that um I am you know
surprised myself by some of the numbers
in terms of how many people each year
are displaced from their homes by
natural disasters and fires and other
events um overall across the US it's 3.3
million people that's 1.3% of the adult
population unless we think it doesn't
happen here in New Hampshire in 20 22
according to the Census Bureau
16,26 people were displaced from their
homes that's not a small number it's not
an uncommon event unfortunately it's
hard for us to imagine unless it's
happened to us that it could in fact
happen to us we know recently in sunpi
you know 20 to 25 people lost their home
like that when their building went up um
in Flames for fortunately nobody was um
killed in that particular
circumstance I know that um even
something just much simpler I was in a
car accident where my car was totaled I
was lucky to to be unharmed but my car
was towed away with all my my things in
it including my purse and my ID and um
so I temporarily lost access to that um
so I think all so when we think about
you know the are we do have some close
elections in New Hampshire there's no
question but we have to weigh the people
that might and it seems to be an
exceedingly no low number of people that
might abuse the system and whose votes
might get counted against those who
might have an incident or some situation
in their life where they can't produce
documents ments and just think what that
would look like if the
16,26 people displaced from their
homes we're not able to cast their votes
how would that affect our elections here
so I said my my testimony was in two
parts and I wanted to kind of deal with
Statistics and um the general kind of
first because the other thing I wanted
to do is to read uh some testimony from
someone who's a close close friend she's
not a member of Ken street but a very
close friend of one of our members and
her name is Susan Young's uh her
situation are you raising your
hand
okay okay um her situation is one that
unfortunately has a very tragic um
Dimension to it um so I'll just state
that ahead of of reading her
testimony um so again Susan Young's
and I'm going to use her voice because
this is her
testimony I am writing to express my
strong opposition to House Bill
1569 a act relative to eliminating voter
identification exceptions this bill
would unfairly disenfranchise legitimate
voters the legislature should be
encouraging voting not trying to limit
it my opposition is based on personal
experience on the 22nd of January
2017 my 1770s Colonial House in Webster
New Hampshire was destroyed by fire
taking the life of my husband Dr Steven
Young's and destroying virtually all of
my possessions I lost my car my
husband's truck my passport my driver's
license my birth certificate all my
clothes and everything else it took me a
while to get a new birth certificate
from my birth place in Dora Iowa a new
driver's license and even longer for a
new
passport if this event had happened
right before an election I would
probably still would have been able to
vote in Webster filling out an affidavit
and relying on the the town clerk or
moderator to verify that I am who I
State I am Webster is a small enough
town that both the clerk and the
moderator would have known who I was
however if I had lived in a larger Town
it was it would be very unlikely that
those people would know me personally if
this new law had been in effect I would
not have been allowed to fill out an
affidavit and I would not have been
allowed to vote taking away my
constitutional right there are many
legitimate reasons why someone would be
without proper ID at a specific time I
think this change is a solution in
search of a problem elections in New
Hampshire are safe secure and virtually
fraud-free I strongly oppose House Bill
1569 and again that's from Susan young
so that completes my testimony okay will
you be taking questions from the
committee sure all right seeing none uh
tramble
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members my name is David Trumble I'm
from the town ofwar and I oppose this
bill for three reasons first voting it's
a fundamental right it's how we choose
our legislators it's the Bedrock of our
democracy any attempt to restrict voting
rights should be looked at very
carefully because you must weigh the
impact of someone losing that right to
vote second I will give you some numbers
on those affidavit and how many were
returned this is from the New Hampshire
Business Review November 7th of 21 and
it's talking about the 2020 election in
It quotes from rep Bill Gardner our
former Secretary of State he said that
about 4,000 voters had to sign such an
affidavit in the state's primary and
general elections in 2020 of those the
state had not been able to authenticate
600 so 30400 people filled out an
affidavit went through the process came
back fill sold out the necessary papers
and their votes counted that's
3,400 people in one single election year
so your question comes up well how much
fraud is there representative Brennan
asked representative Lynn specifically
how much fraud is there when people were
trying to use a fake voter ID and he
could not answer that question but I can
give you some data on that the Brennan
Center for justice in their report
debunking the voter fraud myth has about
a dozen studies court cases on it I'll
just read you one a comprehensive study
found 31 credible instances of
impersonation fraud from 2000 to 2014
out of more than 1 billion ballots cast
even this tiny number is likely inflated
as the study's author counted not just
prosecutions or convictions but any and
all credible claims and that answers
representative Lynn's other response
which it's as a hard crime to prosecute
and similar numbers come about in the
fifth Circuit Court of in Texas where
they found that the photo ID law was
racially discriminatory so what does
that mean for New
Hampshire 31 out of a billion votes is
one out of 30 million it will take us 80
years before we get 30 million votes so
this bill would stop one case of voter
fraud in the next 80 years but it's
going to disenfranchise 3,400 New
Hampshire people every single election
you multiply that o out over those years
that's 100 50,000 people in this state
lose their vote because maybe they
forgot their wallet on the day they came
to vote they work at a job they can only
vote at the last 15 minutes when they go
to show up to vote this bill would keep
them out if they want to register and
vote on the same day these are honest
law-abiding hardworking people who have
a legitimate reason to not be carrying
around all their documents we would lose
150,000 votes to stop one case of voter
fraud in the next 80 years I don't think
that really serves the people of New
Hampshire very well lastly
representative Lynn said well if 600
people didn't come forward that's
suspicious maybe the election results
came out and the election was clearly
decided one way or the other and they
said I'm just not going to bother going
to do all that extra work because it
wouldn't have made a difference anyway
if if the decision in my town was
decided by 700 votes it's not suspicious
at all these are people who deserve the
right to vote and we should not be doing
much you be taking questions from the
committee yes sir are there questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
thank you um now I actually don't have
any more people signed up um at least
that I know of so online uh there was 13
in support 439 opposition one neutral on
the blue sheet do we have the blue
sheet somebody have the blue sheet hi
representative wheeler how are
you it's good to see
you maybe all right well well we don't
have a blue sheet so we'll figure it out
uh let's uh let's close the public
hearing on House
Bill uh jeez I'm 1569 right not 15
that's where we're on yep 1569 wo the
there's the blue sheet all right
everybody was against and one two three
four five six seven eight eight people
no seven people signed up we didn't
speak about that good to close the
public hearing on Hospital 1569 um let's
stand in recess for 10 minutes and get
our people back together how do that
work for you yeah th um little thinned
out yeah so we'll uh let me kind of tell
the committee like where my head's at
we're obviously running really behind
schedule so there's going to be no work
session this afternoon because no
um and uh yeah I I don't hear any
objections to that so the other thing is
is the staff we're getting towards the
end of the staff hours so when we get to
exec we're not going to have the ability
to send anything to OS for amendments so
if we find something during exec we're
just not going to burden our good people
at OS we'll take care of them next week
so if we find something that needs an
amendment during exec we'll recess come
back next week sign say next week what's
um okay yeah we'll figure it out
um no no no it's fine it's fine we'll
take care of it um but anyways it the
the whole the the point Remains the Same
um we're not going to ask for amendments
at this time so let's take let's take 15
minutes get everybody together and we'll
come back in and so let's
say 4 350 350 return 350 okay all right
and uh I would highly recommend the
respective groups caucus to make sure
page
all right are we all here let's do a
head count one two three four five six
seven
eight he he's probably he's in the
bathroom one two three four five six
seven eight nine all right so uh we are
crunches for time today so I apolog my
apologies to the committee obviously we
had two bills that went very long um so
what we're going to do today is we're
going to try to get through as much work
as we can as quickly as we can I'm going
to reset some bills and try to punt um
because I'm going to try to get
everybody out of here as quickly as
possible I'm going to try to get
everybody out of here in the next 30
minutes um so just as an FYI so if
things look like they're going to go
long if there's actual genuine debate
you'll probably just see me recess and
move on um and we'll take that up in a
week or two um when uh because what we
have left is I should say I'm reopening
our executive session um what we have
left we have one bill hearing left yay
um and then so when we meet next it'll
be that one
bill a big old exec the exec of all
execs uh and then work session um all
right so let's start her out um let's
open up
the uh house election law hearing on
cacr 26 relating to election reform and
about reconciliation providing the
requirements for election shall include
provisions and penalties in regard to B
reconciliation access retention polling
location limits poll workers allowance
of registered voters for post selection
ballot viewing ballot lot and V voting
document viewing and scanning and
recording photographically during
citizen audits woo that was a fun one um
we are now on discussion of the bill we
have a motion from representative Lane
representative Lane what is your motion
I motion to itl C
rr26 second okay uh there's a motion
from representative Lane for inexpedient
to legislate representative Ward seconds
is there any discussion on cacr
26 seeing none U Madam clerk when you
are ready please call the
role representative bone
yes pom O'Brien yes representative qua
yes thank you representative inberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood
yes Osbourne yes representative
kutab representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
HR yes representative Hamlet
yes representative
Palmer representative Bay
yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative Rapter
chairman Barry shair votes yes are we
missing a member today um no no sorry I
apologize um yes all right so with that
uh cacr 26 will be reported out as
inexpedient to legislate on a vote of 20
to zero representative Lane who will be
responsible for the committee report
hold
on okay can I get back to you on that uh
yeah it's
fine um all right next up can we put
that on consent please oh uh yeah sorry
I just kind of assume 20 it's goes on
consent is there any objection to being
on consent hearing none it's going on
the consent
calendar
all
right I don't like things going trust me
consent is my default
uh I have I have begged you please don't
write a report please don't take it off
consent um anyways let's go to the next
one um we're going to we're we're
bouncing around here so we're going to
open up the a closing executive session
on House Bill cacr 26 on the consent
cend going to open up the house the the
executive session on House Bill
1136 relative to requiring a
Reconciliation of votes cast and under
votes with the total of ballots cast
representative Lane is recognized for a
motion uh I uh move that we um itl uh HB
1136 there's been a motion of legis
slate representative bom seconds is
there any discussion on the bill hearing
none when Madame clerk is ready she
shall call the role on the motion of
1136 representative Bo yes
Brian yes representative qua yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry representative wood
yes yes representative katab yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative HR yes
representative Hamet yes representative
Palmer yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan representative
Grill yes representative Howard yes
representative Raptor yesman Barry chair
uh the chair votes yes and with that the
um motion of inexpedient to legislate
carries on House Bill 1136 by a motion
of 22 to Z is there any objection to the
bill being placed on consent calendar
hearing none the the house bill 1136
will be placed on the consent calendar
is inexpedient to legislate
representative Lane you'll be
responsible for getting me the um minor
uh the majority report when whichever
one of your members wishes to do so um
going to close the executive session on
house bow 1136 and going to open up the
executive session on House Bill excuse
me next one up uh
1092 um creating a period for the
placing of and removal of political
advertising on public property um for
this one representative katab is
recognized for a
motion Mr chairman I move itl motion of
inexpedient to legis late is there a
second representative anenberg seconds
is there any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate all right there's no
discussion on the motion of any
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1092 so when the Madame clerk is ready
she shall call the role did cat you
seconded
Arenberg Arenberg arber I it makes you
feel better I I change it up every time
I say it so like half 50% of the time
I'm right every time representative Bo
yes representative Pome O'Brien yes
Ankerberg representative Burnham
yes representative
wary representative wood yes
representative
Osborne representative C to yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward representative HR yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Palmer representative Bay yes
representative Brennan
yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard
no representative
ra that is 19 to1 any objection to
consent calendar
hearing none uh House Bill 1092 will be
reported out of committees in expens to
legisl on a vote of 19 to1 and placed on
the Consin calendar representative katab
are you comfortable writing the
report thank you um okay with that I'm
going to close the executive session on
House Bill
um and I'm thinking that is the end of
the period of cooperation so
uh
just just I just have that feeling um so
let's start off with um actually no wa
we might got one more on us um uh let's
open up the house bill uh open up the
executive session on House Bill
1126 uh relative to C request for
absentee ballot information I will recu
the uh do the dubious opportunity to
recognize myself for a motion of a to
pass is there a
second okay I heard a second
representative
uh Arham akber GNA second us uh and with
that I'd like to make a secondary motion
um I do have an amendment that I
distributed if nobody has if needs more
copies of it you should already have it
um but I'd like to make a second motion
so I'm going to move um ought to pass
2024-25 1126 and I would appreciate a
second from someone representative we
seconds um does everyone have a copy of
the bill I did distribute them but I
have
extra can some can we pin two copies
down um can we send two copies down to
Representatives Brennan and rafter um
copies I have plenty of copies I even
had to make five extra
so really really got really got big on
the spending there with five extra
sheets of
paper Okay as everybody has it now um so
uh I I don't want to belb this I am
trying to move quickly but if you have
questions I'm happy to answer them um
the I basically took what I heard during
the hearings as
concerns um and addressed them so the
first concern was um the secretary
States wanted to make sure that it was
uh ballots um the ballots cast not
ballots uh
uh the not ballots I I can't remember
what I said before but it was inaccurate
it was like
requested um the type of the election
the appity ballot was was oh there's a
typo in here all right well never mind
we're going to recess the hearing
because there's a typo um was cast they
missed a
uh they missed a which all right so
anyways all right well never mind
there's a typo in the amendment so with
that I'm going to recess
1192 um let me go back to this 1126
excuse me
so we're going to re I'm going to recess
that and we'll try again but anyways if
you look at the amendment uh you can
take a look at what I'm trying to do and
then I'll fix the typos and come back
next time okay all right so we're going
to we're going to recess
1126 and go back to my sheet here okay
scratch that off all right let's go to a
fun one um let's open up the executive
session on House Bill 1099 uh relative
to partisan School District
elections um
uh representative B is recognized for a
motion
Mo um is there a
second representative Burnham second so
their discussion on the
bill yes just quickly I'm I'm in the
past I've done similar bills I think
School District laws should be the same
as Town laws and whether or not anybody
does this or not it's to make it
consistent so some town wants to do it
let the school district also follow you
know for making it bipartisan and you
know City elections are already partisan
I mean even though they're not
designated at such but just just to make
the law consistent with town thank you
further discussion on the bill um
believe representative Brennan had her
hand up so I try to alternate so thank
you um I wonder if those in favor of
this bill uh have any concerns about the
method by which um you would go about in
engaging in a partisan School Board
election if I remember correctly and I
don't have the bill in front of me I
have not flip to that page yet because
I'm a little bit surprised um by the
ought to pass motion
um if I remember correctly this is a
caucus process that would have to
happen um prior to the
election it would involve multiple
stages um and really complicate the
process
for
voters in a
town
additionally um Municipal elections are
generally
nonpartisan in
most they are nonpartisan they do not
show what party registration a candidate
is and that is by Design to make sure
that you have Community
representation for
everyone in doing so for a school board
making that partisan you contributing
potentially to increased division in a
community
also during testimony I asked the
question if we would then be if the next
step would be requiring uh student
registrations to show party affiliation
to make sure that there was balanced
representation on the school board for
the students because the school board is
there for the students to serve the
students and so I'm very concerned about
this and and I wonder if you share any
of my concerns
concerns further questions on the bill
um represent yeah just to follow up on
that it's it's only if the candidate
wants to the candidate even if they
don't make it through the caucus they
can still register as an independent so
it doesn't really change anything
candidates don't have to and like we
heard in the past and the town ones no
town has done it since 79 so my thing is
just let's make the law
consistent of hammer you
recognized thank you you know I think
this should be left to the cities and
towns to decide for instance Manchester
City Charter has a provision for all
School Board elections to be nonpartisan
and this would require a charter
Amendment wouldn't
it enabling it's enabling it's not
requiring enabling it's enabling it's
very similar to um I mean it's identical
to uh town city or town elections which
allow for partisan Manchester actually
used to have a partisan ballot one fact
um I'll app Pine on this one real fast
I'm going to vote in favor of this um
because it's going I actually think it
will do the thing that nobody really
wants to say out loud which is increase
turnout in the town elections most of
the voters do not know who the
candidates are that's why we have a
party preference on a ballot is to give
voters a framework of this candidate
generally agrees with this set of ideals
um and that is how we have to understand
the reality is that's probably how 80 to
85% of Voters in the state make their
decision and while we may not all love
that um that is just a fact the town and
City elections are honestly 15% turnouts
kind of embarrassing um they're not I I
I love it when they we hear the
arguments of oh the school board
represents the town no the school board
represents 50 50% % of 15% so the school
board represents like 7.5% of the voters
at best um it's actually a very very
tiny minority because the turnout's so
low so anything that we can do that
increases turnout in these elections
will actually get a more representative
body on the board um and by giving
voters
a an option if the if the town and the
school board wants to do it they don't
even have to do it but if they want to
do it then they can enact this option
and they might my guess is if the
ballots became partisan openly I should
say openly partisan because in
Manchester we have nonpartisan elections
and we all know it's a joke we all know
who the Republican is and by the way
they spend a million dollars so it's not
like and they they use the party mailers
and stuff like that so it's not like
it's not known but it's it's I I
understand the opposition we're just
bringing in the law in line with the
town select boards and the municipal
boards and I think you'll see increased
voter turnout and I think as voter turns
out you'll actually get boards that
representative of it because you've got
you know you've got it's very easy to go
through the list of school boards across
the state and find members on the school
board that you wonder how did this
person get elected and then you remember
from this town and you remember oh yeah
it's a 15% turnout election so it's
really not even close to representative
of the Town um and I've grinded this act
before not about partisan elections in
school district boards or town Town
meetings I've grinded the acts before of
our Municipal elections our really low
turnout and the irony is the
overwhelming vast majority of government
that you interact with on a daily basis
is your town government the I it's I'm
I'm going to end my rant here but it it
is it's like stunning to me that the
presidential election has the highest
turnout when that has actually the least
effect on people and the election that
has the least turnout is the one that
actually like runs people into
bankruptcy so I my goal on voting for
this it's enabling legislation
my goal is of a town ad dosis I would
put money down that the election would
then see an increased turnout which has
been a longterm goal of mine for these
Town elections so that that's the end of
my rant uh I'm happy anybody else who
wants to tell me I'm wrong that's cool
representative
Bay tell me wrong thank you chairman
Barry it's always en enlightening to
year um the to to the point of uh they
don't know who the candidate is isn't
that the point of campaigning I know
that when I ran nobody knew who I was
and I campaigned the heck out of it uh
but um uh my other point is with with
regard to making the laws the same so
there's already an enabling um uh law to
um or enabling statute to for for Town
um elections to be partisan but I
believe if I mean you can correct me if
I'm wrong but uh during the hearing when
it was asked how many uh towns have
taken advantage of it I believe there
was none so uh to the point of making
the laws the same you can also do it the
other way and um repeal that one so that
there there's no
enabling member is more than welcome to
bring forward Amendment if we weren't
going to vote on it today um
representative K uh PR O'Brien thank you
for allowing me time to rant because I
have a rant that you overlooked me
numerous times but okay but you know I
agree with you on on nearly everything
you said so that takes the sting out of
my rant I have really just a little bit
to say uh I have been a member of the
library Board of Trustees numerous times
and you'd think it was mostly a gential
event and for the most part that's
absolutely absolutely true we are we did
not have a lot of partisan divide but
sometimes there was some but that was
very rare I think that this would help
voters understand more about who they're
voting for and also understand what the
situation is if there is no um balance
okay because I think a lot of people
assume balance when there's
nonpartisanship and it's not necessarily
the case
and uh I'm seeing more and more of that
I think that we can o overcome uh the
partisan nature of some of these things
with the same sort of attitudes that we
have here in this partisan body where we
are polite to each other as as is POS
every time it's possible um and then
there was another point I was going to
make it was kind of important and I
forgot it so all right thank you further
discussion on the bill the motion of
ought to pass represent Brennan
recognize thank you
um I respectfully disagree with my
colleague who seems to think that um
engaging in partisan elections will
bring together
communities um and not further divide
them because when I hear from my
constituents they're tired of the
division that happens with
partisanship they want people to work
together
and that is the basis for nonpartisan
elections it is working together to
serve the community and the people that
you're neighbors with um as my colleague
representative Bay pointed out there are
zero towns that have enabled the
partisan elections for municipal uh
offices this is
harmful to students we we heard that
testimony from uh Barrett Christina that
this would not be in the best interest
of students and that our nonpartisan
elections serve the students the best
and if we are inserting
hyperarc elections it would only
contribute to more divisive rhetoric
coming at the local
level this is not a good thing we really
really need to avoid
enabling partisan elections for school
boards okay and with that the
clerk okay y representative PR thank you
I I did remember what I wanted to say um
I would feel differently about this if I
could see more uh accurate reporting on
what the opinions were of people that
were running for these boards but I I
feel sometimes in the last you know few
years or so there's been some
obfuscation on that I just want more
information for people people in these
elections I think that would increase
turnout I think this would be a good
thing thank you um nobody's going to
change their mind on this so we're going
to call the vote um clerk will call the
role on the motion of ought to pass on
House Bill 1099 representative om
yes representative prom O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne representative
cutab representative Lane no
Representative no Representative hamr no
representative Hamet no representative
Palmer representative Bay no
representative Brennan
no representative Howard no
Representative rter no chairman Barry
chair yes with that the motion of ought
to pass fails on a vote of 10 to 10
representative Lane is recognized for a
motion I make a motion for inexpedient
to legislate is there's a motion V speed
to legislate is it seconded
representative Bron seconds is there any
discussion on the bill hearing on the
motion hearing none the clerk will call
the role on the motion of inexpedient to
1099 representative Bo
no representative Pome O'Brien no
representative qua no representative
Ankerberg
no representative Burnham no
Representative warry no representative
wood no representative Osborne no
representative
cutab representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
hamr yes representative Hamlet yes
representative
Palmer representative Bay representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard representative
rter repres uh chairman Barry shair
votes no I always had to think about it
because they get the motion yes yes yes
no um with that the motion of in speech
to legislate fails House Bill 1099 will
be reported out will be reported out of
committee without recommendation um
representative bone will be on the
majority report this is the the OTP
report we call it the majority report um
and representative Lane you will get me
somebody for the quote Minority Report
which is not really the Minority Report
because it's 1010 but uh okay with that
we're going to close the executive
session House Bill 1099 we're actually
getting towards the we got two more here
we're going to vote on today um going to
open up the executive session on House
Bill
1149 um relative to domicile residency
voter registration investigation of
voter verification letters relative to
the terms resident inhabitant residence
and
residency um on House Bill
1149 um representative wary is
recognized for a
motion for itl pleas there's a motion of
V speeding to legislate on House Bill
1149 is there a second I second that
representative P O'Brien second says
there any discussion on the motion of
any speed to legislate on House Bill
1149 hearing none when the when Madam
role representa yes representative
O'Brien yes representative quaale yes
representative
Ankerberg representative Burnham yes
wary no representative Ward no
representative Hammer no representative
Hamlet no representative uh Palmer
no representative Bay no representative
Brennan no representative Grill no
representative Howard no representative
RoR no uh chairman Barry chair votes yes
um with that the motion of inexpedient
to legislate fails um representative
Lanes recognized for a motion I move out
to pass
second representative Bay Bales are out
the second um there discussion on the of
a to pass on House Bill
1149 seeing none Madam clerk is ready
call the rooll representative fo no
represent O'Brien
no no representative
inberg representative Burnham no
Representative warry no representative
wood no representative Osborne
Representative cutab no representative
Lane yes yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamet yes representative
Palmer representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative Raptor yes uh
chairman Barry chair votes no um and
with that the motion of ought to pass on
house 1149 fails uh the house B 1149
will be reported out of committee
without recommendation um representative
we will responsible for the quote
unquote majority U no actually excuse me
representative weary is responsible for
the Minority Report and representative
Lane will get me the name for the
majority report excuse me um that I'm
going to close the executive session on
House Bill 1149 going to open up the
executive session House Bill 1119
relative to absentee ballots going to
recognize representative prudom O'Brien
for a
motion I move that we
um we amend go yeah yeah just move move
it OTP OTP yeah and then qu will likely
second that yes correct representative
qua uh humbly seconds that I'm psychic
um and now representative kpo I believe
you'd like to make another motion I
would like to move to amend okay we have
a motion for Amendment do you have the
amendment number in the
is
see it yeah you you thank you Ralph um
0767 H so uh representative PM O'Brien
moves Amendment 202
24767 H is there a second yes I second
it representative quaale bails her out
um with that we are in discussion on
Amendment 2024
07678 is there discussion on the
amendment yes thank you uh for those of
who those of us who are really well
organized and have the original bill in
front of them we're looking at page two
line 31 where it simply says and either
check one which is not really applicable
if we change it to give only one option
and that option is I would otherwise
vote in person but I have concerns for
my safety traveling in the storm when
that's the case we no longer need and
either check one as we previously did so
that simply struck out and you can see
that on page two line two and then I
would otherwise vote in person but I
have concerns for my safety traveling in
the storm is now on line
seven Is there further discussion on the
amendment yes representative
Lane I have a question and I don't
remember who it was during the testimony
um they brought up that under 657 colon
one where we set out in the statute what
the reasons are um have the two that we
just deleted um but now the form doesn't
match the
statute
so I was just curious why we didn't
6572 that's I'm frantically Googling
hold
on you'll Google all right
657 and then you said Roman
numeral and you're looking at two and
what were you looking to be changed well
B it says now that that's a reason it
says and we just deleted it off the form
so I I'm curious as to whether we need
them for adults because it's under the I
I'm talking out loud so anybody feels
feel free to jump in here um so
6571 Roman numeral 2 when the national
weather service has issued a winter
storm warning blizzard warning or ice
storm warning for election day
applicable to the city town or
unincorporated
Place B says a person who cares for
children or infirm adults who reasonably
anticipates that school childcare or
adult care will be canceled who
otherwise would have voted in person but
will be deterred from voting by the need
to care for children or informed adults
shall be considered shall be considered
absent for the purpos of this chapter
and may vote absentee on the day
immediately prior to the election so the
amendment Mr chairman I might be able to
shed some light on that please do um the
excuse for having of children or an
infirm adult to care for is already
covered early in uh
6571 as uh being construed as employment
so it's covered under the employment uh
excuse earlier in that section and so in
the winter weather portion of the excuse
uh it's redundant and that is how they
did it when they modified the uh
affidavit envelope last year sometime I
think to the weeds uh representative
Lane does this uh does this Abate your
concerns uh yes thank you representative
quy okay with that further discussion on
the
amendment seeing no further discussion
The Madam clerk when you're ready please
call the role for the motion of adopting
Amendment
2024-25
B
yes representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative quae
yes representative Ankerberg
yes yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne yes Representative kutab
Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative hamr
yes what
yes representative Palmer yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative
Howard
yes representative rafter chairman Barry
chair votes yes and with that the
amendment carries 11 I'm sorry 19 to1 um
representative PR o' Brian is now
recognized for a new
motion I move to uh
otpa HB 11119 repres restive f m Brian
moves ought to pass this amendment with
Amendment 202
24-7 67h to House Bill 1119
representative qua I believe is going to
second I do second that motion okay
excellent um with that is there
discussion on the bill representative
Lane is recognized we're on the
discussion of the bill as the amended on
on the motion about to pass as submitted
thank you um because the amendment
addressed the issues that we raised in
the hearing I'm going to vote ought to
pass to pass amended so just want yeah
representative katab is
recognized I will be voting against this
uh for a couple reasons one I believe
section 112 of Mason's manual states
that we should not legislate debate or
discuss a matter um that's awaiting
adjudication by before a Judicial
tribunal and with the Dan Richards case
I think that we're currently awaiting uh
decision on that and I think the
justices were pretty clear there that
it wasn't permissive legislative
judgment to exceed the authority of the
Constitution the Constitution gave us
two reasons for absentee voting and
those two reasons were if you were going
to be absent from the town or by reason
of disability and they were also pretty
clear that if that list was not meant to
just be exclusive that it would have
been superus to put those two reasons so
for that reason I think they've kind of
indicated even that they're going to
rule in favor in that so I just I don't
see a reason to put something out there
that we know is going to be found
unconstitutional so thank
you is that to toss out your independent
redistricting since you're soon over the
M sorry I had to make the joke it was an
in the week joke um further discussion
on the bill as amended um hearing none
the clerk will call Madam cler will call
the role when she's ready on we are on
the motion of a to pass as amended on uh
with Amendment 2024 -07 67h to House
Bill
1119 representative Bo yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qualey yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
Representative kutab no representative
Lane yes representative
W representative Hammer yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Palmer representative Bay yes
representative
Brennan representative Grill yes
Howard representative rter yes chairman
Barry the chair votes yes with that the
motion of V pass is amended on House
Bill
1119 uh carries on a vote of 19 to1 is
there any objection to this bill being
calendar okay you will be responsible
for a minority report then
um okay with that uh and representative
pum O'Brien will be responsible for the
majority report um okay so it's it's
4:30 our great staff have entertained us
long enough I'm going to recess the rest
of the bill so excuse me while we do the
world's fastest reset I'm closing the
executive session on House Bill 11:19 uh
so I'm going to recess a bunch of bills
um and then I'm going to recess our
working session so get ready for the
fastest gel of the West all right I'm
going to open up house uh the exec s
House Bill 118 uh
1085 um relative to public inspection of
absente ballots I'm now going to recess
House Bill the exec session on House
Bill 1085 going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 1134 relative to
inventory controls for paper ballots and
I'm going to recess the executive
session on House Bill
1134 going to open up the executive
1157 um relative to over um to to over
voted under voted ballots and I will be
immediately recessing House Bill
1157 going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
1348 relative to polling places at which
total ballots in in which at which total
ballots ballot counts exceed the total
number of registered voters and I will
immediately recess House Bill
1148 uh and finally I will open up House
Bill 11 the executive sessional Hospital
11 1381 uh relative to required training
on Election procedures and I will recess
House Bill 1381 that concludes our
executive session for the day I will now
open up our working sessions on
bills oh my goodness it's here
14276 House Bill excuse me I'm finding
the paper uh house bills 1091 and what
was the last one and
113 and 11:33 and we will immediately
recess thank you guys this concludes our
business for today sorry for the gabble
gabble gabble gabble but it's time to go
specific